GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY AND
WELCOME HERE TO THE BEAUTIFUL
CITY OF ONE OF PARK WHICH
IS PART OF MY DISTRICT I AM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA REPRESENTING NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY THOUGH CITIES
INCLUDE ALL OF FULLER TEN POINT
A PARK WEST ANAHEIM STANTON
APAMA IN CYPRESS BUT -- WE ARE
NOT ONLY TALKING ABOUT NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY TODAY WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ORANGE COUNTY
AND CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS I
AM PLEASED TO BE THE CHAIR
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON ORANGE COUNTY CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND THIS IS OUR
FIRST HEARING IN THE DISTRICT
OF FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO -- FOLLOW HOW
ARE HEARINGS AT THE STATE
GOAL JUST GIVE YOU A FEW --
IN A LITTLE BIT OF INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THEY USUALLY RUN WE
HAVE MEMBERS HERE THAT WILL
GIVE OPENING REMARKS AFTER I
DO AND YOU'LL SEE OTHER MEMBERS
COME IN AS THEY MAY GET IN
THE STATE MANY TIMES WE HAVE
MULTIPLE HEARINGS GOING ON AT
THE SAME TIME SO IT IN IN THAT
CASE YOU'LL SEE MEMBERS COMING
IN AND OUT AS YOU WILL SEE
SOME OF THE MEMBERS HERE -- WE
ALSO HAVE A VERY INFLUENTIAL
AND NOTABLE LEADERS OF THE
COMMUNITY HERE THROUGHOUT AS
ORANGE COUNTY AN AS WE GET OUR
LIST I WILL MAKE SURE YOU KNOW
WHO THEY ARE BECAUSE I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN IT ISN'T ALWAYS
THE FORMAL CONVERSATIONS IT'S
THE INFORMAL CONVERSATIONS AND
ALSO -- THE MEETING SO WE HAD
A LITTLE POP UP MEETING OVER
THERE WITH THE -- NORTH SPA AND
-- JUST SO YOU KNOW AS WE GO
THROUGH OLD OF TRY TO CLARIFY
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE BEAT
IN THE COMMUNITY OF HOUSING
AS SOMETIMES EACH OF OUR
INSTITUTION SPEAK A DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
ARE AN EDUCATION YOU MIGHT HEAR
THINGS LIKE PLA'S OR E. L. D.
AND -- SO JUST SO YOU KNOW NOR
SPAHN MEANS AS SPOT AREA WHICH
IS SERVICE PROVIDER AREA SO
WITH THAT BEING SAID -- WE HAVE
AS PART OF OUR COMMITTEE TODAY
WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL BRO
AND HE WILL GIVE COMMENTS AND
WE CURRENTLY WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TIE THEIR DEEP AND WE
WILL HAVE OTHER MEMBERS AS I
SAID AS THEY COME AND THEY WILL
GIVE THEIR OPENING REMARKS BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT AS A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I SOUGHT TO WORK WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP TO BE SELECT IS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
WITH THAT THE PRIMARY REASON
IS SO THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY NOT
ONLY OPPORTUNITIES STRENGTH IN
ONGOING WORKING RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN ADVOCATES NONPROFITS
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AS WELL
AS LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT
TO COMBAT ORANGE COUNTY'S COM
CHRONIC HOMELESS POPULATION
THAT BEING SAID WHAT WE DO IN
HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY IS NOT
ONLY FOCUSED ON ORANGE COUNTY
AS WE KNOW MANY MANY IF NOT ALL
COUNTIES IN ORANGE COUNTY ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE SAME ISSUES
ORANGE COUNTY HAS CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS OR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
HOMELESS FOR A YEAR OR MORE OR
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE AT LEAST
FOUR EPISODES OF HOMELESSNESS
AND THE PAST THREE YEARS
THE THESE CHAIRS ARE
REALLY LIKE A WHILE -- SO
AND I USED TO BE ON FULLER TO
THE CITY COUNCIL SO I HAD A
CHAIR THAT YOU CAN MOVE UP AND
DOWN BUT OTHERWISE I'LL BE LIKE
THAT SO IN KILEY COMES WE NEED
TO GET HER A LITTLE BOX TO SIT
ON TO IT AM I NOW THE GOAL IS
TO FOCUS ON THE PROGRESS OF
THE REGION HAS MADE OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND WHAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND THE
ROLE OF EACH ONE OF US AND HOW
WE DO THAT AS MANY OF YOU WHO
KNOW WHO MAY BE IN OUR AUDIENCE
WHO ARE WORKING TIRELESSLY
ON THIS ISSUE THIS IS NOT ONE
SIMPLE FIX IT'S NOT EASY IT'S
COMPLEX AND OF WHAT I WILL
ABSOLUTELY NOT EVEN TAKE AS A
SOLUTION IS LET'S BUS EVERYBODY
OUT TO SAMBAR TO DO YOU KNOW
OR TO THE DESERT BECAUSE IT'S
CHEAPER OVER THERE AND THEY
CAN ALL DEAL WITH THAT SEE
THAT'S NOT A SOLUTION -- BUT TO
SOLVE THIS IT TAKES DEDICATION
IT TAKES COLLABORATION AND
IT ALSO TAKES THOSE WHO ARE
WILLING TO DO THE HARD WORK
TO REMEMBER WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THOSE AND NAY AND THEM
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
SO THAT BEING SAID I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE MY COLLEAGUES
TO MAKE OPENING COMMENTS
INTERVIEWS YOURSELF AND YOUR
AREA YOUR FROM AND WILL START
RIGHT HERE WITH THE SEVEN
MEMBER BILL BRO WELL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
-- ONE FOR CONVENING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY --
PROUD TO BE A MEMBER OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON A THANK TO
CITY BOY IN A PARK FOR HOSTING
US TODAY THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING OUT TO HEAR FROM OUR
PANELISTS TO ADDRESS THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF OUR TIME
-- I REPRESENT SOUTH COUNTY
BASICALLY LOOK INTO HILLS
DOWN TO THE SOUND KILLER SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BORDER AND FROM
THE BEACH TO THE SIDE OF THAT
MOUNTAIN SO -- MY COMMITTEES
OF DATA POINT AND SACRAMENTO
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR SITES STATE
SITES COUNTY LAND -- TO HAVE
FUTURE FACILITIES -- TO HELP
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A NEW
DEBATE OF THE TERM HOMELESS
-- GIVEN THE ECONOMY IT'S NOT
THE FACT WHERE SOMEONE LOST
THEIR JOB AND THEY CAN AFFORD
LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY WE'VE
GOT SOME SERIOUSLY MENTALLY
ILL PEOPLE IN THESE POPULATIONS
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE WITH DRUG
AND ALCOHOL ABUSE AND WE'VE
GOTTEN SOME PEOPLE THAT --
HAVE A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND SO
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO IDENTIFY THESE INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
YOU KNOW IN MY COMMUNITY THERE
SHOWING UP AT THE ART MISSION
HOSPITAL AND THAT'S NOT GOOD
FOR OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
AND IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
PATIENT BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
HISTORY OF THESE PEOPLE THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT MEDICATIONS
ARE ON AND IT JUST EXACERBATES
THE PROBLEM SO PROUD TO BE A
PART OF THIS THANK YOU AGAIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HOSTING
THIS HEARING AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM OUR PALS
GOOD MORNING I AND THIS IS
ON GOOD MORNING I AM ASSEMBLY
ONE CUTTING YOU NORRIS AND I
REPRESENT THE SEVENTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH IS A
JUST NORTH OF MISTER BURROUGHS
ALONG WITH SO MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN A NEW SO MANY
SO MANY CITIZENS ALL ACROSS
ORANGE COUNTY ALL ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DRESSING
ORANGE COUNTY'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IS ONE OF MY TOP
PRIORITIES LAST NEEDS TONIGHT
TOMORROW NIGHT ALMOST SEVEN
THOUSAND MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WILL FIND THEMSELVES WITHOUT
A PLACE TO SLEEP RIGHT HERE
IN ORANGE COUNTY RIGHT ON OUR
DOORSTEP THAT IS SIMPLY ON
EXCESSIVE UNACCEPTABLE AND I
THINK WE AGREE ACROSS DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES ACROSS POLITICAL
PARTIES THAT WE NEED TO COME
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS
IN OUR COMMUNITY I THINK THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT ALL HANDS
ARE ON DECK WORKING REALLY
HARD HERE ARE FEDERAL OFFICIALS
STATE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND TOGETHER
WE ARE BUILDING A SYSTEM
OF CARE HERE ACROSS ORANGE
COUNTY AND AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I ALSO CHAIR THE
ASSEMBLIES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
TO I APPROACH THIS WITH
THREE KEY OBJECTIVES NUMBER
ONE ENSURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS SPENDING MONEY
ADDITIONALLY AND EFFECTIVELY
NUMBER TWO YOU ENSURE THAT
ORANGE COUNTY IS GETTING OUR
FAIR SHARE OF RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THIS AND NUMBER THREE
THAT THOSE RESOURCES ARE BEING
ALLOCATED TO PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY WORK SUE THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA FOR CAN
BE NICE AND TO ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS FOR JOINING US I
LOOK REALLY FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM OUR PANELISTS TODAY AND
TO UNDERSTANDING HOW WE AS
STATE LAWMAKERS CAN BRING REAL
SOLUTIONS ONLINE CAN GET PEOPLE
OFF THE STREETS AND INTO HOMES
AND WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
HEAL OUR COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
OF GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TYLER DE UP AND I REPRESENT
THE SEVENTY SECOND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES -- THE
NORTHERN PORTION OF HUNTINGTON
BEACH ABOUT VALLEY GUARDING
GROW WESTMINSTER LOS ALAMEDA
LOSE ROSS MORE IN -- MIDWAY
CITY AND ALSO SU BEACH -- LIKE
MY COLLEAGUES WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE -- OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN ORANGE COUNTY I'LL FIND
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE LONG TERM STATE
FOR THE COUNTY TO BE IN OUR
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE -- NOT
HAPPY WHEN THE SEA OF PEOPLE
URINATING ON THE STREET A
SLEEPING ON THE STREET WHEN
WE HAVE -- A CAMPAIGN AND
THEY FIND THAT IN WHO MAIN
AND UNACCEPTABLE OF FOR
ORANGE COUNTY AND -- I'M GLAD
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA IS CALLING THIS MEETING
TO GIVE ALL OF US FROM THE
ORANGE COUNTY DELEGATIONS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM LOCAL
EXPERT IS BECAUSE WHATEVER IT
IS THAT SACRAMENTO -- PASS OR
DICTATE IT IS THE NONPROFIT IT
IS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HAVE
TO CARRY THEM OUT AND WE WANT
TO HEAR FROM YOU SO THAT YOU
GIVE US THE FEEDBACK ON ON
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU NEED WHAT
KIND OF TOOL THAT YOU NEED FROM
SACRAMENTO TO HELP YOU DO YOUR
JOB I REALLY APPRECIATE I SEE
A LOT NONPROFIT YOUR TODAY'S
ALSO REPRESENTATIVE FROM --
THE -- THAT THE COUNTY THE
COUNTY HEALTH CARE AIDES DE
CALIFORNIA -- AND ALSO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT -- PARTNER BECAUSE
A WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS IT
THAT WE CAN DO IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS
ON TO GIVE YOU ON THE OTHER
TOOL TO COMBAT THIS AT THIS
ISSUE IN A HUMANE WAY WHERE
THIS PROBLEM IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT I SHOULD CONTINUE A
PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA WE PRIDE
OURSELVES TO BE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
BUT YET WE HAVE THE LARGEST
HOMELESS POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY -- SO WITH THAT I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR CONVENING THIS MEETING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HI GOOD MORNING
I'M ASSEMBLY WOMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA AND I AM NOT FROM
ORANGE COUNTY I REPRESENT THE
FIFTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHICH BORDERS UP INTO ORANGE
COUNTY AND HERE BECAUSE WE ALL
NEED TO BE DOING SOMETHING IN
THE COUNTY FROM THE FOR THE
BIG LEARNING FROM EACH OTHER
THE MOST IMPORTANTLY THESE
INDIVIDUALS -- DO NOT KNOW
BORDER LINES ARE COUNTY LINES
AND WE SEE THEM MOVING ACROSS
THOSE LINES ON A REGULAR BASIS
OUT THERE AND SO HERE TO WORK
MY CITY OF WHAT I'M A NINE
CITY TO CITY OF BELLFLOWER
RECENTLY OR -- ENTERED INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH JUDGE CARTER'S
TRYING TO BE PROACTIVE BEFORE
THEY GET SUED HAVE A NUMBER OF
OTHER CITIES ARE STARTING TO
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION TAKING
TO HEART THAT WE ALL HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT AS INDIVIDUAL CITIES BUT
ALSO AS OF THE COLLECTIVE SO
HAPPY TO BE HERE ARE TO WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS
COUNTY LINES TO MAKE SURE
WORKING AS ONE COLLECTED
FOR THE STATE THANK YOU AND
YOU WILL SEE OTHER MEMBERS
PERHAPS COME IN I WOULD LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE BEFORE WE BEGIN
OUR FIRST TIME -- PANEL IS SOME
OF THE LOCAL ELECTED WHO ARE
JOINING US AND ALSO OR CITY
MANNERS WE HAVE RIGHT UP FRONT
HIS CITY HIT -- FROM WHERE
TO PARK -- MAYOR ART BROWN
THOSE OF YOU DON'T KNOW THIS
HE HAS SERVED IN ALL THREE
BRANCHES OF THE MILITARY AND
IS A FORMER SHERIFF AND -- IS
A PROUD MEMBER OF THE SANTA
CLAUS CLUB AND HIS WIFE ELLA
IS ALSO A LOCAL CITY -- SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER FOR SAVANNAH
SAVANNAH DISTRICT WE ALSO HAVE
FROM -- CYPRESS HERE MAYOR
STACY BERRY STACEY STAND UP
IN A DEEP IN ADDITION HER
A COLLEAGUE ON THE SUPER
SICK -- COUNSEL JOHN PETE
FROM THE PALMER WE HAVE
A MAYOR MARSHALL GOOD MEN
YOU GUYS LIKE ME -- MUSIC
HE IS A PROFESSIONAL THE OLD
MUSICIAN WHY I THINK THESE
ARE IMPORTANT THINGS FOR
PEOPLE TO KNOW I GOT TO KNOW
EACH OTHER TO CARE AND DEATH
SO HE IS A VERY ACCOMPLISHED
MUSICIAN OUT WE ALSO HAVE FROM
PLACENTIA SHE GOT WE HAVE --
MAYOR PRO TEM I'M SORRY MAYOR
ROUNDISH A SHADER SO WE HAVE
AND WE ALSO HAVE FROM PLACENTIA
THE MAYOR PRO TEM WARD SMITH
IN ADDITION I HOPE THAT YOU
LOOK AROUND AND AND IF YOU GET
A CHANCE AFTERWARD EXCHANGE
SOME CÑC OF CARDS BECAUSE
WE HAVE SOME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DEDICATED NOT JUST A YEAR OR
TWO BUT REALLY THEIR LIVES TO
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES WE HAVE
THE PRESIDENT -- FROM CYPRESS
COLLEGE JOANNA OF I'M SORRY Y.
BY FORGETTING YOUR LAST YES
I'M SORRY JOINED SHOWING AND
AGAIN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE CITY OF ONE OF PARK
ON LOOKING TOWARDS HOUSING FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS SO
AGAIN CREATIVE IDEAS THAT ARE
OUT THERE WITH PEOPLE WORKING
ON THESE TYPE OF ISSUES SO WE
ARE GOING TO BRING UP OUR FIRST
PANEL HERE AND IF YOU HAVE THE
AGENDA YOU WILL SEE THAT WE
HAVE -- I'LL LET THEM INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND BEGAN THE REMARK
SO AGAIN OUR FIRST PAN IT
PANEL IS INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND I
WANT TO UNDERLINE INNOVATIVE
OR WE COULD DO SLASH CREATIVE
BECAUSE THERE IS A NO LACK
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT US TO DO
EVERYTHING FROM JUST JUST MOVE
ON THAT'S ALL WE WANT MOVE THEM
BUT THAT CAN HAPPEN BUT TO LOOK
AT IT LONG TERM WE NEED PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE SPEAKING
SO WELCOME FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LISA ANGLE I THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND A GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY -- IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO COME DOWN AND
SEE YOUR COMMUNITY AND REALLY
LEARN ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND WHAT YOU'RE CHALLENGES ARE
I AM THE CHIEF CONSULTANT TO
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
I'VE WORKED FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR OVER A DECADE ON HOUSING
AND POLICY ISSUES AND LIKE
YOU I'VE SEEN THE HOMELESS
AND HOUSING CRISIS WORSEN OVER
TIME TO PUT IN PERSPECTIVE MORE
THAN HALF OF THE STATE RIGHT
STATES RENTER'S PAY OVER THIRTY
PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME TO
HOUSING AND TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF RENTERS PAY MORE THAN FIFTY
PERCENT TOWARDS HOUSING WHICH
MAKES THEM EXTREMELY RENT
BURDENED SIXTY NINE PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIA IS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY HOME PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ARE ON SHELTERED
ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT AND THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS -- PEOPLE ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AND THE
CHAIR TALKED ABOUT WHAT THAT
MEANS SO I'M JUST GONNA TRY AND
QUICKLY GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW
OF WHAT THE STATE'S DONE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS AROUND
HOMELESSNESS AND THEN TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE HEARING ABOUT
IN SACRAMENTO THAT COMMUNITIES
ARE DOING IT TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THE CRISIS SO FIRST -- THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED THE
STATE HOMELESS COORDINATES
CORDONING OF FINANCING COUNSEL
TO TRY TO BETTER COORDINATE
STATE RESOURCES ACROSS MULTIPLE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES ALL HAVE
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS AND
SO THE IDEA WAS TO GET THEM
TALKING TO EACH OTHER I ONE OF
THE FIRST TASKS OF THE COUNCIL
WAS TO ADOPT THEM HOUSING
FIRST AS A MODEL FOR ALL STATE
HOUSING PROGRAMS HOUSING FIRST
AS AN EVIDENCE BASED MODEL
USING HOUSING AS A TOOL AND
NOT A REWARD AND CONNECTING
PEOPLE TO PERMANENT HOUSING SO
HOUSING IS NOT CONTINGENT UPON
PARTICIPATING IN SERVICES AND
THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE MAJOR
BEST PRACTICES I THINK WE'VE
REALLY SHIFTED FEDERALLY AND
STATEWIDE TO ADOPT IN THE LAST
TEN YEARS I'M IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN -- THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A MAJOR PACKAGE OF
BILLS WHICH INCLUDED TWO NEW
FUNDING SOURCES SB TWO WHICH
IS A PERMANENT SOURCE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE FIRST
YEAR HALF OF THE FUNDS GO TO
HOMELESSNESS AND IN THE SECOND
YEAR SEVENTY PERCENT OF THOSE
FUNDS GO DIRECTLY TO LOCALS
THIS IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY
TO LOOK AT THOSE FUNDS AS A
WAY TO POTENTIALLY ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS LOCALLY WE ALSO
PASSED SB THREE WHICH WAS AT
THE HOUSING BOND WHICH INCLUDED
THREE MILLION FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS THIS
WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT THE
VOTERS AND THE LEGISLATURE
HAD PASSED A HOUSING BONDS
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX SO IT WAS
SORELY NEEDED AM WE ALSO IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN PASSED
A BILL TO ALLOW JURISDICTIONS
A CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS TO
WAIVE LOCAL LAND USE POLICIES
IN ORDER TO BUILD SHELTERS --
WE PASSED THEM AB SEVENTY FOUR
WHICH CREATED THE HOUSING FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY TARGETS
PEOPLE WHO ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS AND MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS TO TIE THEM TO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING TO
REDUCE THEIR HEALTHCARE COSTS
BECAUSE THESE FOLKS TYPICALLY
HAVE OF A HIGH COST TO THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND WE CAN
GREATLY REDUCE THAT BY GETTING
THEM INTO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND THE PROGRAM WILL
TRACK OF THE COST OF HEALTH
CARE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
TO DETERMINE HOW HOW MUCH THE
HOUSING HAS ON THERE HOW MUCH
IMPACT THE HOUSING HAS IN
THEIR HEALTHCARE COSTS -- AND
THEN IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THINGS REALLY PICKED UP IN THE
LEGISLATURE AROUND HOMELESSNESS
IN TERMS OF FUNDING -- WE THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO A PROGRAM
TO ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME IN MY
MEMORY THAT A SIGNIFICANT FUND
OF CHEN AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WENT TO THIS PURPOSE
AND IT WAS REALLY INTENDED
TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO PASSED
TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO WHICH
ALLOWS FOR STREAMLINING FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
THIS WAS MODELED AFTER AN
ORDINANCE THAT LOS ANGELES
PASSED SO IF THE DEVELOPMENT
IS A HUNDRED PERCENT AFFORDABLE
AND TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF
THE UNITS ARE RESTRICTED TO
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND THAT
DEVELOPER CAN GO IN AND GET THE
PROJECT APPROVED BY RIGHT AND
THEN -- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FROM
YOUR COMMUNITY CARRIED -- AB
FOUR FOUR EIGHT WHICH ALLOWED
FOR THE CREATION REALLY THE
REVITALIZATION OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY HOUSING TRUST FUND
TO ALLOW THE COUNTY AND CITY
COUNTY AND CITIES THAT WANTED
TO PARTICIPATE TO CREATE A
TRUST FUND AND THIS WILL HELP
THEM YOU ALL APPLY FOR AND SB
THREE FUNDS WHICH ARE GONNA
BECOME AVAILABLE NEXT YEAR
THROUGH THE LOCAL HOUSING TRUST
FUND -- TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED
ANOTHER SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO ASSIST LOCALS IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS -- IN
THE BUDGET WE STREAMLINED LOW
BARRIER NAVIGATION CENTERS
LOW BARRIER NAVIGATION CENTERS
ARE A GOOD -- THE HIGHLIGHT
AS A BEST PRACTICE THESE ARE
SHELTERS THAT ARE SERVICE
ENRICHED -- THEY MOVE PEOPLE
TO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AND PROVIDE CASE MANAGEMENT
ONSITE LOW BARRIER REFERS TO
THE FACT THAT -- BARRIERS ARE
REDUCED TO TRY TO GET PEOPLE
TO COME INDOORS SO THEY ALLOW
FOR THE PRESENCE OF PARTNERS
PETS STORAGE OF POSSESSIONS
AND PRIVACY -- THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED EVEN FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WHICH IS A STATE WIDE RENT
GOUGING CAP AND JUST BECAUSE TO
PROTECT TENANTS IN PLACE -- IT
IS A HAS A TEN YEAR SUNSET AND
-- WE PASSED -- THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED -- ESPY'S AT TWO BILLS
TO PREVENT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS
AND VAST VOUCHERS SO HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL HELP THOSE VOUCHERS
BE MORE USEFUL IN THE COMMUNITY
AM THEN WE ALSO X.
THROUGH THE -- CHAIRS BILL
EXPANDED AS THE ASH SHELTER
CRISIS ACT TO ALLOW THE COUNTY
THE ORANGE COUNTY IN THE CITY'S
ORANGE COUNTY TO WAIVE LOCAL
LAND USE POLICIES IN ORDER TO
BUILD SHELTERS MORE QUICKLY
SB FOUR FIFTY WHICH MAKES
IT EASIER FOR COMMUNITIES TO
COMFORT HOTELS AND MOTELS TO
SUPPORT OF HOUSING BY CREATING
A SEQUEL EXCEPTION SO WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE BEST PRACTICES
OR STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS THE SOLUTION TO
HOMELESSNESS IS TO GET PEOPLE
INTO HOUSING AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO THAT WE
KNOW THAT HOUSING FIRST IS
AN EFFECTIVE MODEL TO DO THAT
IT'S PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE
THEY OFTEN HAVE DISABLED DISAIT
UP YOU KNOW ADDICTION ISSUES
-- OTHER CHALLENGES TO STAYING
HOUSE AND SO BY ALLOWING THEM
TO COME INTO HOUSING FIRST AND
THEN DEAL WITH THOSE ISSUES
SECOND THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
TO COME IN -- STE HOUSING
FIRST PAIRED WITH SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WHICH IS HOUSING THAT
IS ACCOMPANIED WITH SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES IT HAS A NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT SECOND SUCCESS RATE
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE TO END HOMELESSNESS SO
A VARIETY OF COMMUNITIES HAVE
-- PAST -- LOCAL BOND MEASURES
TO FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND FOR PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING A LOS ANGELES PASSED
HHH WHICH IS ONE POINT TWO
BILLION TO FIND HOPEFULLY
TEN THOUSAND NEW SUPPORT OF
HOUSING UNITS ALAMEDA COUNTY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY EACH PASS
BOND MEASURES TO FIND HOUSING
FOR VULNERABLE LOWER INCOME
PEOPLE -- AGAIN LOW BARRIER
NAVIGATION CENTERS WERE SEEN
HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY AS WELL
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
-- THOSE ARE SHELTERS AGAIN
WITH WHERE YOU'RE REDUCING
THE BARRIERS AND ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE TO COME INDOORS SOME
JURISDICTIONS ARE SUPPLEMENTING
VASH AND SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS
SO THOSE VOUCHERS CAN BE
USED TO PAY -- RENT THE RENT
OF LOWER INCOME PEOPLE BUT
SOMETIMES THEY ARE NOT ENOUGH
IN THE MARKET SO HAD CAPS THE
FAIR MARKET RENT OR THE AMOUNT
THAT VOUCHER CAN BE USED TO
PAY SO SOME SAN DIEGO FOR
EXAMPLE IS SUBSIDIZING THOSE
-- THOSE UNITS IN THIS COULD
BE A POTENTIAL USE FOR SB TO
FUNDS WHICH ARE AGAIN A VERY
FLEXIBLE SOURCE OF FUNDING AND
LOCALS GET TO DECIDE HOW TO
SPEND THEM THOSE FUNDS JUST
A I DON'T THINK I MENTIONED
EARLIER WILL BECOME AVAILABLE
THIS YEAR ANOTHER SOLUTION THAT
SOME JURISDICTIONS ARE PURSUING
IS A PLACE BASED MODEL LOCATING
BRIDGE HOUSING IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESS HOMELESSNESS
WERE FORMALLY HOMELESS SO
COMMON MYTH IS THAT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
NOT FROM THE COMMUNITY BUT A UC
DAVIS ARE UC IRVINE STUDY FOUND
THAT SEVEN OUT OF TEN PEOPLE IN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT ARE HOMELESS
HAD LIVED IN THE COUNTY IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS THIS IS
ALSO COMMON MYTH ABOUT SAN
FRANCISCO BUT HAS BEEN FOUND
TO BE UNTRUE SOME COMMUNITIES
ARE TRYING TO LOCATE MULTIPLE
SHELTERS CLOSE TO WHERE PEOPLE
PREVIOUSLY LIVED -- SOMETIMES
IT'S BRIDGE HOUSING BRIDGE
HOUSING TYPICALLY HAS A LIMIT
ON THE STATE BUT FOCUSES ON
MOVING PEOPLE INTO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING I'M CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE STARTING
TO COLLABORATE REGIONALLY
OR SEEN THAT HERE THRILLED
THAT NORTH SPA PARTNERSHIP
THAT YOU'VE DEVELOPED TO BILL
TWO FULL SERVICE NAVIGATION
CENTERS THE FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THIS BUDGET
CYCLE THROUGH HALF REQUIRE
A REGIONAL PLAN SO THAT'S A
WAY TO SORT OF ENCOURAGE --
LOCAL -- COLLABORATION --
WERE ALSO SEEING A MOTEL AND
HOTEL CONVERSIONS WHICH ARE
ALL OPTIONAL FOR SHELTER OR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BECAUSE
THEY ARE YOUR CONFIGURED AS
A SINGLE ROOM WITH BATHROOMS
AND SOMETIMES KITCHENETTES
MOTELS CAN SOMETIMES BEEN THE
SITE OF PAST CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
SO BY CONVERTING THEM TO
SHELTERS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
THEY CAN BE TURNED INTO A
USEFUL PART OF THE COMMUNITY
SOME JURISDICTIONS ARE ALIGNING
AT THEIR HOMELESS AND HOUSING
DEPARTMENTS SO THAT THEY
HAVE A SHARED VISION BECAUSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPLY
IS A SIGNIFICANT IF NOT THE
SOLUTION TO HOMELESSNESS OTHER
JURISDICTIONS ARE CREATING
LOCAL FLEXIBLE HOUSING SUBSIDY
POLLS -- THESE POOLS ARE AND
MOST CASES ARE TARGETED AT
PEOPLE WHO ARE HIGH USERS
OF THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM SO
THEY'RE FOCUSED ACHIEVING
HOUSING STABILITY RESOURCES
FOR HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND CASE MANAGEMENT IN
LA THEY TARGETED THEIR HIGHEST
USERS OF THE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THEY USED TO BETTER
CAL DOLLARS PHILANTHROPIC
FUNDS AND LOCAL FUNDS SOME
JURISDICTIONS ARE USING THESE
FUNDS TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSE TO
FILL IN THE GAPS SO IF YOU'RE
MISSING YOUR FIRST MONTH'S
RENT IF YOU NEED A SECURITY
DEPOSIT FOCUSED AT PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM BECOMING HOMELESS
OTHERS ARE USING IT AS A
LANDLORD INCENTIVE TO RENT
TO THE LOCAL POPULATIONS BY
SETTING FUNDS ASIDE THAT CAN
BE DRAWN DOWN FOR SECURITY
DEPOSITS FURNISHINGS ANTENNA
DAMAGES SO I PUT TOGETHER JUST
SOME POSSIBLE NEXT STEPS THIS
IS CERTAINLY NOT AN EXHAUSTIVE
LIST BUT AT THE STATE SORT
OF THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN DO BETTER TO SUPPORT --
LOCAL EFFORTS -- FIRST IS THAT
CALIFORNIA FUNDS OVER TAVERN
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT
ENDING HOMELESSNESS AT SIX
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND EACH DEPARTMENT HAS A
DIFFERENT MISSION CULTURE AND
KNOWLEDGE OF HOUSING RELATED
OR HOUSING ISSUES THE CHAIR
CARRIED A BILL LAST YEAR AB
SIXTEEN TO TRYING TO LINE
THOSE -- DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AND THAT WOULD BE A WAY TO
CREATE COST EFFICIENCIES AND
TO REALLY NOT REALLY DETERMINE
KIND OF WHAT OUR -- INVESTMENT
IS AND HOW TO STREAMLINE IT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN USING
MEDICAL FUNDS TO THE FEDERAL
HOLE PERSON PILOT TO PAY FOR
SERVICES IN CASE MANAGEMENT
AND WRAP AROUND SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT
IS COMING TO AN END BUT DH
CS HAS PUT OUT A NEW CONCEPT
TO CREATE A BENEFIT AROUND
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT TO
POTENTIALLY TAKE THAT -- PLACE
OF THE WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT
AND AGAIN THIS IS A WAY TO TRY
AND PROVIDE CASE MANAGEMENT
AND SERVICES TO HOUSE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
MEDI CAL RECIPIENTS AM WE
ALSO COULD CREATE A STATEWIDE
DATA WAREHOUSE TO COORDINATE
RESOURCES AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS --
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT BEST PRACTICES TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS -- WHICH
IS A GREAT IDEA WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT SORT OF WHAT HOW
TO -- FOCUS THOSE ON THOSE
THAT ARE TRULY AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS FOR A FEW MONTHS TEND
TO HAVE A HARDER TIME GETTING
BACK INTO HOUSING BECAUSE
THEY LOSE THEIR JOB THEY HAVE
HEALTH IMPACTS AND SO WE NEED
TO THINK THIS IS A A GOOD WE
ARE SEEING AND MORE PEOPLE FALL
INTO HOMELESSNESS AS WE TRIED
TO HOUSE PEOPLE SO WE NEED TO
PUSH THESE IDEAS FOR BUT THINK
ABOUT HOW TO DO IT BEST AND
THEN FINALLY THEY -- HOMELESS
POPULATION IS POPULATION IS
AGING AS OUR OVERALL POPULATION
IS AGING RESEARCH BY MARGARET
WHO SHALL WITH YOU SEE AS AFTER
SHOWS THAT A GROWING STATEMENT
OF HOMELESS OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION OUR SENIORS SHE
FOUND THAT AMERICANS BORN IN
THE SECOND HALF OF THE BABY
BOOM NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE TO
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE HAVE AN
ELEVATED RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFETIME AND
SHE FOUND THAT SOME SENIORS HAD
NEVER EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
WILL PICK BUT WE'RE BECOMING
HOMELESS BECAUSE OF A SUDDEN
HEALTH CRISIS ARE JOB LOSS OR
A SPOUSE DYING AND MANY ARE
IN POOR HEALTH SO SENIORS ARE
REALLY ACUTELY -- IMPACTED BY
THE HOUSING CRISIS AMONG THE
RENTER'S AGE FIFTY YEAR OVER
THIRTY PERCENT SPEND MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME AND RENT
AND ARE CONSIDERED -- SEVERELY
HOUSING BURDENED SO WE NEED
TO THINK THERE'S STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS THIS GROWING SENIOR
HOMELESS POPULATION AND THAT'S
MY PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU EARLY SIR BEFORE WE TAKE
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
UP HERE AND ALL WE'LL JUST DO
THAT INDIVIDUALLY AS EACH POUND
SPEAKS I THINK AND I DO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE WE HAVE SO CITY
MANAGERS AND FOR MANY OF YOU
WHO LOOK AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND AND EVERYTHING THEY DO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE
DON'T ALWAYS REALIZE IS THAT
CITY MANAGERS AND -- CITIES
WHERE -- YOUR CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE NOT FULL TIME
WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH EVERY
CITY OTHER THAN MAYBE A LOS
ANGELES AND SOME OF THE MAJOR
CITIES THE CITY MANAGER'S ARE
NOT ONLY AS INVESTED BUT PLAY
A HUGE ROLE AND HOW POLICY AND
EVERYTHING FROM ORDINANCES
ANYTHING THAT APPEARS ON AGENDA
CALMS -- MAIN MANY TIMES FROM
THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS -- CITY
MANAGER SO WE HAVE HERE WITH
US JIM VANDERPOOL REPRESENTING
-- BUT A PARK WE HAVE LAURA
MURRAY REPRESENTING LOW PAMA
WE HAVE CAN DO DELMER CITY
MANAGER FULLER TEN AND WE HAVE
-- CHRIS IS A PAPA REPRESENTING
ANAHEIM AND THIS IS A BIG DEAL
AND I SAY THAT THEY'RE KIND OF
LIKE JUST BARELY RAISING THEIR
HAND BUT THE REASON IS TO RUN A
CITY IS A HUGE IN THAT TIME AND
THEY HAVE EVERYTHING LITERALLY
FROM FIRES THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
FULLER TEN ACROSS THE STATE AND
THAT THEY'RE CHOOSING TO SPEND
ONE OR TWO HOURS WITH THIS IS
A REALLY MEANINGFUL BECAUSE I
THINK THAT -- IT SHOWS THERE
-- DEDICATION WE ALSO HAVE --
I'M SIR WE HAVE AARON FRANCE
FROM THE CITY OF ONE OF PARK
BUT IF YOU ARE ALSO WORKING
FOR A CITY OR INVOLVED IN THE
GOVERNMENT HOUSING POLICY WHY
DON'T YOU JUST STAND UP SO WE
KIND OF KNOW WHO WERE WHO'S
OUT THERE YOU'RE EITHER WORKING
FOR THE COUNTY YOU'RE WORKING
FOR THE STATE YOUR WORKING FOR
A CITY THERE SOMEBODY RAISING
HER HAND BACK THERE -- TOBY
STAND UP IT'S OKAY HEY LOOK
WE WANT TO SEE YOU THERE WE
GO SO THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
TAKE ALL THE STUFF THAT PEOPLE
LIKE A SAY THAT IT YOU KNOW
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS AND THEN
THEY SIT THERE AND THEY HAVE
TO IMPLEMENT SOMETIMES IT'S
A GOOD IDEA AND SOMETIMES IS
LIKE WHO THE HECK ARE THESE
PEOPLE TELLING US TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE PEOPLE HERE -- WITHOUT
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBER FOR -- LISA ANGLE
THANKS FOR BEING HERE WITH
US THIS MORNING I WANTED TO
GET INTO I'M A POINT THAT YOU
STARTED TO MAKE ABOUT THIS
KIND OF BEWILDERING ARRAY OF
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING STREAMS
BECAUSE THEY TREAT TREAT AS
WE'VE GOT A LOT WE'RE SPENDING
A LOT OF MONEY WE GOT A TON
OF FUNDING PROGRAMS I'M IT'S
INCREDIBLY CONFOUNDING I THINK
FOR ALMOST ANYONE TO NAVIGATE
AND I THINK WE FIND OURSELVES
IN A SITUATION WHERE UNLESS
YOU'RE A REALLY BIG CITY ARE
REALLY BIG NONPROFIT YOU CAN
HIRE LIKE A FULL TIME GRANT
WRITER ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACCESS THESE FUNDS SO WHAT DO
YOU THINK THAT WE CAN DO TO
STREAMLINE THIS AND GET YOUR
MORE MONEY INTO I INTO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY NEED IT
WELL I THINK I AM STREAMLINING
SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS AND
AGAIN PART OF IT IS JUST HAVING
A A COMMON APPLICATION PROCESS
GUIDELINES WOULD BE HELPFUL
-- ALSO IF IT'S USEFUL EACH CD
THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT DID AT ONE TIME
HAVE A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO HELP A SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS APPLY FOR FUNDS
I CAN LOOK AT THAT AND SEE
IF THAT STILL IN EXISTENCE
BUT I MEAN IT WILL TAKE A
LOT OF WILL TO RE ORGANIZE
-- OUR DEPARTMENTS BUT I DO
THINK WE KIND OF LACK A GLOBAL
PLAN AROUND HOMELESSNESS
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND THAT
WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT A STATEWIDE DATABASE
WOULD ALSO DO THAT IT GIVE
US A CHANCE TO SEE REALLY
WHERE INVESTMENTS ARE GOING
WHERE LOCALS ARE VESTING AND
HOW WE CAN SUPPORT LOCALS
I'M IN PICKING UP ON THAT SO
RIGHT NOW WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
TRAFFIC TRACK THE EFFICACY OF
STATE DOLLARS IN HOW DO WE KNOW
THAT THE MONEY WE'RE INVESTING
IS ACTUALLY WORKING OR NOT WELL
THE HEAP IN THE HOUSE FUNDS
WERE INTENDED TO BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD GO OUT QUICKLY AND
HELP AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THIS THE HEAT FUNDS DID NOT
HAVE A LOT OF REPORTING HAP
HAS MORE REPORTING ABOUT HOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SPENDING
THE FUNDS SO THAT SHOULD
GIVE US THE DATA AND SOME
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY WORKING -- MANY OF THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS THAT WE USE TO
FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING DO HAVE
A REPORTING REQUIREMENTS SO
I THINK AGAIN FIRST THE FIRST
ROUND OF HE WAS REALLY INTENDED
TO GET OUT QUICKLY THE SECOND
ROUND OF HOP HAS MORE REPORTING
AND MORE -- ABILITY TO LOOK
AT HOW THE FUNDS ARE BEING
VESTED OKAY AND THEN JUST TO
CLARIFY AND HE'D BEEN HAPPY FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT IN THE
HOUSING WORLD SO KEEP WAS THE
FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING AND IT'S
SAD I CAN'T I CAN'T REMEMBER
THE ACRONYM WITHOUT LOOKING
AT IT IT'S HOMELESS EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM HOMELESS EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND THAT IS
HEAP FUNDING AND HOW UP WILL BE
AROUND TOO AND THAT WILL BE AND
HALF IS HOMELESS HOUSING AND
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND THAT'S
THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
THAT'S GOING OUT THIS YEAR AND
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUUM'S
OF CARE WHICH ARE LOCAL COUNTY
ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDS -- AROUND HOMELESSNESS --
CITIES THE BIG THIRTEEN CITIES
NOW AND COUNTIES AS WELL OKAY
SO WE GET KEEP AND HELPS THEM
WILL BE VERY HAPPY NOW I'M
JOKING BUT ACTUALLY ON THE --
STREAMLINING WE ARE OFFICE DID
RUN ON THE FLEXIBLE HOUSING
BILL WHICH WE HAD PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING IN THE BILL AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
TOOK PIECES THAT HAVE OUT OF
THAT AND PUT IT INTO IS --
PACKAGE AS FAR AS BUDGET BUT WE
WILL RUN AGAIN STREAMLINING THE
APPLICATION BECAUSE FOR SOME
OF YOU WHO HAVE -- YOUNG ADULTS
AND HELP THEM TO THE COLLEGE
PROCESS WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
FORMULA YOU APPLY TO MANY BUT
THE SAME PARAMETERS ARE FOR
MOST OF THE APPLICATIONS BUT
FOR A LOT OF THE INDIVIDUAL
CITIES THEY MIGHT APPLY FOR ONE
AND NOT KNOW WHAT ABOUT ANOTHER
AND IF WE COULD STREAMLINE
THAT SO MAYBE EVEN DEADLINES
AND SO FORTH BECOME MUCH MORE
LIKE THIS IS A TIME OR CITY
HAS TO GET THESE APPLICATIONS
IN IT I THINK IT STARTS TO
SHIFT ON HOW CITIES LOCAL
YOURS ARE LOOKING AT DID WE
MISS THAT DEADLINE BUT IF YOU
KNOW JUST SAY NOVEMBER IS OUR
HOUSING -- TIME JUST LIKE WITH
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS I THINK WE
COULD START TO SEEK RECEIVE AN
ORANGE COUNTY AND EAT AND OTHER
COUNTIES THOSE DOLLARS THAT
THE STATE HAS THAT WE HAVEN'T
ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO ATTAIN SO
RIGHT ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT
IT DOES IS TO YOUR POINT IT'S
IF WE HAVE AN INTEGRATED IN
KIND OF COHERENT STRATEGY AND
THEY'RE SORT OF A SINGLE POINT
OF MANAGEMENT IT'S IT'S MUCH
EASIER TO THEN ASSESS WHAT'S
WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT RATHER
THAN THIS KIND OF MISHMASH SO
I'M VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO I THINK WE'LL
GO HAD ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
OUR STATE AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
THIS IS LISA ANGLE WORKING AS
THE PRIMARY CONSULTANT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND IF YOU HAVE
LEGISLATIVE IDEAS MAKE SURE
YOU TALK TO HER ON THE WAY
OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR NEXT PANELIST AND BEFORE
THAT I JUST WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE DO ALSO HAVE --
THE PLACENTIA CITY MANAGER AND
IF YOU WILL STAFF TO STAND UP
THAT IS DAMIEN A RUE LÀ THEY
MET WELCOME AND -- WITH THAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE OUR NEXT
PANELIST IN THAT IS MUHAMMAD
ALI WHO IS THE ATTORNEY AND
FOUNDER OF ORANGE COUNTY
POVERTY ALLEVIATION COALITION
SO MUCH IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
HONOR TO BE HERE AND HONESTLY
I COULDN'T SPEAK AS WELL ON
THIS ISSUE -- AS SOME OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE REALLY
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF IT SO I'M
MICHELLE MURPHY FROM THE UNITED
WAY ACT ARE THE CAMPAIGNS AND
HOMELESSNESS -- IS HERE AND
I MEAN SHE COULD CERTAINLY
TALK ABOUT -- THE VARIOUS
INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO TRY TO INCENTIVIZE
LANDLORDS TO ACCEPT -- TO
ACCEPT SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS
TO EXPAND OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK I'M IN GENERAL
SEETHER COVERT CORPORATE RUBIO
SAYS HERE FROM THE KENNEDY
COMMISSION YOU CAN CERTAINLY
SPEAK TO THE LEGAL ADVOCACY
YOU KNOW CHALLENGING I'M CITIES
COMPLIANCE -- WITH THE OTHER
SB TO -- YOU KNOW VARIOUS
LAWSUITS I'M THAT WE'VE BEEN
BROUGHT BY KENNEDY COMMISSION
REYES ADVOCACY AS WELL --
IT AND TERMS OF LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCACY OF WE ALSO HAVE LIKE
ADVOCATES FROM THE ARM HOUSING
IS HUMAN RIGHT ORANGE COUNTY
SO I MEAN WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS
HERE HAT -- DAVID --
MY FOR MY GOOD FRIEND REBEKAH
IS HERE -- WE HAVE YOU KNOW IF
PEOPLE I CAN THAT DEFINITELY
SPEAK TO THE GRASSROOTS
ADVOCACY AS WELL -- YOU KNOW
ON THIS ISSUE -- BUT I WANTED
TO REALLY FOCUS ON WHAT IS
INNOVATIVE AND WHAT ISN'T
REALLY BEING TALKED ABOUT --
AND I WANTED TO KIND OF I'M
BEGIN WITH LIKE THE FAMILIAR
PRINCIPLE THE EIGHTY TWENTY
PRINCIPLE -- AND AND START WILL
LIKE THIS NOTION THAT MAYBE
MAYBE IT'S THE CASE THAT TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE POPULATION --
ARE REALLY GIVING ARM THE OTHER
EIGHTY PERCENT -- THIS STIGMA
OF CAUSING PROBLEMS A FEELING
CRIME -- OF BEING THE ADDICTS
OF OF BEING PEOPLE THAT AREN'T
WORTH OUR HELP WHERE PEOPLE
THAT IF WE DO TRY TO HELP IF
WE DO TRY TO BUILD SHELTERS TO
BE TO TRY TO BUILD HOUSING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THEY'RE GOING
TO CREATE ALL OF THESE -- YOU
KNOW IT IMPACTS OUR COMMUNITIES
WE CAN'T BUILD SHELTERS TO
CLOSE TO SCHOOLS WE CAN'T
BUILD SHELTERS TO COSTA HOMES
THAT WILL IMPACT THEIR I HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED PROPERTY VALUES
-- BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW THE
CRIME THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS HOMELESSNESS POPULATION
AND THE STIGMA I THINK IS THE
REASON WHY YOU KNOW WE HAVE
ALL THIS MONEY THAT YOU KNOW
IS AVAILABLE IN ALL THESE IT
YOU AGREE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE BUT REALLY OVER
COMING -- THE PUBLIC OPPOSITION
-- TO THE TO ADD DID THIS NAME
ESM -- TO PROVIDING SERVICES
THAT IS A HUGE BARRIER AND IT'S
HARD AND IT'S VERY RARE TO FIND
THE LOCAL LEADER THE LOCAL --
YOU KNOW CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
THAT'S WILLING TO STAND UP TO
SOMETIMES OVERWHELMING PUBLIC
OPPOSITION TO THESE PROGRAMS SO
STARTING WITH THIS NOTION THAT
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO FOCUS ON
THAT TWENTY PERCENT AND REALLY
START TO UNDERSTAND TRULY
UNDERSTAND THEIR ISSUES --
YES WE DO HAVE THIS OUR ISSUE
OF DRUG ADDICTION IS REALLY
PREVALENT AMONG THIS POPULATION
WHY DO WE HAVE THAT PROBLEM WHY
IS THERE AN OPIATE CRISIS WELL
IT'S BECAUSE I I WOULD I WOULD
HUMBLY SUBMIT A WE AREN'T LOOK
AT WE ARE EMPLOYING EVIDENCE
BASED BEST PRACTICES IN DEALING
WITH -- THIS INTERSECTION OF
DRUG ADDICTION AND HOMELESSNESS
AND WHAT IS THIS EVERY IT'S
BASE BEST PRACTICE IT'S THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
FOR FOLKS THAT HAVE A AN OPIOID
I USED TO SORT HER ARM AND WHAT
IS THAT WHAT IS THAT MEANS THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
WHICH AGAIN IS RECOGNIZED
YOU KNOW BY PHYSICIANS AS THE
EVIDENCE BASE BEST PRACTICE FOR
DEALING WITH OPIATE ADDICTION
MEANS I'M COMBINING THERAPY
WITH ARMED WITH ACTUAL YOU KNOW
MEDICAL INTERVENTION IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW PHARMACEUTICALS
I'M SO OPIATES AND AND AND
FORGIVE ME I DON'T HAVE TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT LIKE
THE SCIENCE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE LAWN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PUBLIC POLICY ON THIS ISSUE FOR
US TO TRULY UNDERSTAND -- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE BEST
WAY OF SOLVING THIS -- ABED SO
STARTING WITH THE SCIENCE GIVE
OPIATE RECEPTORS IN YOUR BRAIN
-- AND -- YOUR BRAIN ACTUALLY
PRODUCES ENDOGENOUS MORPHINE
SO IT'S A IT'S A NATURALLY
COMMIT ARE NATURALLY PRODUCED
CHEMICAL IN YOUR BRAIN YOU
PRODUCE AND DODGES WORKING
OR INDOOR FAN -- IN ORDER TO
CALM YOUR BODY DOWN IN ORDER
TO NAM PAIN WHEN THERE'S BEEN
AN INJURY YOU'RE NOT FREAKING
OUT WHEN YOU'RE YOU KNOW YOU
BREAK YOUR LEG OR YOU HAVE AN
INJURY -- SO YOU HAVE THESE
THESE OPIATE RECEPTORS IN YOUR
BRAIN AND YOU HAVE OBVIOUSLY
OPIATES WHICH ACT ON THE OPIATE
RECEPTORS -- WHICH YOU KNOW
DO WHAT YOU KNOW IT IT'S USED
-- FOR PAIN TREATMENT AND I WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE IN
OUT THAT THESE ARE IMPORTANT
LEE YOU KNOW THIS THESE ARE
IMPORTANT OCCASIONS USED YOU
KNOW APPROPRIATELY ARM AND WE
SHOULDN'T STIGMATIZE PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY NEED -- YOU
KNOW OUR PAIN MEDICATION THE
SAME TIME OBVIOUSLY IT HAS
THESE ARE FACTS OF IN OF --
INCREASING TOLERANCE AND ARE
INCREASED IN THIS CONDITION OF
IT OF OF ADDICTION ARM AND ALL
UNFORTUNATELY WE YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU SEE WHEN YOU HAVE DOCTORS
ON THAT ARE BEING LOBBIED BY
THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY TO
OVERLY PRESCRIBE ARM YOU KNOW
THE OPIOID CRISIS NOW WE SEE
YOU KNOW PROSECUTIONS AGAINST
YOU KNOW THE FACT THEIR FAMILY
AND PROSECUTIONS AGAINST IN
THE PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY
FOR FOR ESSENTIALLY CREATING --
YOU KNOW THIS OPIOID EPIDEMIC
-- WE WE DO HAVE THE AFFECTS
OF THAT LOCALLY -- WHEN WE
ARE WE ARE SEEING THIS -- YOU
KNOW IF ACTING -- AFFECTING
EIGHT FOLKS IN ORANGE COUNTY
-- WE DO HAVE AN OPIATE
CRISIS IN ORANGE COUNTY I
KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN KILEY
PETRIE-NORRIS IS FOR FOCUSING
ON THIS IN COSTA MESA -- WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
PERHAPS AN IRRESPONSIBLE SOBER
LIVING HOMES -- AND PEOPLE
THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY CAME IN
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY ARM IN
ORDER TO -- TO BUILD AS MUCH
MONEY OUT OF INSURANCE POLICIES
WERE ACTUALLY FIXING OUR WITH
OUR ACTUALLY FIXING DOES THE
CONDITION OF OPIOID ADDICTION
THAT PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING --
AND THEY'RE NOT USING EVIDENCE
BASED BEST PRACTICES SO THAT
SO EVIDENCE OF MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT USES A
COUPLE DIFFERENT -- DRUGS IN
ORDER TO -- IN ORDER TO EITHER
BINDS TO THE OPIOID RECEPTORS
ON AS A AS AN ANTAGONISED ARMS
SO THE SO BUPRENORPHINE IS AN
OPIOID ANTAGONISE WHICH MEANS
THAT IF YOU'RE ON A DRUG CALLED
BUPRENORPHINE YOU WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO GET HIGH IT HAS A
GREATER AFFINITY TO THE OPIATE
RECEPTORS WHICH MEANS YOU WON'T
BE ABLE TO GET HIGH EVEN IF YOU
WERE TO TRY YOU HAVE TO DO A
LOT OF LOT OF HEROIN IN ORDER
TO BLOW OFF THE -- PEOPLE ARE
FAN OR YOU KNOW THE SUBOXONE
-- BINDING TO YOUR OPIATE
RECEPTORS WHICH MEANS -- YOU
EAT IT YOU YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO RELAPSE SEC AND IF YOU GET
SOMEBODY ON THE STRUGGLE PEOPLE
NORTH AND ARE YOU YOU ARE ABLE
TO ESSENTIALLY GET THEM OUT OF
THIS CONDITION OF THE WAY OUT
OF THIS CONDITION OF HAVING
THIS CRAVING FOR OPIATES AT
THE SAME TIME -- AT THE SAME
TIME -- PREVENT THEM FROM BEING
ABLE TO RELAPSE -- THE PROBLEM
WITH THAT IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
TAKE THIS PEOPLE ARE FAN DALY
AND OFTENTIMES WHEN PEOPLE
WITH THE WORST PEOPLE WITH THIS
-- WORSENING ADDICTIONS ENTER
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TAKING THEIR
MEDICATIONS THE TREATMENTS
IN OUR JAILS AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN FIX
LOCALLY AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN FIX STATEWIDE
AND I DO THINK THAT THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T START TAKING THIS
THIS AT THIS PROBLEM OF OPIATE
ADDICTION IS OPIATE EPIDEMIC
WHICH IS CLAIMING THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE I'M FOR NOT ONLY
HOMELESS WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOUSE I'M AT ASTRONOMICAL
LEVELS AND COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE LEVELS AND WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEE AN END TO
WITH THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED
WITH DRUG ADDICTION AT THE AND
IN ALL THE PROBLEMS OF COURSE
SOME MIGHT -- BUT THAT THE
NEXT HOUSE IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK OUT SPEAK ABOUT IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
THE CRIMES IN THE COMPLAINTS
IN THE COMMUNITY -- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SEE AN END TO THAT
UNLESS WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY
LOCALLY -- THIS THIS ISSUE
FIXED BY ALLOWING PEOPLE WHEN
THEY GO TO JAIL UPON BOOKING
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TAKING
THEIR DRUGS -- INCLUDING PEOPLE
NORTH AND WORSE OR SOMETIMES A
PRESCRIBED METHADONE -- WHICH
IS ANOTHER DRUG USED AND AND
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
-- IF WE DON'T SEE THAT CHANGE
THEN ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE
EXPECTING PEOPLE TO DO AND I'VE
HAD THIS EXPERIENCE IS THERE
ON THE STREETS AND THEY'RE TOLD
A MILLION TIMES BY YOU KNOW
THE OUTREACH WORKERS YOU NEED
TO GET HELP WITH YOUR DICTION
NEED TO START HELPING YOURSELF
YOU NEED TO GET OFF THE STREETS
YOU NEED IT YOU NEED TO DEAL
WITH YOUR DRUG ADDICTION SO
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY GO TO A
METHADONE CLINIC OR THEY GO TO
YOU KNOW SUBOXONE CLINIC AND
THEY GET ON METHADONE TO GET ON
SUBOXONE THEN WHAT HAPPENS THEY
GET PICKED UP BY THE POLICE
FOR VIOLATING ANY KIND OF YOU
KNOW STATUS CHORUS ANY ANY KIND
OF YOU KNOW CRIME ASSOCIATE
WITH BEING HOMELESS HAPPENS
ALL TOO OFTEN THEY GO TO
JAIL THEY'RE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING
THERE AREN'T THEY'RE TAKING
THEIR TREATMENTS RIGHT BUT WHEN
THEY GO TO THE JAILS THEY'RE
TOLD WE'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU YOUR METHOD ON ROCKETING
GIVE YOU YOUR SUBOXONE WE
DON'T DO THAT SO THE SAUDI
DO INSTEAD IS THEY GIVE YOU A
DRUG TO DRINK TO ESSENTIALLY
TRANSITION YOU OFF OF THAT TO
GET YOU OFF OF METHADONE STATE
GIVE YOU VARIOUS DRUGS LIKE
YOU KNOW ASPIRIN OR DRUGS FOR
A CERTAIN DRUGS FOR YEAR YOU
FOR THE VARIOUS SIDE EFFECTS
OF OF OPIATE WITHDRAWALS LIKE
-- VOMITING OR DIARRHEA EXTREME
PAIN EXTREME DISCOMFORT ARM AND
SO YOU'RE SO THEY'RE TREATING
THE SYMPTOMS ASSOCIATED WITH
OPIATE WITHDRAWALS IN THE
JAILS BUT THAT'S POINTLESS
BECAUSE WHEN THEY GET RELEASE
FROM THE JAILS EITHER GOING
TO RELAPSE BACK ONTO OPIATES
OR THEY'RE GONNA GO RIGHT BACK
TO WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING
WHICH IS GETTING ON MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT SO THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO STOP
AND CURRENTLY IN ORDER AND IN
JAILS IN ORANGE COUNTY -- WE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE PREGNANT AND ON METHADONE
SHOULD BE CONTINUED ON THE
METHADONE TREATMENT BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO PUT THEIR FETUSES
INTO WITHDRAWAL AND ESSENTIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE -- TO -- TO
MISCARRY SO WOMEN FOR PREGNANT
ARE ACTUALLY IMMEDIATELY UPON
BOOKING ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
TAKING METHADONE HOWEVER THAT'S
NOT THE CASE WITH EVERY OTHER
IN THE UPON BOOKING SO THAT
NEEDS TO CHANGE LOCALLY AND
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE
STATEWIDE AND SO I DID HAVE
SO I BASICALLY DID HAVE A
MEMORANDUM THAT I PRINT THAT
I -- THAT I LAID OUT ALL THESE
ISSUES A RECENT YOU KNOW CASE
WHERE -- IN THE FIRST CIRCUIT
THE FEDERAL -- THE FEDERAL AT
FIVE FOR CIRCUIT COURT SAID
THAT THIS ESSENTIALLY BY THE
TEAM OR BECAUSE DISABILITIES
ACT TO TO DISCREETLY P.
TREAT PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT
DISORDERS THIS WAY AND ARE
IN IN JAILS THAT'S ALONG THE
FIRST CIRCUIT THAT LOT THAT
CASE ERRORS DUKE -- AIRS THE
HEIRS TO COUNTY CASE SMITH
RETURNS TO COUNTY THAT NEEDS
TO BE CODIFIED LOCALLY THERE
NEEDS TO BE LEGISLATION
PASSED IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT NEEDS TO THAT SO
THAT NEEDS TO BE CODIFIED
STATEWIDE AND THE NEEDS TO
BE FIXED LOCALLY AS WELL
OKAY SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
WHOLE FOR DISCUSSION I THINK
OF THAT MANY OF US MAY NOT
HAVE EVEN BEEN AWARE OF OR
UNDERSTAND STOOD THE CAPACITY
AND YOUR -- EFFORT IN THAT AREA
JUST SO YOU KNOW WE WILL HAVE
THESE PRESENTATIONS AVAILABLE
BY EMAIL IF YOU LET US KNOW
SO WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD
AND SEE IF THE PANEL HAS ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
YES THANK YOU SEE YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT MEDICAID MEDICAID
AS MEDICATIONS TO TREATMENT
YOUR SPECIFICALLY SPEAKING
ABOUT IT WILL BE IT WILL BE
ABLE TO DO WE HAVE SIMILAR
TREATMENT FOR OTHER DRUGS THAT
ARE OUT THERE THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY THING PEOPLE ARE ADDICTED
TO YEAH I MEAN SO I MEAN A LOT
OF THE ADVOCATES ARE HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE CAN TELL YOU THAT
OPIATES ARE BIG ONE AND MATH
IS ALSO ANOTHER BIG ONE --
ESSENTIALLY IT'S ARE A LOT MORE
EXPENSIVE TO GET YOUR HANDS
ON -- THAN MATH SO IF YOU HAVE
LIKE A MATH PROBLEM IF YOU'RE
SPENDING TEN BUCKS A DAY TRYING
TO FUEL YOUR METHOD ACTION WITH
OPIATES IT'S CLOSER TO YOU BY
THE TIME YOU'RE SHOOTING UP
MAYBE SEVENTY EIGHTY DOLLARS A
DAY I'M SO THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE
ABLE TO KIND OF SUSTAIN THAT
HABIT IS BY STEALING ARM BY
SELLING -- SO SO ALL SO I MEAN
I WOULD SAY THAT THEIR THEIR
PRODUCT I MEAN THERE THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY TREATMENTS FOR MATH
ADDICTION AS WELL -- IT'S A LOT
HARDER TO OVERDOSE ON MATH AND
IT IS TO OVERDOSE ON OPIATES
OPIATES -- OPIATES ARE OFTEN
LACED WITH -- -- WITH FAT NOW
WHICH IS A SYNTHETIC OPIATE ARM
WHICH IN VERY VERY VERY MINUTE
JOE SAYS I'M COULD EASILY KILL
YOU I'M UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE
SEEING FAT NOW BEING LOCATED IN
OTHER DRUGS AS WELL -- AND SO
IN TERMS OF THE IN TERMS OF THE
IN THAT THE OF THE FATALITIES
CAUSED BY DIFFERENT DRUGS I
THINK THAT MORE PEOPLE DIE IT
WILL BE IT'S PROBABLY MOST I
MEAN PROBABLY A GREATER NUMBER
DIVE -- ALCOHOL ADDICTION AS
WELL SO SO SO THERE NEEDS TO
THEIR NEEDS TO BE YOU KNOW MORE
TREATMENT OBVIOUSLY FOR ALL
THESE SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES
BY THE REASON WHY I FOCUS ON
OPIATES IS BECAUSE ONE ARM THE
THE THE THE THE FATALITY RATES
CAUSED BY OPIATES ARM TO ARM
THE OF THE BUT THAT THE WAY
THAT IT COMPLETELY DESTROYS
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND RUIN SOME
FINANCIALLY AND RUINS OF
ECONOMICALLY IS VERY SPECIFIC
AND VERY UNIQUE TO OPIATES --
AND THREE WHEN PEOPLE OFTEN
USE OPIATES ARM SINCE OPIATES
ESSENTIALLY HAVE THIS NARCOTIC
THEY HAVE AN ARCATA CA FACT
OBVIOUSLY BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE KIND OF LIKE AT A
DOWNER DRUG OFTEN PEOPLE WILL
USE OPIATES IN CONJUNCTION WITH
MATH WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY KIND
OF AN UPPER DRUG SO OFTEN TIMES
YOU SEE THIS ARM HE IS YOU SEE
THIS -- DO WILL OCCURRING LIKE
ADDICTION ARE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ARE TAKING BOTH TRUCKS VERY
VERY REGULARLY IT'S CALLED
SPEED BALLING ESSENTIALLY ARM
AND -- AND AND SO I I THINK
THAT -- OPIATES ARE OFTEN A
GATEWAY INTO I'M ESSENTIALLY
WORSE AND WORSE ARM USE ARM
WHEN PEOPLE GO FROM SMOKING TO
SHOOTING UP OPIATES THERE THE
ADDICTIONS GET EXPONENTIALLY
WORSE IN TERMS OF -- EIGHT HOW
MUCH SHE HOW MUCH IS ACTUALLY
IT IS THAT YOU'RE SPENDING IN
ORDER SHOULD UP VERSES WHEN
YOUR HABIT IS BASICALLY JUST
SMOKING BY BLACK TAR HEROIN
ARM AND BE LIKE THE THE THE
LEVELS OF LIKE COMPLICATIONS
ARM FROM SHOOTING APPARENTLY
I'VE FROM SHOOTING UP HEROIN
SO ESSENTIALLY LIKE OPIATES
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND IT'S
BUT WITH ONE OF THE HARDEST
IT'S ONE THE HARDEST TO BE ABLE
TO -- TO BE ABLE TO OVERCOME
ANOTHER ANOTHER FACT TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS IS THAT YOU CAN'T
NECESSARILY I MEAN YOU DON'T
REALLY DIE FROM MASS WITHDRAWAL
YOU ABSOLUTELY CAN WITHDRAW
CAN DIE FROM HEROIN WITHDRAWAL
BECAUSE OF ALL THE DIFFERENT
COMPLICATIONS IN TERMS OF LIKE
THE VOMITING ARMS THE DIARRHEA
-- AND LIKE ALL AND JUST STATE
THE HYDRATION AT THAT CAN COME
FROM THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY CAN'T
DIE FROM THE AT THE WITHDRAWALS
ARE ALSO ALL VERY EXTREMELY
SEVERE WHEN IT COMES TO IT I'M
VERSUS OTHER DRUGS BUT HEROIN
IS NOT AN OPIATE OR NOT ANOTHER
ONE IS AN OPIATE YES KAREN IS
AN OPIATE -- AND THEN YOU ALSO
HAVE YOU KNOW PHARMACEUTICALS
-- LAKE PHICHIT N.
METHADONE ALL OF THESE
ARE OPIATES THEY THEY THEY
WORK IN THAT SAME WAY --
BUT YEAH SO WE NEED IF
WE NEED TO GET A LOOK AT
MEDICATIONS AS A TREATMENT FOR
TREATING -- OPIATE ADDICTION
SO REMEMBER THAT LAST
QUESTION VERY TIED TO THE
SO SO YOU DON'T YOU'RE NOT
RECOMMEND THAT WE DO YOU
MEDIC MEDICATION IS THE
TREATMENT THAT WE DON'T
YOU TALKED ABOUT STEVE I
LEGISLATION THAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING YEAH AND YOUR FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT OPIATES
AND NOT JUST MEDICATED
ASSISTED TREATMENT IN GENERAL
WHAT MADE IT MEDICATIONS
THAT THE TREATMENT IS KIND
OF A TERM OF ART T.
ARM THAT'S THAT IS TO DESCRIBE
THIS VERY SPECIFIC MEDICAL
INTERVENTION -- FOR OPIATES
I THINK THE EASIEST WAY TO
CONCEPTUALIZE A POTENTIAL STATE
BILL ON THIS ISSUE IS TO CODIFY
THE HOLDING IN SMITH V.
ARISTIDE COUNTY AN DO
WE HAVE DATE OF BEING OF
LET'S FIRST I CAN ACCEPT YOUR
PREMISE THAT TWENTY PERCENT OF
THE POPULATION IS WHAT'S GIVING
THE STIGMA TO THIS LARGER
POPULATION SURE ARE AND AMONG
SAID TWENTY PERCENT DO WE HAVE
DATE OF HOW MUCH OF ITS OPIATE
VERSUS MATH AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE YET SO -- THIS IS A
VERY VERY COMPLEX ISSUE TO TRY
TO EXPLAIN AND SO I I TRY TO
RUN TO AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
BUT I DID PREPARE -- ABOUT
A FIFTY PAGE MEMO -- THAT I
THINK CAN BE SENT OUT TO -- TO
ANYBODY UPON REQUEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER DATE
YES --
CAN I CALL SOMEBODY FOR MURDER
THE HEALTHCARE AGENCY TO ANSWER
ABOUT THIS BUT THIS PROGRAM
ABOUT MEDICAL ASSISTANT THE
TREATMENT WELL WE HAVE COMING
TO THE MIKE CARE OR YOU CAN
SIT RIGHT THERE -- THIS IS
RICHARD SANCHEZ FROM THE
COUNTY BUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT SO SO SO WITH THE
SANCHES HER DESK ORANGE COUNTY
CURRENTLY OFFER THIS PROGRAM
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE TEMPORARY
DETAIN -- WHEN WHEN WHEN THEY
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL PROBLEM
WE GIVE THEM ANYTHING AT ALL
TO -- TREAT THEIR PROBLEM
SO FOR A CAR ST INDIVIDUALS
WE DO PROVIDE AS MISTRAL HE
SAID -- PREGNANT WOMEN AND AB
ONE OH NINE INMATES SUBOXONE
AND NALOXONE -- EXCUSE ME
THE PROVEN ARE FITTING AND
STOP AND AND NALOXONE WE
ARE WORKING ON PROVIDING THE
OTHER TRACKS BOX ON AS WELL
AND WE ARE EXPANDING MAPPED
MEDICARE SYSTEM TREATMENT
TWELVE INMATES AS WELL
DO YOU NEED THE STATE
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM OR LANDING WOULD YOU
HELPFUL MORE IS A MORE IT IS
MORE OF A FUNDING ISSUE THIS
AND THE AND THE LEGAL ISSUES
AS YOU MAY KNOW -- MEDI CAL --
SUSPENDED WHILE INCARCERATED SO
FAR ALL FUNDING FOR TREATMENT
INSIDE THE JAIL IS IS WE HAVE
TO FIND FUNDING FOR OTHER THAN
MEDI CAL THAT WE CANNOT USE
ANY MEDI CAL NOR MHSAA NOR ANY
SUBSTANCE USE DOLLARS WHILE
THEY'RE INCARCERATED SO THE
STRUGGLES ALWAYS BEEN FUNDING
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY LCD
LIKE TO ADD TO A A LOT OF THE
-- JUST THAT -- M.
A. T. IS SOMEWHAT NHIÁU --
MEDICAID ASSISTED TREATMENT --
WE HAVE FOUND THAT TO BE VERY
USEFUL WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT
RE ENTRY SO -- AGAIN AS THE
SPEAKER SAID THEY ENTER WITH A
DRUG ADDICTION WE ARE EXPANDING
OUR AS YOU AS THE THIS GROUP
MAY NOW WE ARE EXPANDING OUR
SERVICES INSIDE THE JAIL IN
TERMS OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE AND SO WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT RE ENTRY SO WHEN
THE PERSON HITS THE STREETS
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEIR --
WELL EQUIPPED WITH MEDICATION
TO TIE THEM FOR PERIOD UNTIL
THEY GET THEIR -- EITHER MEDI
CAL OR OTHER INSURANCE COVERAGE
SO THEY DON'T RELAPSE THANK YOU
SO THIS I THINK IS WHERE WE GET
INTO THE COMPLEXITIES OF WHO
IS ON OUR STREETS WHO IS THE
MOST VULNERABLE IN THE SENSE
OF BEING REALLY CLOSE TO DEATH
BECAUSE IF YOU'VE INTERFACED
WITH ANYBODY WHO HAS -- THESE
ADDICTIONS A OR A STEP AWAY
FROM DEATH AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN
TALKED ABOUT ALCOHOLISM SO --
ADDICTIONS DO PLAY A ROLE I
THINK WHAT YOU STARTED WITH
THOUGH IS THE STIGMA THE STIGMA
THAT'S ATTACHED TO WHETHER
IT BE A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE
WHICH WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MANY OF OUR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHO DO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THEY CAN HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND ADDICTION
ISSUES AND MANY OTHER ISSUES
TO COP COMPOUND -- WHAT TERRY
ARE SUFFERING ON THE STREETS
INCLUDING HEALTH ISSUES -- SO
YOU MAY HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE -- NOT ONLY ADDICTION
ISSUES MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
-- BUT -- SOME TYPE OF HEALTH
ISSUE AND THAT WOULD BE --
AS SOME OF THE OF NO I DON'T
LIKE TO DO IT OFTEN BUT I
WILL IN THE SENSE THAT WOULD
BE MY BROTHER BILLY AND HE --
STARTED OUT AS A VERY STRONG
HARD WORKING ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT COME WITH WHAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO SEE ANY OF YOUR FAMILY
MEMBERS BUT THROUGH INTERFACE
SCENE WITH A ALCOHOLISM AND
WITH THE ALCOHOLISM AND WITH
GETTING OLDER AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND THAT HE SUFFERED
FROM HERNIA THAT WAS NOT
TREATED BECAUSE WE COULDN'T
GET HIM TO GET TO -- ACTUALLY
MAKE THE APPOINTMENTS AND MANY
TIMES THESE APPOINTMENTS ARE
NOT ALL IN THE SAME PLACE SO I
JUST PUT A FACE TO THIS BECAUSE
THIS ADDICTION AND HOMELESSNESS
IS NOT A REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT
ISSUE IT IS NOT A POLITICAL
ISSUE AND IT DOESN'T HAVE
ANY OF THEM IT DOESN'T CHIU
SOMEBODY BY ECONOMICS SO WE
COULDN'T SAY THAT IT'S ALL
THE PEOPLE IN THIS AREA OR ALL
THE PEOPLE IN THIS AREA THE IT
DOESN'T TO PICK BY YOUR SOCIAL
ECONOMICS OR YOUR COLLEGE
DEGREE IT AFFECTS MANY IN EVERY
FAMILY IN SOME WAYS THAT MOST
OF US ARE DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
ABOUT AND THAT'S THE STIGMA
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THAT AT THE
LAST HEARING ON SOBRE WHICH IS
THAT IF SOMEBODY COMES IN AND
THEY ARE DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER
WE IMMEDIATELY RALLY AROUND
THEM LET'S GET MEALS LET'S
GET OUR FACEBOOK FRIENDS TO
DELIVER MALES LET'S YOU KNOW
WOULD DO PRAYER GROUPS IS DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
HIM SOMEBODY STARTS HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES OR ADDICTION
ISSUES EVERYTHING BECOMES
REALLY QUIET AND WILL WHISPER
THAT WHEN I TALKED ABOUT MY
BROTHER'S BILLY STORES I HAD
ALMOST A THOUSAND TEXT MESSAGES
AND EMAILS ALL WITH THE SAME
NARRATIVE YOU KNOW I HAVEN'T
REALLY TOLD ANYBODY ABOUT IT
BUT MY BROTHER SUFFERS FROM
THIS OR WE'VE BEEN DEALING AND
THIS IS FAMILY SUFFERING IN
SILENCE AND THEN PRETTY MUCH
THIS FAMILY ISN'T THERE ANYMORE
BECAUSE MAYBE THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY CAN'T DO ANYMORE THEY LET
GO AND THAT IS MANY TIMES WHERE
YOU SAY WELL HOW DOES A SENIOR
HAVE NO SAFETY NET HOW DOES
SOMEBODY WHO HAVE GRANDCHILDREN
OR ANSWER ON GOALS HOW DOES
THAT HAPPEN AND THE TRUTH IS AT
SOME POINT PEOPLE JUST LET GO
SO WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO OUR
THANK YOU AND WILL MOVE TO OUR
CHIEF CHIEF COREY SINUS THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CROOKS OVER
IP SHAPE BEING HERE TODAY --
MONITOR SPEAK ON BEHALF OF --
NORTH ON CARILLON FORSMAN --
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHEN A PARK AND WE'RE
GOING TO PARK IS DOING AND
THEN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SOME OF THE REGIONAL THINGS
WE'RE DOING IN NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY OUR WAS BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN IS WHEN -- WE REALLY
STARTED TO FEEL THE IMPACT OF
HOMELESS NURSE IN OUR COMMUNITY
-- ARE COMPLAINTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY REGARDING
THE HOMELESS WERE ON THE RISE
AND OUR CALLS FOR SERVICE --
INVOLVING HOMELESS ACCOUNTED
FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
PERCENT OF OUR TOTAL CALLS FOR
SERVICE IT WAS BECOMING A HUGE
GRIN ON SOURCES AND IT WASN'T
GETTING ANY BETTER WE STARTED
TO HAVE SOME SOME SERIOUS
DISCUSSIONS WITH CITY COUNCIL
REGARDING A HOMELESS ISSUES
WE ALL REALIZE THAT WE HAD TO
CHANGE OUR MINDSET AN ATTITUDE
ABOUT THE HOMELESS BECAUSE WHAT
WE WERE DOING WHICH WAS MOSTLY
ENFORCEMENT AT THAT TIME WASN'T
SOLVING THE PROBLEM WE HAD TO
BECOME MORE PROACTIVE AND WE
KNEW THAT WE WEREN'T DOING ANY
LONG TERM PROBLEM SOLVING WE
WERE JUST KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE ROAD THEN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
OUR CITY COUNCIL HIRED A
CONSULTANT TO TAKE A DEEP DIVE
INTO -- ARE HOMELESS ISSUES
AND MAKE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
ON HOW WE COULD BETTER SERVE
THAT OUR POPULATION TWO
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH
WERE IMPLEMENTED WERE TO
CONTRACT WITH THE NONPROFIT
THAT COULD HELP US -- WITH
HOMELESS OUTREACH WE SERVICE
SUBSEQUENTLY CONTRACTED WITH
CITY NET AND TO -- HIGHER
AND TWO ADDITIONAL FULL TIME
POLICE OFFICERS AS HOMELESS
LIAISON OFFICERS TO WORK WITH
CITY THAT AND TO BUILD AND
MAINTAIN STRONG RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND ALL HOMELESS POPULATION
WE STARTED TO SEE THE CHANGES
ARE IN THE WAY WE DID BUSINESS
WHEN IT CAME TO ADDRESS AND
ALL HOMELESS ISSUES WE'RE
BECOMING PROACTIVE AND WE'RE
NOW FOCUSING ON REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE CITY
AND THE REGION BY FUNDING
FIND A LONG TERM SOLUTION
SUCH A SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT REACH
COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND MULTI
DISCIPLINARY COLLABORATION WE
ALSO UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS WAS
JUST NOT A WHEN A PARK ISSUE
IT WAS A REGIONAL ISSUE IN
ADDITION WE STARTED BUILDING
STRONGER PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OUR OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE COUNTY WITH
ORANGE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH IT
WAS SHELVE SEVERAL NONPROFIT
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO BRING
AS MANY AVAILABLE RESOURCES
TOGETHER FOR THIS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY APPROACH IN AND
DEAN -- SHORT TERM AND CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE WE WERE
BECOMING MORE PROACTIVE IN
GOING TO SPEND MORE TIME
ON LONG TERM SOLUTIONS WE
PROVIDE PROVIDED WE ARE A
CELLO IS IN ALL OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS ADDITIONAL TRAINING
TO ASSIST THEM IN CONNECTING
WITH THE HOMELESS POPULATION
ALL OF OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
ATTENDED A SIXTEEN HOUR
CRISIS INTERVENTION TRAINING
COURSE AND SPENT SOME TIME
WORKING WITH OUR H.
ELLOS AND SITTING AT C.
I. T. COURSES DESIGNED TO
TRAIN OFFICERS TO HANDLE
CRISIS SITUATIONS INVOLVING
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES RECOGNIZING THAT
A VERY SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION
OF OUR HOMELESS POPULATION
WHEN A PARK SUFFER FROM SOME
FORM OF OF MENTAL ILLNESS
WE ALSO DEVELOPED A CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
TO ASSIGN A PSYCHOLOGICAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TECHNICIAN
ALSO REFERRED TO AS PART TO
RIDE WITHOUT A CELLO IS A
MINIMUM OF TWO DAYS A WEEK
THEN IN TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
-- WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH AND SENATOR JOSH
NEWMAN -- AND NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY CITIES WERE ABLE TO
OBTAIN TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BUDGET TO
CREATE A NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
PUBLIC SAFETY TASK FORCE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF ADDRESSING
THREE FOCUS AREAS ONE WAS
YOUTH VIOLENCE PREVENTION TO
WAS PROGRAMS THAT PROMOTE AND
ENHANCE THE SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
OF OFFENDERS INTO OUR COMMUNITY
AND THREE WHICH IS BECOME OUR
BIGGEST FOCUS AREA HOMELESS
OUTREACH AND INTERVENTION
EFFORTS THAT MONEY COULD NOT
OF CAME AT A BETTER TIME SIXTY
PERCENT OF THOSE BONDS WERE
TO BE DISTRIBUTED TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND FORTY
PERCENT OF THE FUNDING --
WOULD BE SET ASIDE -- FOR EACH
CITY -- TO ADDRESS THOSE --
THREE FOCUS AREAS MANY OF THE
CITY'S USE THAT FORTY PERCENT
TO ADD STAFF IN TO ADDRESS
THOSE THREE FOCUS AREAS FROM
A REGIONAL PERSPECTIVE AFTER
THE TASK FORCE WAS CREATED
WHAT WE STARTED REALIZING WAS
HELD VALUABLE AND CRITICAL
IT WAS OFF TO HAVE A MULTI
AGENCY COLLABORATION BUT ALSO
PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE WERE
DEVELOPING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE
WE'RE FINDING OUT THAT THE CBO
IS OFFERED SO MANY RESOURCES
THAT CAN HELP US PROACTIVELY
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT WERE
NEEDED WE HADN'T SEEN THIS
TYPE OF COLLABORATION BEFORE
CBO IS LIKE THE SEVEN BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUBS IN NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY THAT OFFER SO MANY
LEADERSHIP AND SKILLS LIFE
SKILLS PROGRAMS TO ARE AT RISK
YOUTH OTHERS AND BIG SISTERS
THIS STARTED A BIG SOME BADGES
PROGRAM HERE I'M GOING TO
PARK IN CYPRUS WHERE POLICE
OFFICERS VOLUNTEER TO MENTOR AT
RISK YOUTH AND MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR LIVES SO
THEY DON'T BECOME HOMELESS
THEY DON'T BECOME CRIMINALS IF
YOU DON'T BECOME GANG MEMBERS
RESILIENT FAMILIES OF CAL STATE
FULLERTON AND THAT PROVIDE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
SERVICES TO HIGH RISK FAMILIES
AND SUNBURST YOUTH ACADEMY
WHICH SERVES USED AGES SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD TO REFORM
THEIR LIVES ACADEMICALLY
EMOTIONALLY AND SOCIALLY WHAT
WE FOUND IS HOMELESSNESS IS
HERE IT'S BEEN HERE FOR A
LONG TIME BUT WE WERE WE WERE
DROPPING THE BALL WAS NOT BEING
PROACTIVE IN PREVENTING IT FROM
EVER OCCURRING SO WE FIGURED
IF WE START PARTNERING WITH THE
CBO IS IN ADDRESSING IT THESE
KIDS AT A YOUNG AGE AND HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THEM THEY WILL NEVER
GET TO THAT STAGE IN THEIR
LIFE ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND MANY MORE -- WE PARTNER
WITH HELP US TO PROACTIVELY
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS GANGS
IN YOUTH VIOLENCE SO THAT
IT NEVER HAPPENS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE TASK FOR SPEND
SOME OF THE FUNDS AND CONDUCTED
IT UP A FIRST OF ITS KIND
HOMELESS CENSUS HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE BELIEVE THAT IN
ORDER TO COORDINATE EFFORTS
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS
HOMELESSNESS THERE WAS JUST
NO WAY OF TELLING WHO THE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS FOR WHERE
THEY SLEEP OR CONSIDER THEIR
CITY OF RESIDENCE OR WHEN
THEY BECOME HOMELESS AND WHAT
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED IT OR
HAVE BEEN OFFERED ALTHOUGH THE
COUNTY DOES A POINT IN TIME
COUNT EVERY YEAR WE WANTED IT
TO DO A DEEPER DIVE AND SEEK
MORE MEANINGFUL DATA THAT WAS
ACCURATE AND CONTAIN GRAPHIC
GEOGRAPHIC AND DEMOGRAPHIC
AND PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HOMELESS THIS EFFORT WAS DONE
FROM MARCH NINETEENTH THROUGH
APRIL TWENTIETH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IN THE MORNING MID DAY AND
EVENING AT DESIGNATED LOCATIONS
MULTIPLE TIMES DURING THE
DAY WE DIDN'T WANT TO MISS
EVERYONE ANYONE BECAUSE WE
KNEW THEY MOVE AROUND A LOT
THERE WAS THERE WERE OVER
ELEVEN HUNDRED HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE IN IF
YOU'RE DOING THIS CENSUS THE
SENSES REVEAL THE FOLLOWING
THESE ARE JUST SOME HIGHLIGHTS
THERE WERE APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
HOMELESS ADULT IN NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE OF WHOM WERE ON
SHELTERED IN NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY FIFTY FOUR FOUR PERCENT
HAD BEEN HOMELESS FOR THREE
YEARS OR MORE FORTY ONE PERCENT
REPORTED HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE WHICH IS MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE GENERAL U. S.
POPULATION PERCENTAGE FORTY
SIX PERCENT HAD A PERMANENT
DISABILITY ALSO DOUBLE
THE GENERAL U. S.
POPULATION PERCENTAGE SIXTY
THREE PERCENT REPORTED HAVING
NO INCOME FIFTY FOUR PERCENT
OF THE WOMEN CONTACTED HAD
SURVIVED DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT REPORTED
HAVING NO HEALTH INSURANCE
NINE PERCENT WERE VETERANS
AND FORTY PERCENT HAD THEIR
LAST PERMANENT RESIDENCY
OUTSIDE OF NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY ALL OF THIS DATA WAS
EXTREMELY CRITICAL AS A TASK
FORCE TRYING TO DETERMINE
THE GRAVITY OF THE ISSUE AND
THE TYPES OF RESOURCES AND
SERVICES THAT WOULD BE NEEDED
TO MOVE FORWARD ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION WAS ALSO ENTERED
INTO A BY NAME DATABASE FOR OUR
OUTREACH TEAMS FOR IMMEDIATE
ACCESS IN THE FIELD AND IN
AN EFFORT TO HAVE REAL TIME
INFORMATION ACCESSIBLE TO OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND NOW REACH
MEMBERS WE ALSO PARTNER WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY COMPANY BY THE
NAME OF OUTREACH GRID THEY
DEVELOPED AN APPLICATION TO
USE OUR OFFICERS CELL PHONES
IN ADDITION WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF WORKING WITH THE
HOMELESS SHELTERS TO DEVELOP
AN AVAILABLE BED APPLICATION
SO THAT OUR OFFICERS CAN SEE
WHAT BEDS ARE AVAILABLE WHEN
THEY COME IN CONTACT WITH
INDIVIDUALS IN THE FIELD
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE CITY
ONE APART PARTY WITH OTHER
NORTH COUNTY SPA CITIES AND THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE TO REGIONALLY
FIND TO NAVIGATION CENTERS
ONE OF PLACENTIA AND HERE IN
THE CITY OF ONE OF PARK THE
HOMELESS NAVIGATION CENTER
IN ONE OF PARK IS EXPECTED TO
OPEN SOMETIME AROUND JUNE OF
THIS YEAR UP NEXT YEAR WHY DO
WE NEED SHELTER BEDS WE NEED
THEM AS A TOOL TO HELP US
PROVIDE HOUSING AND SERVICES
DRAW HOMELESS NEIGHBORS AND
TO GET OUR TOOLS BACK SO WE
DON'T HAVE THE HOMELESS CAMPS
IN OUR PARKS AND STREETS OF
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS CAN FEEL
SAFE AGAIN AND WE DON'T HAVE
THE PROBLEMS THAT COME WITH
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES WITHOUT
AVAILABLE BEDS WERE ALSO UNABLE
TO ENFORCE OUR CAMPING AND
ORDERING ORDINANCE AS IT WAS
ALSO MOVIES WE SOME LAWSUITS
AND THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY SO THE BOTTOM LINE
FOR A MOMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE AND FROM A CITY
PERSPECTIVE IS AT I THINK I AM
GOING TO QUOTE OUR CITY MANAGER
HERE WE SAYS ONE OF PARK
IS IN THE HOMELESS BUSINESS
BECAUSE WE ARE AND WE ARE
COLLABORATING WITH OTHER CITIES
AND THE COUNTY TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO HELP HOMELESS HOMELESS
NEIGHBORS PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS AND RESOURCES
TO GET THEM INTO HOUSING AND
OFF THE STREET WE'RE TRULY
TO HELP AND HOMELESSNESS WE
NEED TO CONTINUE OUR REGIONAL
EFFORTS AS WE'RE DOING WITH
THE NORTH ORANGE COUNTY PUBLIC
SAFETY TASK FORCE WHICH HAS
HAD TREMENDOUS SUCCESS AND
I WOULD HAVE I WILL PROVIDE
ANYBODY THAT WANTS A COPY OF
OUR OF OUR ANNUAL REPORT AND
OUR SENSES REPORT IT'LL BE IN
THE BACK OF THE ROOM YOU'RE
WELCOME TO TAKE A COPY OF
IT REALLY WE NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NEED A PLACE FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO GO BEYOND
THE SHELTER BECAUSE ALL WE'RE
DOING IS OPENING A REVOLVING
DOOR FOR THEM AND SO UNTIL WE
GET THE HOUSING IN PLACE WHERE
THEY HAVE A PLACE TO GO AND
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MAKE MUCH OF A DOWN THIS CALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU MISTER UP POLICE
CHIEF COREY SINUS AND I CAN
TELL YOU JUST FROM SERVING
IN AND REPRESENTING THIS AREA
FOR FIVE YEARS HE DOES WHAT
HE SAYS ANY IS OUT THERE AND
THIS IS A NOT ABOUT PUSHING
PEOPLE FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER IT'S ABOUT BUILT
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS AND
LOOKING AT THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE SOMEBODY
FROM HOMELESSNESS TO HOME ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BEFORE MOVED TO
YES THANK YOU CHIEF CHIEF YOU
WALK ME THROUGH TO SAID A FEW
SCENARIOS SO THAT THE PUBLIC
IN AND MAYBE THE MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY CAN CAN ME --
-- CAN HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT
IT'S LIKE SO FIRST NERIO YOUR
YOUR FRONTLINE OFFICER GET A
CALL THAT SOMEONE IS CAMPING
OUT AT THE PARK YOUR OFFICE
SHOW UP IT'S A FAMILY YOU
COULD BE A FAMILY COULD
BE A MOM WITH HER CHILDREN
WHAT DOES THAT OFFICERS SAY TO
TO THEM I AM AND WHAT KIND OF
SERVICE CAN YOU OFFICER ORDER
OR YOUR TASK FORCE OFFER IN
IN IN DEALING WITH A FAMILY
THAT'S DOWN ON ON THEIR LUCK
SO -- WE DO SPEND SOME QUALITY
TIME WITH THEM NOW VERSUS WHAT
WE DID YEARS AGO AND THAT IS
HAVING SOME CONVERSATION WITH
THEM REGARDING THEIR NEEDS COM
YOU KNOW THE SOME PAST HISTORY
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN PROVIDED AS
FAR SERVICES AND A WHAT IS IT
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR CAN
WE WE KIND CONNECTION WITH YOUR
FAMILIES -- AND AND NOW OTHER
OFFICERS ARE NOW EQUIPPED WITH
WITH INFORMATION ON RESOURCES
AVAILABLE WILL EIGHT WERE ABLE
TO HELP CONNECT THEM WITH THE
RESOURCES TO GET THEM MAYBE
INTO A INTO SOME FORM HOUSING
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT THAT
FAMILIES AND WOMEN GET FIRST
PRIORITY -- YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
FIRST PARTY GET THEM OFF THE
STREET AND THERE ARE USUALLY
PLACES WHERE THEY CAN GO IF
THEY WANT TO -- WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND IS THAT APPROXIMATELY
FORTY PERCENT OF THE HOMELESS
DO NOT WANT ASSISTANCE SIXTY
PERCENT AROUND SIXTY PERCENT
DO AND IF THEY WANT TO HOUSING
USUALLY WE CAN FIND A PLACE
FOR THEM TO GO SO FOR THE FOR
THE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT DON'T
WANT THE ASSISTANCE LIKE LIKE
YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
KNOW YOUR OFFICER COMES UP TO
THEM AND SAID HEY -- WE WE HAVE
SOME MOTEL VOUCHER FOR YOU TO
STAY FOR A COUPLE WEEKS VERY OR
WE WE KNOW THAT THESE SHELTER
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO HOME HI
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THE NEIGHBORS DON'T WANT THEM
CORRECT TO BE AT A PARK OR
TO BE SLEEPING IN AN ALLEY
OR OR ON A SIDEWALK IT WAS
YEAH IT WASN'T A PROBLEM FOR
US BECAUSE YOU KNOW ALL GIVEN
EXAMPLE MISTY WHEN YOU HAVE
LIKE A LITTLE LEAGUE GOING ON
IN A PARK AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THIS PERCEPTION OF
HOMELESS -- THEY DON'T WANT
THEM ANYWHERE NEAR THEIR KIDS
IN THEIR CHILDREN -- YOU KNOW
WE DO ALL WE CAN TO KIND OF
RELATE THAT INFORMATION TO THAT
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL A TO SEE
IF MAYBE WE CAN HELP THEM AND
AND MAYBE MOVE THEM TO ANOTHER
LOCATION -- BUT OFTEN TIMES
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO AND THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE IN THAT
PART JUST LIKE ANYBODY ELSE
DOES SO THERE'S NOT THERE'S
NOT MUCH WE CAN DO AS FAR AS
ENFORCEMENT WE TRY TO DO WHAT
WE CAN DO TO ENCOURAGE THEM
AND ENTICE THEM TO MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER LOCATION IF THEY DON'T
WANT ANY ASSISTANCE WHETHER
THAT BE WITH SOME FOOD OUT
YOURS OR SOME MOTEL VOUCHERS
OR THINGS OF THAT NATURE BUT
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO GO THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE IN THAT PART
JUST LIKE ANYBODY ELSE SO SO
THAT WOULD BE ONE SEGMENT OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION THAT
WE THAT THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
A SOLUTION YET RIGHT CORRECT
AND I WILL I WILL ASSURE
YOU THAT OUR OFFICERS OF
FIRST RESPONDERS KNOW THESE
INDIVIDUALS THEY COME IN
CONTACT WITH THEM ON A REGULAR
BASIS THEY WERE THERE THE
CALLS FOR SERVICE AND WE GET
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND AND
WE KNOW THEM ON A FIRST NAME
BASIS -- AND BECAUSE OF THAT
WE KNOW WHERE THEY LIKE TO
STAY WITH A LIKE TO EAT THAT
KIND OF STUFF AND SO WE HELP
PROVIDE THEM WITH SOME SOME
ASSISTANCE WE CAN OPERATE YOU
GET YOUR OFFICER YET GET A
CALL YOU SHOW UP A.
N. DE THE PERSON OR THE
GROUPS BAD -- TRIGGER
THAT THOSE CALLS WHERE THE
THEY'RE NOT MEANT TO LEASE
OF STABLE ANYMORE A IN HAVING
A CONVERSATION WITH YOU AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE GOOD THEY'RE
THEY'RE CAUSING A DISTURBANCE
WHEN YOU GET TO THE LIKE
WHAT IS WHAT IS YOUR SOLUTION
TO AT LEAST ABATE THAT
PROBLEM ON THAT DAY OR THAT
WEEK WELL IF IF THIRD --
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CALL FIFTY ONE
FIFTY AFTER DANGER THEMSELVES A
DANGER TO OTHERS OR R.
OR I GAVE THE DISABLED ARE
OFFICERS CAN TAKE THEM TO A
TREATMENT CENTER -- WHICH AND
IN THE END I MENTION THIS IN MY
IN MY ORIGINAL COMMENTS ABOUT
US HAVING A OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAM --
WE'RE WE HAVE SOMEBODY FROM
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCY THAT
USUALLY RIDE WITH OUR HELOC
OF SOMEBODY THAT'S MORE --
MORE HAS MORE EXPERTISE IN
THAT AREA THEY CAN HELP US SEE
EVALUATE THEM AND BE ABLE TO
HOPEFULLY FIND THEM A BAD TAKE
THAT THEY CAN GO TO AND GET
THEM THE MEDICATION WITH THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED TO
WILL WHERE WITH THAT TREATMENT
CENTER BE AN ORANGE COUNTY
ARE YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE
NAMES OF THEM ALL AT HONESTLY
BUT -- THERE'S A MULTIPLE
LOT OF TIMES THEY MIGHT GO TO
THE HOSPITAL FIRST ON IT AND
I BELIEVE SOMEBODY MENTIONED
-- SOME OF THE HOSPITALS BEING
OVERWHELMED WITH PATIENTS --
THAT ARE YOU THE MENTALLY ILL
OR OR A -- NEED TREATMENT -- A
LOT OF TIMES THEY THEY WILL GO
TO THE HOSPITAL FIRST AND THEN
WE CALL A PSYCHOLOGICAL TEAM
HOW TO THE HOSPITAL THE TO DO
AN EVALUATION THEY ARE CUTTING
DROPPING THEM OFF AT THE E.
R. ROOM IS -- IS COSTLY IT
IS VERY COSTLY YES AND THAT'S
A THAT'S A MAJORITY OF WHAT
WE HAVE TO GET A MEDICALLY
CLEARED FIRST CHIEF AYE AYE
I ASK YOU THESE QUESTIONS TO
RELEASE ARM HAVE HAVE THIS
OPEN DISCUSSION ABOUT --
HOMELESSNESS IN IN A SENSE
WHERE OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE
IS NOT ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE
WHO WANTS HELP RIGHT OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE AT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS ABOUT HOW DO
WE DEAL WITH PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
WANT TO HELP BUT HAVE CERTAIN
CIVIL RIGHTS WHERE YOU CANNOT
TAKEN TO A EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT
CENTER OR EVEN A TREATMENT
CENTER AGAINST THEIR WILL AND
THEN HOW DO WE DO WITH THAT
POPULATION IF THAT IS NOT THE
TWENTY PERCENT THAT IS ON THE
THE ADDITION -- CATEGORY WHAT
ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT JUST
REFUSE HELP WANTS TO BE ON THE
SIDEWALK LIKE TO LIVE IN A TENT
IN THE BACK OF AN ALLEY AND
THAT BASS AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT OUR CONSTITUENT REALLY
WANT US TO ADDRESS TO BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THEY SEE
WHEN THEY DRIVE ACROSS THE --
THE FREEWAY WHEN THE WHEN THE
DRIVE TO THE STREET THAT'S WHAT
THEY ALLEGE THE SOUL RIGHT IBM
I I HOPE THAT YOU CAN GIVE US
SOME SOME IDEAS ON HOW WE DEAL
WITH WITH THAT SEGMENT OF THE
OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION
BECAUSE THEY ITS MULTI FAST
RIGHT IT IS AND THAT'S A BIG
CHALLENGE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
YOU KNOW AND AND AND A LOT OF
TIMES -- THERE'S NOT MUCH YOU
CAN DO FOR THEM -- IF THEY
DON'T WANNA HELP AND SO --
THAT'S YOU KNOW WE DO ALL WE
CAN TO ADDRESS -- IT FROM AN
ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE AND IN
SOME CASES -- BECAUSE -- THAT'S
OUR ONLY ALTERNATIVE OTHER
THAN OFFERING THEM SERVICES
THEY DON'T WANT IT IS AND THEN
WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
OBEY THE LAWS AND REGULATIONS
AND ORDINANCES OF THE CITY AS
LONG AS THEY DO THAT HOW WE
HONESTLY IT'S JUST TOO IT'S
TOO TIME CONSUMING FOR OFFICERS
AND SO WE HAVE TO MOVE ON TO
BE AVAILABLE FOR OTHER BRIDGES
CALLS AND SHE VALUE THE LAST
COMMENT I KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
RUNNING LOW ON TIME BUT BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
TREATMENT CENTER I ASK YOU NOT
TO TO TRY TO STOP YOU BECAUSE
OP I DON'T KNOW IF WE EVEN
HAVE A A DESIGNATED TREATMENT
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY BOARD
OR IN NORTH COUNTY WHERE -- YOU
OFFICER OTHER POLICE OFFICER
IN A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
COUNTY NO LIKE HEY IF IF THERE
IS A FIFTY ONE FIFTY CASE AND
AND THAT PERSON IS A PUBLIC
DISTURBANCE IT'S A DANGER TO
HIMSELF AND OTHER PEOPLE LIKE
YOU OFFICER KNOW WHERE TO TAKE
THE PERSON RIGHT RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T HAVE SUCH A TREATMENT
CENTER AND THEN THE OUR ROOMS
YEAH THERE'S VERY FEW BEDS AND
I WILL TELL YOU THAT AS PART
OF THE TASK FORCE A BUNCH OF
US WENT TO PHOENIX ARIZONA AND
TOOK A LOOK AT THEIR TO ONE
ONE SYSTEM AND IF YOU HAVEN'T
DONE THAT YET I WOULD HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE YOU -- THAT IS A
WRAPAROUND SYSTEM THAT YOU CAN
GET THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND THEY HAVE A RAPID RESPONSE
TEAM THAT WILL RESPOND OUT TO
THAT CALL FOR SERVICE AND TAKE
THAT INDIVIDUAL OFF THE HANDS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER CREE CAN
CLEAR TO GO TO OTHER CALLS IT'S
IT'S A PHENOMENAL SYSTEM AND
IT AND IT'S PAID FOR VIA THEIR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM -- AND IT'S
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO EVENTUALLY SEE HAPPEN
HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY A SIMILAR
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN ORANGE
-- MENTAL HEALTH I I BELIEVE
IS A TOPIC THAT'S IT'S NOT BEEN
TALKED ABOUT ENOUGH AND BEEN
ON YOU KNOW AS FAR AS PROVIDING
FUNDING TO ADDRESS IT BECAUSE
IT'S IT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM
THANK YOU TO THEM THANK YOU
CHIEF YOU SAID THAT BASED ON
YOUR EXPERIENCE YOUR ESTIMATE
AS THE SERVICE REYES THIS TIME
POPULATION IS THAT IT'S FORTY
PERCENT OF THE FOLKS THINK
IT'S ABOUT THAT WHEN ACT WHAT'S
THE RANGE OF REASONS THAT
PEOPLE ARE SERVICE RESISTANT
YOU KNOW I I I THINK A LOT --
JUST TELL LIKE DON'T MIND BEING
ALMOST DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH
-- GOING INTO A SHELTER AND
FOLLOWING RULES AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO DRINK ALCOHOL AND NOT
BEING ABLE USE DRUGS AND --
THEY JUST WANT TO BE LEFT ALONE
AND AND TO THEMSELVES THERE'S
PLENTY OF FOOD FOR THEM AND
COMMUNITIES THAT PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE EATEN
-- YOU KNOW WE WE DON'T USUALLY
BOTHER THEM WITH THEIR NOT
VIOLATING THE LAWS AND I COULD
JUST ENJOY THAT TYPE OF LIFE
ANDERSON ON THANK YOU ALSO FOR
MAKING AB IN MAKING THE POINT
ABOUT JUST HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS FOR US TO BUILD A SYSTEM
OF CARE AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HERE IN OUR
COUNTY AND ALL ACROSS THE STATE
THAT IS FAILING CAN MIGRATE I
THINK WE'RE TAKING SOME GOOD
STEPS HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY
WITH THE GROUND BREAKING UP THE
WELL TO START TO CLOSE THAT GAP
IT IT IS A YAWNING GAP RIGHT
NOW AND A BIG PART OF THAT
A BIG PART OF THE CHALLENGER
FACING ITS CATCH UP YEAH
ABSOLUTELY THANKS THANKS THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU TO THIS GROUP
OF PANELISTS THAT -- FOCUSED ON
STRATEGIES WE'VE I THINK HEARD
QUITE A BIT JUST IN THIS FIRST
PANEL SO WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
TO SECOND WITH OUR OF A CITY
MANAGER WHO IS GOING TO MAKE
A REAL QUICK COMMENT THEN WILL
DO LITTLE FIVE MINUTE BREAK
BECAUSE AGAIN I'M ONE OF THOSE
CLASSROOM TEACHERS THAT KNOW
THAT AFTER A POINT IF YOU DON'T
MOVE YOU'RE GONNA START LOSING
INTEREST -- BUT THIS IS CITY
MANAGER THEM -- JIM VANDERPOOL
THAT IS A PARTNER HERE WOULD
NOT ONLY INVITE APART BUT
WITH CHIEF COREY SINUS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IN THE STEAM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE -- TO THE PUBLIC
-- IN NORTH ORANGE COUNTY IN
ORANGE COUNTY AS A WHOLE --
I WANNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
JUST FROM A CITY PERSPECTIVE
UP BEYOND WHAT SHE SIGNED AS
A SHARED WITH THE COMMITTEE
WITH THE PUBLIC -- MORE FROM
AN ADMINISTRATIVE MAY BE
FINANCIAL KIND OF OPERATIONAL
PERSPECTIVE -- AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
-- CITIES IN CALIFORNIA --
-- WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
LARGER CALIFORNIA CITIES --
ARE NOT PREPARED FOR TAKING
THE LEAD ROLE IN THIS ISSUE
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY PREPARED
TO BE A PARTNER -- WE RECOGNIZE
THAT IT'S REGIONAL ISSUE AND
-- -- SOLUTIONS BY A CITY
BY CITY -- BASIS OUR CASE
ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE -- CAN DOWN THE
FUNDING OF COURSE -- CITIES
WE FILL POTHOLES -- WE KEEP
NEIGHBORHOOD SAFE WE PROVIDE
PARKS SERVICES WE PROVIDE
SENIOR CENTERS ON THE MYRIAD OF
-- SAFE WATER ON HOMELESSNESS
IS NOT ONE -- THAT WE -- --
HAVE TRADITIONALLY PROVIDED --
THE CHIEF MENTIONED DIALOGUE
THAT WE ENGAGE WITH THE CITY
COUNCIL I IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW ARE WE GOING INTO THE
HOMELESS BUSINESS AND NOT
TO BE YOU KNOW -- -- LIGHT
IN ANY CAPACITY BUT IT WAS A
POLICY QUESTION FOR THE CITY
COUNCIL AND YOU THINK OF THE
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY CITIES
-- THAT ARE GOING THROUGH --
-- SALES TAX MEASURES JUST
TO MAINTAIN THE SERVICES THAT
THEY TRADITIONALLY PROVIDE
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT ADDING
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES TO THAT
AND THE EXPENSES RELATED TO
THAT IT'S QUITE A BURDEN --
-- IT WE WOULD REQUEST THAT
THE STATE LOOK AT -- POSSIBLY
REWARDING THOSE CITIES AND
THOSE REGIONS THAT ARE WORKING
COOPERATIVELY ON TO TAKE THIS
ISSUE ON A PRO ACTIVELY AND
POSSIBLY INCENTIVIZE OR REWARD
THOSE CITIES WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE DIRECT ALLOCATION IN THE
LEGISLATION FROM THIS LAST
YEAR FOR THE THIRTEEN LARGEST
CITIES JUST OUR NORTH SPOT
ALONE REPRESENT ABOUT ALMOST
A MILLION PEOPLE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY SO IF THERE'S
SOME MECHANISM TO DO A DIRECT
ALLOCATION FOR THOSE CITIES
AND THOSE REGIONS ARE WORKING
COOPERATIVELY TO TO GET FUNDING
-- I I THINK THAT WOULD REALLY
INCENTIVIZE -- A PROACTIVE MORE
PROACTIVE ACTION -- YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE CHALLENGED -- WAS
SPENDING MORE ON RESPONSES TO
HOMELESSNESS NOT EVEN PROVIDING
THE SHELTERING AT JUST THE
RESPONSE TO THE DILEMMA THAT'S
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS -- POLICE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL FIRE PUBLIC
WORKS CLEAN UP AND WE CANNOT
STOP DOING THOSE SERVICES AND
THAT WOULD BE THE FUNDING WE
COULD POTENTIALLY PROVIDE TO
SHELTERING -- I DO WANT TO
TOUCH ON ONE THING THE CHIEF
MENTIONED THAT IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SB TWO WAS REALLY
ESTABLISHED AS WE UNDERSTAND
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE ARE
DIVERTING ALMOST A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THOSE FUNDS FOR
HOMELESS SHELTER WHICH IS A
CRITICAL NEED BUT THE NEED
IS AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN
REDEVELOPMENT WAS ABOLISHED
AND WE LOST THAT SET ASIDE
FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT WAS CRITICAL AND
IF I CAN MAKE A PAGE TO THE
LEGISLATORS IN THIS ROOM AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN SACRAMENTO
TO CONSIDER INCREMENTS
FINANCING IN SOME CAPACITY
TO BRING BACK CITIES ABILITY
TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT WOULD BE A PHENOMENAL
AND FINALLY -- NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY IN THE TWELVE CITIES
THAT ARE PART OF THE SPA AND
CERTAINLY THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
THE CAME UP WITH A REGIONAL
SOLUTION OPEN UP TO SHELTERS
AND WORK COLLECTIVELY TO FIND
NOT ONLY THE CONSTRUCTION BUT
ALSO THE OPERATIONS WE ARE
HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN SACRAMENTO
TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO TAKE
OUR STORY TO SACRAMENTO TO
TAKE THIS -- OUR REGIONAL
APPROACH TO HOMELESSNESS AND
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS WE CAN
DO TO HELP YOU DELIVER THAT
MESSAGE WE'RE HAPPY TO DO
THAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CITY MANAGER
SO AS WE HAVE A SOMBER
CONVERSATION WE ALSO HAVE
LIGHT TO WHERE WE SEE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SEEN A CRITICAL ISSUE
IN EVERY SPONDE IT AND SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE NOT ONLY
A LOCAL ELECTED IS THAT ARE
HERE BUT ALSO THE NOR SPA CHRIS
WE'D LIKE TO SELL TO THE SOUTH
BUT REALLY ALL OF THE COUNTY
WHO IS INVESTING THEIR TIME
IN THIS SO WITH THAT WILL DO
LIKE I'M INSANE THREE MINUTES
BECAUSE THAT MEANS IF WE DON'T
SAY THREE PEOPLE TAKE TEN SO
THREE MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL BE
BACK WITH OUR SECOND HALF PANEL
NOT A PROBLEM OKAY YEAH HOUSE
COMING IN AT THAT ARE
CHAMBER IN THE MY DISTRICT
ORANGE COUNTY
HI
YEAH YEAH SOME OF THAT
WHEN THE MARKET
LIKE WHEN
THERE HAVE HER LIKE
YES MISS CARLY I ONLY WILL
AND I'M NOT SURE I JUST
REALLY LOW IN THE
THIS IS A PROBLEM EVEN
YEAH
I DON'T KNOW
YES GUYS THERE'S
IT'S LIKE A HUNDRED
YEAH
FAMILY
NO I'M GOOD I'M
WELL I
ALONG
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND START BACK
WITH OUR SECOND PANEL
THAT CLOSE
YEAH IN THE SAME ONE
I ACTUALLY LEFT REALLY
LIKE REALLY REALLY
A REALLY
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND START WE ARE A LITTLE
OVER TIME HERE BUT WE WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF OUR
PANELISTS WILL BE AVAILABLE
AT THE END IF YOU HAVE ANY OF
THE INDIVIDUAL QUESTIONS FOR
THEM IF YOU SIGN UP WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN EMAIL YOU
THE PRESENTATIONS AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC EMAIL OR OR
QUESTIONS FOR ANY OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS -- PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CONTACT THEIR OFFICES REGARDING
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I'M PLEASED
TO INTRODUCE OUR SECOND
PANEL HERE WE HAVE THE TITLE
EVERYONE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY
AND I WILL LET THE PANELISTS
AND INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND
WE WILL BEGAN WITH A OF FORMER
MAYOR PRO TEM OF THE CITY OF
SANTA ANA MACHEL MARTINEZ THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND TO THE
-- AND STEAM SELECT COMMITTEE
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY YOU
KNOW RECENTLY I'VE BEEN READING
THE BOOK TALKING TO STRANGERS
FROM MAX WELL I'M GLAD WELL
ANY SAYS WE MISS READ THOSE
WE DON'T KNOW I THINK WE AS
GOVERNMENT ARE MISREADING EACH
OTHER WHAT WE'VE GOT HERE IS
A FAILURE TO COMMUNICATE WHEN
WERE DRESSING HOMELESSNESS AND
WHY I BEGIN THAT WAY IS THAT
I'VE BEEN ON THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WORKING WITH FEDERAL
COURT JUDGE DAVID -- CARTER
ON HOMELESSNESS AS A PRO BONO
POLICY ADVISER ON WITH CITIES
I AM NO LONGER ELECTED BUT WHEN
I REALIZE THAT THIS IS NOT A
CITY ISSUE THIS IS NOT A STATE
ISSUE THIS IS NOT A COUNTY
ISSUE IS NOT JUST A FEDERAL
ISSUE THIS IS EVERYONE'S ISSUE
WE CANNOT SOLVE HOMELESSNESS
IF WE FIRST CANNOT COMMUNICATE
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE LACKED IN
COMMUNICATION FROM THE FEDERAL
LEVEL ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL IT TOOK A FEDERAL
COURT JUDGE TO REMOVE THOUSANDS
OF FOLKS FROM THE RIVER BACK
FROM OUR CIVIC CENTER MANY
OF US FOR MANY YEARS AND MANY
OF YOU ARE APPEAR ARE NEW TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU OFFERS FOR REALLY
REALLY NOT THEIR SLEEVES AND
REALLY HAVING THIS DIALOGUE
HERE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE
THIS WASN'T HAPPENING IN THE
PAST BUT IT TOOK A FEDERAL
COURT JUDGE AND YOU ALL TO NOW
THIS FIGURE WE'RE NOW FIGURING
OUT THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
IS STEPPING UP TO THE PLATE
AND IS BUILDING EMERGENCY
SHELTERS BUT IS THAT THE
BUSINESS IS A CITY SHOULD BE IN
IS THE QUESTION THAT WE
ALL NEED TO ASK OURSELVES
I WANT TO THANK THE STATE
FROM MOVING FORWARD AND
ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS WITH
NEW WITH OF COURSE WITH ADDING
YOU -- EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
TO ADDRESS A BUILDING THESE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU
ALL HAVE PROVIDED -- AND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION GOING
TO CITIES ABOUT MORE POORLY
IT'S GOING TO THE THIRTEEN
ON LARGEST CITIES I WOULD ASK
AND IMPLORE YOU ALL TO LOOK
AT SMALLER CITIES BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
IMPACTED THE MOLES WITH THE
LAST RESOURCES CITIES LIKE
LA ORANGE AND BIG CITIES IN
ORANGE COUNTY LIKE ANAHEIM IN
SANTA ANA YOU KNOW HAVE MORE
RESOURCES THAN A CITY LIKE
WHEN A PARK AND SO OR LIKE A
CITY LIKE COSTA MESA OR CITY
LIKE WESTMINSTER THERE HAVE
BEEN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
ONE TIME FUNDS TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS FOR SHELTERS IS
NOT THE ANSWER AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL A LOT OF THESE FUNDS WILL
BE ONE TIME FUNDS CITIES CANNOT
SUSTAIN THESE NEW SHELTERS
WITH ONE TIME MONIES AND THESE
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE BEEN
ADDRESS ADDRESSING AT THE
FEDERAL COURT AS CITIES HAVE
BEEN A SETTLING POLICE AND FIRE
COSTS WERE TALKED ABOUT WHEN
WE'RE ADDRESSING THE HOMELESS
COMMUNITY THAT IS PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST COSTS FOR CITIES IS
FIRE POLICE SERVICES AGAIN WE
ARE ALSO NOT MAXIMIZING THE
PUBLIC LAND THAT WE OWN WHETHER
IT'S FEDERAL STATE OR LOCAL
WE SHOULD BE MAXIMIZING JUST
BUILDING A EMERGENCY SHELTER ON
PUBLIC ON PUBLIC LAND WHETHER
IT'S STATE OR LOCAL AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO DO INTEGRATED
HOUSING OR TAKING PROPERTY
LIKE MOTELS OFF THE PROPERTY
TAX ROLLS DOES NOT HELP THE
CITY AND SO THESE ARE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT AND SOME OF THE
OTHER UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT CREATED THIS HOMELESS
CRISIS THAT I SEE BEFORE US IN
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE COULD HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HERE TODAY AND THAT
IS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT PROP
THIRTEEN AND ALSO SB FIFTY ONE
FIFTY FOUR AND AB EIGHT WHICH
IS THE PROPERTY TAX ALLOCATION
FORMULAS FOR CITIES NOT ALL
CITIES ARE CREATED EQUAL AND
SO CERTAIN CITIES GET CERTAIN
PERCENT PERCENTAGE BACK ON
PROPERTY TAX AND THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WANTING
TO BUILD YOU KNOW HOUSING
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
THAT COMES ALSO WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR CITIES THESE
FIRE PUBLIC WORKS PARKS AND
RECREATION I CAN GO ON AND ON
AND SO WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS
A TEMPORARY SOLUTION THAT THE
FEDERAL COURT IN ORANGE COUNTY
HAS PROVIDED PROVIDING TWELVE
HUNDRED TEMPORARY SHELTER BEDS
IS NOT A FINAL SOLUTION FOR
ORANGE COUNTY AND OR FOR THE
REST OF THIS REGION OR THIS
STATE I WOULD IMPLORE YOU
ALL TO LOOK AT THESE FUNDING
ALLOCATION SYSTEMS AND SYSTEMS
FUNDING SYSTEMS THAT ARE
SUSTAINABLE FOR CITIES NOW THAT
WE'RE MOVING INTO THIS BUSINESS
BECAUSE WE CANNOT IGNORE THIS
ISSUE ANYMORE AS AS AS CITIES
THAT IN FRONT OF OUR FACE THE
PUBLIC DOESN'T CARE WHO THE
JURISDICTION IS WHETHER IT'S
THE COUNTY'S ROLE WHETHER IT'S
A STATE ROLE OR FEDERAL WHILE
THEY'RE LOOKING AT LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND MAYORS AND
SAY THIS IS YOUR JOB YOU BETTER
ADDRESS IT AND SO WITH THAT YOU
KNOW I JUST WANT TO IN IN IN
THE PAST NINE MONTHS THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH JUDGE CARTER
ON ON TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO HELP CITIES MAXIMIZE
THEIR ABILITY AND REALLY
ENDING AND SHOWING -- THE JUDGE
CARTER THAT CITIES ARE BEING
IMPACTED IN WAYS LIKE NEVER
BEFORE WHETHER YOU'RE DEALING
WITH PENSION PROBLEMS WITH
PROP THIRTEEN THAT TOOK AWAY
FORTY PERCENT OF CITIES LOCAL
FUNDING THREE PERCENT F.
FIFTY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED IN REGARDS TO PENSIONS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ALL
THOSE THINGS HAD UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES AND SO I THINK
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD THIS
WILL NOT BE ADDRESSED WITHOUT
ALSO THE CITY THE CITY'S
ADMITTING THAT WE CHOSE NOT
TO ZONE APPROPRIATELY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BECAUSE
NOT IN MY BACKYARD SO WE
HAVE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THAT THEY WE LACKED
MANY OF US LACK THE COURAGE
TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THE AFFORDABILITY PROBLEMS
THAT WE ARE FACING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE NOW CAUSING
OTHER UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
LIKE SINGLE MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN ARE ENDING UP HOMELESS
THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN AT
LEVELS SO HIGH BEFORE WHEN I
LOOK AT SANTA ANA AND I LOOK
AT THE LINK AND TO SEE THE
MOUNT OF CHILDREN THAT ARE
IN THAT HOMELESS SHELTER WAS
SINGLE MOTHERS OR IT'S AN
AGING HOMELESS POPULATION IS
CONTINUING TO RISE THIS IS JUST
THE BEGINNING OF OUR PROBLEM
BEFORE IT GETS BETTER IT'S
GOING TO GET WORSE BECAUSE WE
DO NOT HAVE THE HOUSING STOCK
IN OUR COMMUNITIES TO SUSTAIN
THE CURRENT GROWTH IN EACH
OF OUR CITIES AND SO THIS IS
NOT AN EASY JOB THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
OVERNIGHT OR COUNTY GOVERNMENT
OR THE CITY IT'S GOING TO TAKE
ALL OF US TOGETHER WE ALL HAVE
A ROLE TO PLAY BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CITY SHOULD SHOULD NOT BE THE
LEADERS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING STREAMS
TO SUSTAIN WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US AND SO WITH THAT I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
CONTINUING TO GO ON THIS TOUR
A BECAUSE I HOPE THAT THIS
IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF THIS
SELECT COMMITTEES OF YOU KNOW
TOUR HERE IN INTO AN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN HEARING FROM
THE PUBLIC AND FROM THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS I'M NOT JUST IN
THIS COUNTY BUT THROUGHOUT
THIS ENTIRE REGION OF BECAUSE
I REALLY BELIEVE THE ANSWER
IS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THOSE
ADVOCATES THAT ARE WORKING
WITH THE HOMELESS POPULATION
OR THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN ROLLING UP
THEIR SLEEVES FOR TWENTY
THIRTY YEARS THEY HAVE ALSO --
IN THIS ISSUE BUT ONE SINGLE
WHAT I BELIEVE AT THE END OF
THE DAY THAT HAS BEEN MISSING
IT'S IT'S THE REALLY THE COOP
THE COOPERATION BETWEEN ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT WE HAVE
SEEN OVER THE PAST IN MY TWELVE
YEARS OF OFFICE A DISCONNECT
OF OF COMMUNICATING WITH OUR
STATE LEGISLATORS WITH OUR
COUNTY OFFICIALS IN WANTING
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IN
IN A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
AND SO HERE WE ARE TODAY BUT
I BELIEVE AT THIS PRESENT
MOMENT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP MITIGATE THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEFORE US IF WE
COME TOGETHER SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
-- I'D JUST LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT REGARDING MIGHT NOT
ONLY FRIEND BUT COLLEAGUES
FROM MY COUNSEL DAYS MICHELLE
MARTINEZ AND IT'S NOT JUST TO
SEE HER PASSION AND WORKING
ON THESE DAYS ARE DIFFICULT
SCENARIOS THAT CITIES FACE AS
FAR AS HOW DO YOU ALLOCATE YOUR
DOLLARS WHAT KIND OF BUDGET DO
YOU HAVE ANY MANY CASES I START
IN ON COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR AND FULLER TEN AND I CAN
TELL YOU FROM TWO THOUSAND FOUR
TO TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND I'D
LOVE TO GO TO THE STATE THIS
WAS JUST EMERGING SO WE DID
NOT HAVE BUDGET DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT YOU KNOW MERGING SEE
SHELTERS ABOUT NAVIGATION
CENTERS AS A MATTER OF FACT I
WAS ON COUNCIL WE AND WE HAD
THE DEATHS OF KELLY THOMAS
AND IF THAT HAD NOT ONLY THAT
THE IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY TO
FOCUS ON ON A KELLY THOMAS WAS
A SCHIZOPHRENIC MAN WHO MANY
PEOPLE KNEW IN OUR CITY BUT
IT ALSO FOCUSED OUR CITY ON
ON POLICE REFORM AND FOCUSED
OUR CITY ON WHAT ARE WE
DOING WITH BEST PRACTICES FOR
HOMELESSNESS AND IT WAS REALLY
THE VERY BEGINNINGS OF THIS
-- THAT HAS MATERIALIZED IN
AND REALLY EXPLODED SO I KNOW
THAT SOME OF THE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY OF SIR HAVE SEEN
FROM IN MY CASE TWO THOUSAND
FOUR TO NOW TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A DRAMATIC SHIFT IN
THE CONVERSATION BUT NOW WE
HAVE SOMETHING IN FRONT OF US
IN THE NEXT QUESTION IS WHAT DO
WE DO ABOUT IT SO WITH THAT I
WILL INTRODUCE OUR NEXT SORRY
AS I DUG INTO IT I REALIZING
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU SAID AGAIN
THERE'S A LOT OF CONFUSION IN
TERMS OF WHAT IS THE ROLE AS
THE STATE THE COUNTY CITIES
ALL OF OUR ENGAGE NONPROFITS
IN SOLVING NESS AND THE BEFORE
WE CAN ACTUALLY BEFORE WE
NEED CLARITY ON RESPONSIBILITY
AND I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ALIGNING
RESPONSIBILITY WITH RESOURCES
SO IF YOU ARE STARTING WITH
IN A BLANK SLATE WHAT DO
YOU THINK IS THE ROLE AS THE
CITY'S VERSES THE COUNTY IN
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE SHOULD SUPPORT OUR LAND
USE AND ZONING TO ACCOMMODATE
HOMELESS SHELTERS NAVIGATION
CENTERS WHATEVER WE WANT TO
CALL THEM PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING ATTAINABLE I DON'T
CALL IT AFFORDABLE HOUSING A
CALL ATTAINABLE HOUSING THE
THE -- THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT CITIES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOU KNOW AS A BURKE
PERTAINS TO MENTAL HEALTH THAT
IS NOT IN OUR PREVIEW THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO
OUR POLICE STRUGGLE OUR FIRE
STRUGGLE ON THAT IS MORE BY
COUNTY ROLE SO I THINK FROM
BEING ABLE TO BE SUPPORTED
TO DESIGNATE THE LAND USES
AND SONY TO ACCOMMODATE THE
HOUSING THAT WE NEED IS THE
CITY'S ROLE ARE CAN WE PROVIDE
-- CBG GRANT FUNDING THAT'S
GIVEN TO US FROM THE FEDS AND
STATE FOR -- HOMELESS SHELTERS
IN PROVIDER MONIES THAT WAY
AND LEVERAGE THEM HOWEVER WE
POSSIBLY CAN WITH THE COUNTY
WE SHOULD DEFINITELY DO THAT --
SO I THINK THAT IS THE INITIAL
ROLE BUT TODAY THAT HAS CHANGED
WE'RE NOW IN THE BUSINESS OF
BUILDING HOMELESS SHELTERS
WHICH WE CANNOT SUSTAIN WE
HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT THAT
THERE'S NO WAY GETTING YOU
KNOW SB TWO FUNDS OR THIS NEW
MONIES COMING DOWN THIS ONE
TIME MONEY SO HOW WE GOING
TO STAY IN THESE OPERATIONS
AND NOT ONLY THAT YOU KNOW WE
HAVE CODE ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE
ALL THESE CODE ENFORCEMENT
TEAMS OUT THERE IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR POLICE ARE ARE PARKS
AND REC AND THE MORE MORE WE
GROW THE MORE MORE SERVICES
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES NEED AND
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH -- REVENUE
COMING IN TO SUSTAIN THAT
A GREAT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YET THANK YOU
SO I HAVE AT NINE CITIES TO ARE
GRAPPLING WITH THE SITUATION
ALSO AND ARE TRYING TO BE
PROACTIVE ON AND ARE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH JUDGE CARTER IN
OUR NOT HAVING THAT DISCUSSION
THAT THEY HAVE GONE INTO THE
BUSINESS OF HOMELESSNESS BUT
THEY'RE DOWN FACING WITH THE
REALITY OF HOW DO WE PAY FOR
THIS FOR A WHILE THE FELLOW
THEY'RE NOT EQUIPPED WITH
THE SKILL SET BUT BE THERE
DEFINITELY THINKING ABOUT
THOSE DOLLARS WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO COME FROM BUT THEY'RE
HEARING FROM THE CONSTITUENTS
AND THEY SAID THAT THEY CAN'T
WAIT FOR ALL OF US FIGURE IT
OUT THE COUNTY FOR ALL OF ITS
BECAUSE HER FIGHT TO SEE AN
ACTION BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
STRESS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL NOW
IS HE TAKING THIS ACTION IF
AND THERE'S DIFFERENT MODELS
I MEAN IF THE FUNDING COMES
AND IT'S A STATE OF WILL TO
THE CITY'S BE IN THE BUSINESS
OF RUNNING THESE OPERATIONS
ARE SHOULD IT SHOULD BE IN
THE COUNTY OR SOMEBODY ELSE IS
ALSO PART OF THE QUESTION THAT
THERE THAT WE'RE GRAPPLING WITH
AND SO WHAT WOULD HE SAY THAT
SO I WOULD SAY THAT TODAY'S
A NEW DAY WORD TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY GOVERNMENT AND WE'VE
NOW ARE STEPPING UP TO TAKE
ON THIS ROLE AND SO I WOULD
SAY THAT YES CITIES CAN BUILD
THE BRICK AND MORTAR IT IT IS
KIND OF PRIVATIZING IT OUT TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WHETHER
TO LIMÓN NATION FOUNDATION
MERCY HOUSE ON AND SO FORTH
IF WE HAVE THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING STREAM
TO GIVE THOSE MONIES TO THOSE
NONPROFIT I DON'T SEE WHY NOT
A CITY CANNOT PARTNER WITH
UP THE PRIVATE WITH WITH THE
NONPROFIT I CALL IN A P.
FOR NOT A P. THREE WHICH
IS A PEOPLE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP THE THE PEOPLE
ARE THE HOMELESS COMMUNITY IN
HAVING AND ENSURING THAT WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE I THINK WHEN WE
LOOK AT BUILDING ON EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND THE BUT THIS VERY
CITIES IN YOUR CITY AND MY
GOOD FRIEND WAS THE MAYOR OF
JUAN GARCIA BELLFLOWER HAD THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THEM FOR OVER
A YEAR AND WE'RE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING HIM WITH JUDGE CARTER WAS
THAT WE CANNOT CLOSE OUR EYES
WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING RIGHT
SO I WOULD SAY THAT YES WE CAN
MOVE TOWARDS SUSTAINABILITY IF
THE STATE IS COMMITTED TO GET
A NOSE ONGOING RESOURCES TO
SUSTAIN THE OPERATIONS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT COST THE MOST WHEN
YOU'RE GIVING US THE ONE TIME
FUNDS FOR BRICK AND MORTAR THAT
IS FANTASTIC THAT'S EASY TO TO
NO BRAINER BUT IT'S THE ONGOING
COST SO A LOT OF THESE GRANTS
THERE'S A SUNSET SO WHAT'S NEXT
AFTER THIS BILLION DOLLARS IS
GONE WHAT ARE CITIES GOING TO
DO I GUESS THAT'S THE QUESTION
THAT EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
YOUR DISTRICT SHOULD BE ASKING
AND THEY SHOULD PUT A PAUSE
OR CAN THEY LEVERAGE THEIR
RESOURCES AND SAY HEY WE'RE
GONNA USE PUBLIC SAFETY WE'RE
GONNA BE LIKE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY CREATE THIS PARTNERSHIP
A GPA AND SAY HATE FIVE CITIES
ARE GOING TO COME TOGETHER AND
SHARE PUBLIC SAFETY RESOURCES
WE'RE GOING TO SHARE AND
LEVERAGE OUR CBG FUNDING AND
AND PUT IT TOGETHER AND CREATE
-- A SYSTEM THAT HELPS ONE
THE HELP EACH OF THE CITIES SO
THAT ONE CITY DOESN'T AND KERR
MOST OF THE COSTS AND SO YOU
KNOW I BELIEVE THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY SPOT MODEL IS AN OPTION
-- BUT AS BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY I DO BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE
PLAYS A ROLE IN THIS BUT AGAIN
IT'S GOING TO COME DOWN TO
LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
FOR CITIES AND SO WE'VE WE'VE
HAD THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
SHELTERS WHICH IS THE EMERGENCY
HOUSING BUT THERE'S BEEN
MULTIPLE COMMENTS TODAY BEING
MADE BY A NUMBER OF PANELISTS
THE CITY MANAGER THAT WE HAVE
A HOUSE IS A PLACE YOU KNOW WE
NEED AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT'S
MORE PERMANENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WOULD ALL HAVE THIS CONTINUOUS
CYCLE GOING ON IS A FIFTY TO
SAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
YOU A SINGLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR THIS EMERGENCY SHELTERS
YOU SHOULD BE WE SHOULD BE
MANDATED SOME SORT OF SIGNING
TO GUARANTEE THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO FILL THE I MEAN WE HAVE A
DENSITY ISSUE COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE I WOULD GO BEYOND JUST
EMERGENCY SHELTERS YOU NEED
INTEGRATED HOUSING RIGHT SO YOU
BUILD SO THIS IS WHERE I TALK
ABOUT MAXIMIZING YOUR LAND IF
YOU'RE GOING TO MATCH MY STATE
FEDERAL OR LOCAL LAND YOU WANT
TO DO INTEGRATED HOUSING BUILD
A SHELTER AT THE BOTTOM AND
AND AND DO YOU KNOW SINGLE I
FORGET WHAT THEY'RE CALLED --
SINGLE ROOM OCCUPANCY AND OTHER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES SO YOU CAN
MAXIMIZE YOUR LAN AND MAXIMIZE
YOUR RESOURCES AND LEVERAGE
AS MUCH AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN
BUT JUST BUILDING AN EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND SPENDING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND THEN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT OKAY WHERE AM
I GONNA FIND GLAND TODAY BILL
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
ON AND SO FORTH I THINK IF WE
WANT TO INDUSTRY HOMELESSNESS
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT INTEGRATED
MODELS AND AND AND UNDERSTAND
THAT SPEAK SPECIFICALLY IN YOUR
AREA ASSEMBLY GARCIA YOU GUYS
HAVE A SMALL FOOTPRINT RIGHT
SO YOU GUYS ARE PRETTY BUILT
OUT YOU'RE GOING TO EITHER HAVE
TO GO UP AND LOOK AT THE LAND
THAT YOU HAVE AVAILABLE BUT
YOU CAN'T JUST BUILD A SHELTER
STAND ALONE AND THEN TRY TO
FIND SOMEWHERE ELSE TO BUILD
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
BECAUSE IT'S NEVER GOING TO
PENCIL OUT AND SO I AGREE WE
NEED TO BE BUILDING AL AND
SO I'M HAPPY TO SEE THAT MY
CITIES ARE STARTING TO TAKE
HIS PRACTICE STEPS AND I THINK
AT A MINIMUM ABOUT THE RAPPER
OF AT THE SHELTER CENTER AND
IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR A WHILE
WHEN I GOT ELECTED SEVEN YEARS
AGO WE WE DON'T EVEN HAVE
HOMELESS PEOPLE HERE AND I
THINK OR DO YOU SO THEY OPEN
THEIR EYES A LITTLE BIT RIGHT
AND SO PROGRESS THEY'RE NOT
HAVE OTHER MY CITIES IN THAT
WHO ARE NOT TAKING BOTH HOURS
LEAD -- AS WELL BUT THERE'S
THIS BIG FIGHT AGAIN ABOUT
BUILDING UP IN MY CITIES HAVE
ALSO BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
FIGHTING THE BUILDUP MODEL AND
BUT THIS KIND OF KNOW WHERE
ELSE TO OTHER RIGHTS I THOUGHT
THE STATE I WANT TO HELP MY
CITIES GET THAT CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION MANY DENTAL TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AFTER THINKING
ABOUT BUILDING UP AND HOW DO WE
GET COMMUNITIES TO DO THAT AND
BE READY FOR THAT BECAUSE THE
ABILITY THE CHARGE AGAINST THIS
IDEA OF BUILDING UP BUT THERE'S
NOWHERE ELSE TO BUILD TO STEP
COULD I LIVE IN IN MY HOMETOWN
SORT OF THE DEFICIT PUTS IN
THE WHOLE COUNTRY EXACTLY
ALL RIGHT SO WE OURS NOW REALLY
STARTING TO BE BEHIND ON TIME
IS SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO OUR NEXT TWO PANELS
AND FOR THE THE MEMBERS OUT
THERE WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS -- SO I AM LOOKING
AT THE CLOCK AND WE'RE GONNA
MAKE SURE YOU GET THE TIME THAT
SPECIFIED BUT ON THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
WRAP UP THE WHOLE PROGRAM BY
ELEVEN THIRTY SO THAT WOULD
PUT US A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
BUT AGAIN MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
A CONTACT NUMBER IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN ALWAYS
GET INFORMATION TIAS SO WITHOUT
WE'RE GOING TO -- BRING FORWARD
TO OUR NEXT PANELIST SUSAN
PRICE WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
CARE COORDINATION FOR ORANGE
COUNTY I KNOW SHE'S CALLED
BIZARRE AHEAD OF HOMELESSNESS
-- IMPROBABLY OTHER NAMES BUT
I ONLY SAY THAT BECAUSE ANY
OF US WHO ARE WORKING FORWARD
WE DON'T ALWAYS GET CALLED THE
BEST NAMES IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THINGS
THAT PEOPLE JUST EITHER AREN'T
FAMILIAR WORTH I DON'T WANT SO
WITHOUT SUSAN SO WITH THAT ALSO
YOU CAN CALL ME SU IF YOU'D
LIKE -- BUT THERE'S NO OTHER
NAMES -- GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY -- FOR WHAT IS A ROBUST
DIALOGUE ABOUT SOMETHING I'M
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT AND THAT
IS HOMELESSNESS AND THE IMPACTS
ON OUR COMMUNITY I AM OKAY
WHO'S GOT THE CLICKER BEHIND
ME YEAH AWESOME PERFECT -- SO
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS SLIDE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I THERE'S SO
MUCH DIALOGUE THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN HAD IN AND TO BE EFFICIENT
WITH TIME I JUST KIND OF WANT
TO TALK ABOUT -- SOME OF THE
KEY HIGHLIGHTS THAT I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT
FOR US LOCALLY AND ON SOME OFF
SOME OPERATIONAL SUGGESTIONS
FOR THE STATE AS WELL SO WHEN
YOU KNOW IN IN MY ROLE WITH THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE I'VE I'VE BEEN
WITH THE COUNTY ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF YEARS AND WHEN I
DID MY INITIAL ASSESSMENT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN -- YOU KNOW
AT THAT TIME WE WERE HAVING THE
DIALOGUE ABOUT THE INTERSECTION
OF HOMELESSNESS WITH MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS ACROSS ANY COMMUNITY
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE EXCHANGE
THAT WE JUST HAD ABOUT KIND
OF WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IS IT
AND WHO IS TO DO WHICH PART OF
THIS IT'S KIND OF LIKE GOING
TO AN AIR SHOW AND WATCHING THE
BLUE ANGELS FLY WITHIN TWO FEET
OF EACH OTHER FIVE PLANES IN
ALIGNMENT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE FOR US TO
EFFECTIVELY SOLVE HOMELESSNESS
IN ANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THOSE FIVE PLANES INCLUDE
BASICALLY THE CITIES THE COUNTY
THE STATE THE CONSTITUENCIES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT
THESE SOLUTIONS AS WELL AS THE
HOMELESS POPULATION THEMSELVES
SO THAT WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
SERVICE RESISTANCE AND YOU
KNOW I COULD TALK FOR A WHILE
ABOUT THAT BUT I'M GOING TO
TABLE THAT FOR JUST A MOMENT
-- BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT ANYONE TRULY CHOOSES TO BE
HOMELESS I THINK SOMETIMES --
THE THE OVERWHELMING BARRIERS
THAT A PERSON FACES ALLOWS
HIM TO RESIGN THEMSELVES TO A
PLIGHT THAT SEEMS OVERWHELMING
TO OVERCOME AND SO WITH THAT
I'M JUST GONNA -- MOVE ON TO
HEALTH CARE AND TALK A BIT
ABOUT THE COUNTY'S ROLE IN
THE COUNTIES PARTNERS ON I'M
STILL ON THE FIRST SLIDE ON
HEALTH CARE IS YOU KNOW THE THE
STATE'S MEDICAID WAIVER PROGRAM
FOR WHOLE PERSON CARE GAVE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT HIGH
UTILIZES WHO ARE HOMELESS WHO
WORK -- INTERSECTING WITH --
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SYSTEM
A VERY KEY PROGRAM -- WHICH
I KNOW IS COMING TO AN END
IN THE NEXT YEAR OR SO --
THE COUNTY IS ALSO ENGAGING
VERY PROACTIVELY WITH CAL
OPTIMO WHICH IS OUR MEDI CAL
PROVIDER IN THE COUNTY -- TO
INTEGRATE THEIR EFFORTS ON THE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS THAT
WE HAVE I'M AS WAS MENTIONED
BY -- CHIEF C. N.
AS AROUND LAW ENFORCEMENT
NON PROFITS ARE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM ON THE STREETS DOING
MULTI DISCIPLINARY OUT
REACH TO THE POPULATIONS ARE
HOSPITALS ARE IMPACTED AS
IS OBVIOUSLY MENTIONED -- SB
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO AND HAVING
TO DISCHARGE PEOPLE THAT ARE
YOU KNOW MEDICALLY CLEARED
BUT VULNERABLE WHEN YOU'RE
COMING OUT OF AN INPATIENT
STAY YOU'RE STILL VULNERABLE
MEDICALLY EVEN THOUGH YOU MIGHT
BE MEDICALLY CLEARED LEGALLY
-- YOU KNOW IS THE SHELTER
SYSTEM THE MOST APPROPRIATE
PLACE -- YOU KNOW THE WHOLE
PERSON CARE PILOTS BEEN ABLE
TO FILL THAT GAP IN GIVING
US FOR COOPER OF CARE BEDS A
STEP DOWN MODEL FROM BEING AN
IN PATIENT IN THE HOSPITAL TO
HAVING AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF CARE UPON DISCHARGE AND
RECUPERATIVE CARES BEN REALLY
CRITICAL TO THAT ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH -- YOU KNOW THIS IS A
BIG TOPIC -- OF COURSE ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE AS WELL AS
ON THE ADDICTION SIDE AND I'LL
JUST MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
-- THE BE WELL INITIATIVE FOR
THE IN NEEDED DRIVE PROPERTY
WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS
AND PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
OF THAT FOR OVER A YEAR --
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY BEHIND THE
CURVE ON HOW MANY OF THOSE
WE ULTIMATELY NEED IN THE
COUNTY -- AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THIS MODEL COMING FORWARD THAT
WILL INFORM AND BE REPLICATED
BOWL NOT JUST IN ORANGE COUNTY
BUT ANYWHERE IN THE STATE --
AND THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO DECOMPRESS WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS TO TALK
ABOUT THE SOBERING CENTERS TO
DEAL WITH THE -- BE A CRISIS
THAT IS ALSO -- BEEN TOUCHED
UPON IN OUR DIALOGUE HERE
TODAY -- AND THAT IS YOU KNOW
ONE LOCATION WE TALK ABOUT
ACCESS AND NAVIGATION ACROSS
ANY OF OUR SYSTEMS OF CARE
ACCESS AND NAVIGATION ARE PART
OF OUR PROBLEM IN THAT PEOPLE
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW WHERE
OR HOW TO ACCESS SOME OF THESE
RESOURCES AND SO WHAT WE HEAR
TODAY IN WHAT WE WHAT WE SEE
ON OUR STREETS IS A TREMENDOUS
INFUSION AN EXPANSION OF OUR
OUT REACH CAPACITY -- TO REACH
THE POPULATIONS AND -- SO
I'M GONNA MOVE ON FROM THERE
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I'M I'M
LIMITED ON TIME -- I HAVE FIVE
MINUTES WHILE -- THIS IS ALL
THAT FIVE MINUTES I PROMISE
SO COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS ON
STEPPING UP INITIATIVE WE'VE
A RICHARD SANCHEZ JUST CAME UP
A MINUTE AGO TO TALK ABOUT HOW
DO WE GO FROM IN CUSTODY THE
OUT OF CUSTODY IN A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
AN OPIATE DISORDER THAT NEED
TO NEED TO GET MATT TREATMENT
IN CUSTODY AND OUT OF CUSTODY
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND WE LOOK AT OUR
REENTRY PROGRAMS AND I'M GONNA
JUST TALK ABOUT THESE BECAUSE
OF THE LIMITED TIME THAT WE
HAVE YOU KNOW WE CAN'T TALK
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AND JUST
FUND HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE RE ENTRY
SYSTEM REENTRY IS A RELATIVELY
NEW TOPIC -- FROM CORRECTIONAL
REFORM YOU KNOW OVER THE COURSE
FROM AS COREY C. N.
AS SAID TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO
NOW WE ALL OF A SUDDEN HAVE A
NEW LINE OF BUSINESS RE ENTRY
FROM OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM NONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
WERE WELL EQUIPPED HAD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE CAPACITY
TO ADDRESS REENTRY EFFECTIVELY
FROM THE BEGINNING SO THE
PROP FORTY SEVEN GRANTS THE
CAME OUT THEY WERE COMPETITIVE
GRANTS TO CAME FROM THE STATE
COMPETITIVE TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THAT WERE ALL IMPACTED
BY CORRECTIONAL REFORM BUT
NOT EVERY COUNTY GOT FUNDING
WE'RE FORTUNATE ORANGE COUNTY
TO RECEIVE SOME FUNDING ON
THE RE ENTRY PEACE BUT IT WAS
THREE YEARS AFTER THE REENTRY
OCCURRED AND SO ALL SAY TO
YOU THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT RE
ENTRY AND WE LOOK AT SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT SYSTEMS AND
PROGRAMS AROUND PROP FORTY
SEVEN IN THE DECLASSIFICATION
OF NON VIOLENT DRUG OFFENSES
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WASN'T
THERE TO RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
TO THOSE NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AND WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OFTENTIMES IS HOMELESSNESS
BUT I I I I ASK YOU TO NOT
LOOK AT HOMELESSNESS AS THE
PROBLEM HOMELESSNESS IS THE
SYMPTOM OF THE PROBLEM THE
PROBLEM IS ACTUALLY LOOKING
AT THE LOTS OF REDEVELOPMENT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND TEN
YEARS OF CITIES NOT HAVING
THE FUNDING TO CREATE HOUSING
THAT'S TEN YEAR ATTRITION OF
NOT DEVELOPING ANY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
CITIES OR THE HOUSING AND ON
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE SIDE NOT
HAVING AND THERE'S A LOT OF
LEGISLATIVE DIALOGUE GOING ON
IT'S VERY PROACTIVE AROUND THE
OVERSIGHT OF THESE THINGS --
ABOUT -- CREDENTIALING THESE
THINGS AS WE WOULD COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING FOR JUVENILES
AND AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
-- WE OFTEN STRUGGLE WITH HOW
ARE WE GOING TO -- IDENTIFY
WHAT'S THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT OPTION FOR A PERSON
WHEN THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
JUST NOT THERE -- SO IN THE
HEALTH CARE AGENCY THE DRUG
MEDI CAL PROGRAM ON THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE IS IMPLEMENTING THAT
WHICH GIVES US AT LEAST AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE A LEVEL
OF OVERSIGHT AND I WON'T GO
SO FAR TO SAY ACCREDITATION
OF A TREATMENT SYSTEM THAT CAN
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
-- AND ON THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SIDE OR SHARE STUDENT AMAZING
JOB TO ADDRESS THE IN CUSTODY
IN THE OUT OF CUSTODY ROLE ON
THE HEALTH CARE -- CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH SYSTEM IS IS TRYING TO
INTEGRATE THAT WITH THE PROP
FORTY SEVEN REENTRY CENTER ON
THAT WE RECEIVED A COMPETITIVE
FUNDING FOR SO YOU SEE ALL
THESE PIECES STARTING TO COME
TOGETHER ON THE HOUSING SIDE
YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE HOUSING TRUST
FUND WE HAVE TWENTY TWO OUT
OF THIRTY FOUR CITIES THAT
HAVE SIGNED ON TO THAT --
I'M IMPRESSED BY THE LEVEL OF
PIPELINE THAT IS ALREADY AND
IS IN DEVELOPMENT AS A RESULT
OF JUST THE DIALOGUE AROUND
CREATING THE TRUST FUND GETTING
THIS CITY SIGNED ON TO IT --
THERE'S MORE THAN A THOUSAND
UNITS ALREADY IN THE PIPELINE
AND ANOTHER EIGHT HUNDRED THAT
ARE SEEKING FUNDING SO THE
COUNTIES MOVING FORWARD QUICKLY
IN THE HOUSING TRUST FUND IN
AND CERTAINLY WE NEED A A LOT
MORE MONEY EVERYBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT MONEY WE ALL NEED A TON
MORE MONEY -- ON THE BENEFITS
AND SUPPORT SERVICES ALL JUST
KIND OF MAKE A HIGHLIGHTER AND
-- PUBLIC BENEFITS MEDI CAL
ON THE MEDICAL REIMBURSEMENT
RATE FOR BOARD AND CHAIRS IS
OFTEN A CHALLENGE -- FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO USE THE BORDEN
CARES EFFECTIVELY TO TREAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE BORN WILL
DISABLED WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AS WELL AS PHYSICAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS SOME IN A
BLAZE REALLY QUICKLY THROUGH
THIS -- SLIDE PRESENTATION IN
A NINETY SECOND SO NEXT SLIDE
-- SERVICE PLANNING AREAS
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED -- THIS IS
AN INITIATIVE THAT I BROUGHT
FORWARD IN MY ASSESSMENT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN I BELIEVE
AND I I THINK I CONCUR WITH
WITH EVERYONE WHO'S HERE
REPRESENTING A CITY THAT NO
ONE CITY IS GOING TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS INDEPENDENTLY
OF THEIR NEIGHBORS AND THAT
THE NOR SERVICE PLANNING AREA
HAS BEEN EFFECTIVELY ABLE TO
CREATE A A SUBSTANTIAL MO YOU
TO PARTNER AND SHARE ON THIS
EVEN COLLECTIVELY REQUIRING THE
COUNTY'S RESOURCES TO MAKE THAT
A REALITY -- AND SO I'M SUPER
PROUD OF THE NORTH -- SPOTS
CITIES TO BE ABLE TO PULL THAT
TOGETHER FINE TO APPROPRIATE
LOCATIONS AND EFFECTIVELY
ACKNOWLEDGING REALIZE THAT
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS A REGIONAL
ISSUE AND YOU KNOW THIS THIS
IDEA OF TRYING TO ESTABLISH
A RESIDENCY -- IMPACT FOR A
PERSON ENTERING A SHELTER IS
VERY VERY CHALLENGING TO SAY
WELL YOU'RE FROM HERE YOU
CAN YOU KNOW -- THE RESIDENCY
PIECES VERY DIFFICULT BUT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT IS THE BOTTOM LINE -- IN
OF ADDRESS THEM PROACTIVELY
SO WITH THE SHELTERS BEING
DEVELOPED THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S BEING EXPENDED FOR THE
SHELTER SYSTEM HAS ME AND MANY
OTHERS CONCERNED THAT WE NEED
AN EXIT FROM THE SHELTER SYSTEM
-- AND SO WITH THAT -- GO TO
THE GO TO THE HOMELESS COUNT
NUMBERS JUST QUICKLY BACK TO
THE HOMELESS COUNT -- SO IN
THE IN THE ON SHELTER NUMBER OF
THIRTY NINE SIXTY ONE AND ALL
ALL SAY TO YOU THAT THESE ARE
THE MOST ACCURATE FIGURES WE'VE
EVER SEEN AN ORANGE COUNTY
BECAUSE WE TALKED TO EVERY
HOMELESS PERSON THAT WE CAME
ACROSS IN THE COUNTY -- GIS MAP
LOCATIONS FOR WHERE THE SURVEYS
WERE COMPLETED I AM TOLD I NEED
TO STOP AND I HAVE -- TWO MORE
MINUTES YES ME THANK YOU -- AND
I WILL SAY TO YOU THAT ON THE
SHELTERED COUNT THERE WERE SIX
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL BEDS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT DID NOT
EXIST IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND THERE'S PROBABLY ANOTHER
FIVE TO SIX HUNDRED BEDS THAT
WERE NOT HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THAT ARE HERE NOW OR
IN THE PIPELINE AND SO I'LL SAY
TO YOU AT SOME POINT WE NEED TO
PIVOT FROM DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SHELTER SYSTEM WHICH I THINK
YOU KNOW AND I I WANT TO PAUSE
TO SAY SOME OTHER COMMUNITIES
CALL ME REGULARLY FROM AROUND
THE STATE AND SAY YOU KNOW
HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO DEVELOP
ALL THE SHELTER BEDS BECAUSE
THEY ARE YEARNING TO CREATE AN
URGENT RESPONSE TO THE STREET
POPULATION IN ORANGE COUNTY IS
SUCCESSFULLY IN THE IN THE A
MODE OF DOING SO AND YOU KNOW
WE WE TAKE A LITTLE CRITICISM
THERE BECAUSE IT'S NOT HOUSING
FIRST AND I I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT WE'VE GOT TO ADDRESS THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
HOMELESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BY PROVIDING EMERGENCY SHELTER
PIECE -- FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
IT'S TIME TO PIVOT FROM THOSE
THAT ARE IN THE PIPELINE AND
BEING FULLY DEVELOPED -- THOSE
WILL BE THE SHELTER SYSTEM
GOING FORWARD I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY MORE THOSE WE ULTIMATELY
NEED BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE
IT AND GET INTO THE PERMANENT
HOUSING AND THE SYSTEM OF CARE
RIGHT NOW IS HOUSING ABOUT
FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
NEAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
OUR SYSTEM THAT ARE WORKING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE UNABLE TO
IDENTIFY YOUR SECURE HOUSING IS
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT SO A FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT SORRY I MESSED
THAT UP -- SO WITH THAT WHEN
WE PUT PEOPLE INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THE RETENTION RATES
NINETY NINE PERCENT SO YES
HOUSING WORKS HOUSING IS THE
SOLUTION TO HOMELESSNESS --
BUT MOVING FORWARD FROM THERE
I WANT TO GO TO -- I'M GONNA
SKIP THAT YOU ALL KNOW WHERE
THE BEDS ARE IN THE NORTH PART
OF THE COUNTY -- REALLY QUICKLY
PREVENTION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS THAT'S THE SYMPTOM
THE ISSUE IS PREVENTION ON THE
FRONT END A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
TWO PERCENT OF OUR POPULATIONS
THAT HAVE BECOME HOMELESS
IN THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
COUNT I BECAME HOMELESS IN THE
LAST TWELVE MONTHS SO WE'VE
GOT TO DO MORE ON THE FRONT
END AND YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS SOMEWHAT A ROAD
ID THE PREVENTION RESOURCES
DUE TO THE LACK OF RESEARCH
THAT PREVENTION IS EFFECTIVE
SO YOU'LL SEE THAT OUR OUR
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
ARE SOMEWHAT UNDER UNDER FUNDED
WITH REGARDS TO PREVENTION
AND DIVERSION ON THE FRONT
END AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT OUR
CONTINUUM OF CARE JURISDICTION
WILL TAKE A A GOOD STRONG LOOK
AT THAT WITH REGARDS TO THE
STATE FUNDING COMING DOWN IT'S
ONE TIME MONEY PREVENTION IS
A VERY -- -- EFFECTIVE TOOL I
WILL TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
ROSE TALKING ABOUT HOUSING WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT INCOME AS
WELL WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
IT WAS SAID EARLIER THAT
ARE CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS THAT DON'T HAVE
AN INCOME AT ALL -- THERE'S A
TO A TON OF REASONS FOR THAT
WHICH I DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO
GO INTO BUT I WILL SAY TO YOU
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
THIS JURISDICTION AND ACROSS
THE STATE THAT ARE DISABLED
THEY ARE CLEARLY DISABLED
THEY'RE NOT RECEIVING GENERAL
RELIEF BUT THEY'RE ALSO NOT
RECEIVING FEDERAL DISABILITY
PAYMENTS AND SO THAT'S WHERE
THAT OTHER PLANE FLIES NEXT TO
US IS THE FEDERAL DISABILITY
SYSTEM IS VERY VERY CHALLENGING
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR A
HOMELESS PERSON TO NAVIGATE
IT'S QUITE IMPOSSIBLE SOMETIMES
EVEN FOR CASE MANAGEMENT TO
NAVIGATE THAT ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENTS -- TRUTH BE KNOWN AND
THEREFORE WE TRAIN PEOPLE WHAT
THE SORE PROGRAM TO BE ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THAT BUT IT REQUIRES
MEDI CAL IT REQUIRES A PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDER AND IT PROVIDES
A YOU KNOW A HISTORY OF MEDICAL
CARE THE DOCUMENTS ALONG AND
WAS STANDING DISABILITY -- I
TALKED ABOUT THE LINK TO STAY
IN SHELTERS THIS IS -- PROBABLY
A NUMBER ONE OR TOP FIVE ISSUE
FOR ME IN A IN MONITORING THE
SHELTER THE GROWING SHELTER
SYSTEM AND HOW LONG PEOPLE
ARE STAYING THERE AND WHETHER
THEY'RE EXITING SUCCESSFULLY OR
NOT -- GIVEN THE LENGTH OF STAY
IT'S DIFFICULT TO STAY IN A
SHELTER LONG TERM IF YOU DON'T
SEE THE OUTCOME OF FORESEEABLE
IN YOUR STAY THERE MOVING
FORWARD TO THE NEXT SLIDE
I'M AND I DID TALK ABOUT THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE -- THE MAT PROGRAM WAS
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER BIG STRONG
-- PROPONENT OF THAT -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE DEALING WITH AN OP
A CRISIS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BUT IN OUR COUNTRY AND YOU'RE
NEVER WOULD WE THOUGHT -- HOW
DO WE SITE -- METHADONE CLINICS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES SO TRYING
TO DECIDE A HOMELESS SHELTERS
CHALLENGING -- BUT CITING A
METHADONE CLINIC CITING CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS CITING
A SOBERING CENTER AT CETERA
THESE ARE THINGS THAT REQUIRE
COMMUNITY EDUCATION THEY
REQUIRE COMMUNITY INVESTMENT
AND KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING
THESE THINGS ARE BETTER THAN
THE ALTERNATIVE WHICH IS
NOT DOING THAT -- WE NEED
TO PROVIDE TREATMENT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND TREATMENT IS NOT ONE THING
TREATMENT AS MULTIPLE THINGS AS
I THINK I'VE DESCRIBED FAIRLY
EFFECTIVELY OR EFFICIENTLY IN
THE TIME I HAVE -- HOMELESS
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MOTEL
CONVERSIONS BIG FAN OF THOSE
-- SANTA ANNA'S DONE A GREAT
JOB ANAHEIM'S DOING A GREAT
JOB THERE ARE PROBABLY OTHERS
BUT THERE'S BEEN AT LEAST FIVE
IN THE TIME I'VE BEEN HERE --
WE DID SOME IN LONG BEACH AS
WELL AND WHAT IT DOES IS GIVE
YOU SEVENTY UNITS IN ONE SHOT
-- BY PROVIDING A RESOURCE TO
HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT'S LIKE
SINGLE ROOM OCCUPANCY BUT
IT ALSO ALLOWS PEOPLE THAT
WERE POTENTIALLY LIVING IN
AN ENCAMPMENT LIKE THE CIVIC
CENTER WHEN I FIRST ARRIVED
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND MANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE ENCAMPMENT
WENT ON TO LIVE IN THE ORCHARD
WHERE THEY COULD MAINTAIN THEIR
THEIR COMMUNITY RELATIONSHIPS
WHILE ALSO BEING HOUSE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL MODEL THERE --
AND THEN THE HOUSING TRUST
FUND WHICH ALL APPEAL TO THE
STATE MONEY MONEY MONEY --
NEXT SLIDE -- MARCHING HOME
TO END VETERAN HOMELESSNESS
I'LL TAKE OPPORTUNITY IN
PERSON AT THANK YOU A COPY
PETRIE-NORRIS FOUR OF THE
INFUSION OF MONEY FOR VETERANS
INITIATIVE MARCHING HOME TO
END VETERAN HOMELESSNESS UNITED
WAYS HERE TODAY AS WELL -- WE
HAVE MORE BASH VOUCHERS AND WE
HAVE HOMELESS VETERANS -- AND
SO THANK YOU TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT BUT WE ALSO
HAVE AN ISSUE IN OUR COMMUNITY
OF AVAILABLE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN TRYING TO IDENTIFY
LANDLORDS UNITED WAY IS DOING
AN AMAZING JOB ON THE LANDLORD
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO TO TRY
TO OVERCOME EVERY BARRIER THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING IN AND YOU
CAN TELL FROM MY PRESENTATION
THAT WE ARE HITTING THIS ISSUE
FROM EVERY CORNER AND WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS NOT JUST THE
FRONT END THE METAL AND THE
BACK END OF HOW WE'RE GOING
TO SOLVE THIS BUT -- MOVING
ON TO ANOTHER SLIDE HERE AT
THE END -- DATA INTEGRATION IT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY THE
STATE THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
SERVING THE SAME PEOPLE OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT OUR RESOURCES ARE SO
EXTREMELY LIMITED AND YOU KNOW
THE TALK OF HOUSING FIRST --
IT WOULD BE MY PREFERENCE THAT
WE CAN SERVE A PERSON ONCE AND
SERVE THEM SUCCESSFULLY AND SO
DATA INTEGRATION IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL BE REQUIRED THE
COUNTY IS ENGAGING IN THE VERY
EARLY STAGES OF THIS TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEMS ACCESS TO IMPROVE
NAVIGATION TO IMPROVE THE
RESOURCE ALLOCATIONS AND HOW WE
CAN SERVE PEOPLE FLEE ONCE AND
AND SERVE THEM BETTER -- AND
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE FIRST -- BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT
HAVE SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES
THAT WITHOUT THE ASSISTANCE OF
THE SYSTEM OF CARE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM -- AND SO
IN SUMMARY AND TO FINISH -- MY
MY TOP FOUR LIST THAT I'VE GOT
HERE'S THE OVERSIGHT CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT SYSTEM ON THAT
IS CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS
-- THE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SIGNIFICANT IMPAIRMENT POPULAR
WE HAVE A POPULATION WAS
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT IMPAIRMENT
THAT EVEN THE DISCUSSION OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS
NOT UNNECESSARILY REALISTIC AND
SO WERE WERE FREQUENTLY LOOKING
FOR THIS COMMUNITY BASED
OUR RESPONSE WERE APPROACH
AND YOU KNOW THE BOARDING
CARE ISSUES COMING UP A LOT
IN THE RE ENTRY DISCUSSION
ALSO COMING UP IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH DISCUSSION AROUND THE
MEDI CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES
BEING LOWER -- FOR FOR THOSE
-- CONDITIONS FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION AND MAYBE IT
WOULD BE FOR DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED POPULATION AND I
I'M NOT SURE WHY -- BUT YOU
KNOW WE WE REALLY NEED TO
MAXIMIZE THE RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEN ON THE RE
ENTRY SIDE -- FUNDING FOR RE
ENTRY SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING BECAUSE
IN THE HOMELESS SYSTEM OF CARE
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE WITH CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BACKGROUNDS AND WE'VE
GOT PEOPLE WITH RE ENTRY NEEDS
THAT ARE NOT REALLY GETTING
THEIR NEEDS MET IN THE HOMELESS
SYSTEM IN THE IN THE SHELTER
SYSTEM PER SE AND SO I I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A -- A
DIFFERENT SET OF SOLUTIONS FOR
PEOPLE IN RE ENTRY A SMALLER
ENVIRONMENT A SOBRE ENVIRONMENT
A PLACE WHERE LIFE SKILLS
AND FINANCIAL LITERACY ARE
PARAMOUNT TO A PERSON ACTUALLY
WORKING FOR AN EMPLOYER WHO
TAKES BALANCE AND A HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT ALSO TAKES FELONS
-- AND SO IT'S JUST NOT --
SUFFICIENT TO SAY THAT WE'RE
JUST CAN INTEGRATE ALL OF THAT
INTO THE HOMELESS SYSTEM AND
HOPE THAT OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS
CAN MANAGE THE COMPLEXITY ALL
IN ONE LOCATION -- I THINK
THAT IS A RECIPE FOR MULTIPLE
CHALLENGES FROM THE HEALTH
CARE SIDE THE REENTRY SIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ALL IN ONE LOCATION VERY
CHALLENGING TO BE EFFECTIVE
ON ALL OF THOSE FRONTS --
AND WITHOUT IT WILL STOP AND
THANK YOU FOR THE EXTRA TIME
THANK YOU AND -- MAYBE WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE STRAIGHT TO OUR
NEXT PALACES YES THANKS RAPTURE
SOON THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
INFORMATION JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS -- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE SPEND A MONTH TO THE UP IN
SACRAMENTO WHAT'S SO WHAT'S
THE CURRENT PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDING AT THE COUNTY WHAT
WHAT HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU GUYS
HAVE BECAUSE I THINK THE LAST
SUMMER HERBS TO AND FOURTEEN
MILLION AND WE HAVE RICHARD
SANCHEZ HERE FROM THE HEALTH
CARE AGENCY I DON'T HAVE THAT
SPECIFIC INFORMATION IN FRONT
OF ME I'M NOT SURE WHAT HE DOES
AT THE ABBOTT AUDIT THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THAT AT
THAT NUMBER AND I BELIEVE THE
NUMBER WAS TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN MILLION IS A THREE OR
FOUR YEARS OLD NOW -- WE WE DO
NOT HAVE THAT AMOUNT WE SPEND
IT DOWN MOSTLY ON -- WHAT'S
CALLED S. AN H. P.
MONEY WHICH IS PERMITS PART
OF HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS THE COUNTY
-- JUST TODAY FUNDED NINETY
MORE UNITS IN FOUR CITIES
IT'S MOSTLY IN A BIZARRE SPOT
AND SO AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME
ALL OF OUR BUT DOLLARS ARE
EITHER ALLOCATED OR SPENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO -- ALL
THE SERVERS IN SOUTH COUNTY
LOOKS LIKE SOUTH COUNTIES LOW
BEHIND THE OTHER AREAS SAP'S
IS THERE A HOLD UP -- DO
YOU KNOW WHY SOUTH COUNTY IS
LAGGING BEHIND THE OTHER AREAS
-- DESPITE THE THE CHUCKLING
THERE I WILL SAY TO YOU THAT
-- ALL THREE REGIONAL SERVICE
PLANNING AREAS TO CITIES ARE
MEETING -- AND I THINK THAT
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND I SIT
IN A LOT OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
-- SOMETIMES GET ASKED TO
LEAVE IN THE SOUTH COUNTY --
THERE'S A DIALOGUE GOING ON
ACROSS THIS COUNTY IN ALL THREE
SERVICE PLANNING AREAS I THINK
IN THE SOUTH SERVICE PLANNING
YOUR IT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THEY HAVE A LOT LESS OF A
VISIBLE PROBLEM THAN WHAT WE
SEE IN CENTRAL AND NORTH SO
THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT LATE TO
THE TABLE ON HAVING TO REACT
OR RESPOND TO SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE IT'S FAIRLY -- ISOLATED
-- AND SPREAD OUT AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT SOUTH COUNTY I
MEAN IT'S NOT A A TRANSIT
FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT IF YOU'RE
HOMELESS YOU WANT TO BE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION AND
FOOD AND RESOURCES AND YOU KNOW
IT YOU'RE YOU'RE IN KIND OF
A URBAN AREA WHEN YOU GET TO
SOUTH COUNTY IT'S IT'S QUITE A
WALK FROM A TO B.
AND SO THE POPULATION THERE
IS KIND OF A CONGREGATING
AROUND THE COASTAL AREAS OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND AND I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT'S TRUE ACROSS
THE STATE I COME FROM THE CITY
LONG BEACH FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
AND EVERY COASTAL CITY HAS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT MIGRATORY
PATTERN OF HOMELESS POPULATIONS
USING A BEACH AMENITIES AND
ASSETS AS WELL AS THE ISOLATION
OF THE BEACHES AT NIGHT FOR
A SLEEPING AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO YOU KNOW THE ISSUES
ARE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
ON THE COASTAL SIDE THAN WHAT
YOU WOULD SEE IN THE BROADER
SELF SERVICE PLANNING EVERY
MOST OF THOSE CITIES HAVE VERY
FEW HOMELESS PEOPLE THERE AND
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY AN OUT
REACH TO -- BUT YOU KNOW I WILL
ASSURE YOU THE CONVERSATIONS
ARE HAPPENING ABOUT YOU KNOW
GETTING SOME ADDITIONAL BEDS
DOWN THERE SAN CLEMENTE HAS A
RESOURCE CENTER -- THAT'S IN A
CITY BUILDING SO I MEAN THEY'RE
DOING A LOT DOWN THERE IN SAN
CLEMENTE LAGUNA BEACH HAS BEEN
DOING A LOT THERE'S ACTUALLY
THE FIRST SHELTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT I REMEMBER WORKING
WITH IN THE THE MID NINETIES SO
I MEAN THERE'S THERE'S A LOT OF
ACTIVITY HAPPENING IN THE SOUTH
PART OF THE COUNTY -- AND WITH
THE STATE FUNDING LAST YEAR --
WE WERE ABLE TO FIND REGIONAL
STREET OUT REACH FOR THE ENTIRE
SELL SPA SO WE'RE ABLE TO KIND
OF MAINTAIN A BY NAME LIST IN
THE CITY'S ABOUT WHO IS -- IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND TARGETING
THEM FOR THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE I JUST RECENTLY
MET WITH MY MARES IN IT IT
SEEMS LIKE SAN COMMITTEES
WAITING ON THE U.
TALK COURT DECISION TO MOVE
FORWARD THEY'RE ALSO A LOT OF
-- MARES ARE LOOKING BECAUSE
A LOT OF MY CITIES ARE THIRTY
THOUSAND SAN JUAN DATA POINT
TWO SMALL THAT THEY FEEL TO
OPEN UP THEIR OWN FACILITY THEY
LIKE TO COORDINATE WITH THE
COUNTY ON ORIGINAL SO THERE'S
TALK OF LAND LÀ PADA -- AT THE
LANDFILL THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
COUNTY PROPERTY THERE THERE'S
A CALIFORNIA CON LOS PINOS
SUB LIKELY CLEVELAND NATIONAL
FOREST ITS STATE PROPERTY BUT
-- JUST JUST FROM MY POINT
OF VIEW IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
ANYBODY'S TAKEN THE LEAD IN
SOUTH COUNTY TO SAY WHAT WE
HEARD FROM THE CHIEF AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING UP HERE BUT A PARKING
PLACENTIA SO I JUST BE CURIOUS
IT IS OUR TIME LINE IS WHY
DON'T I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
TIME LINE ON THAT BUT WOULD
YOU KNOW WITH THIS YOUNG AFTER
AFTER JUDGE CARTER THERE WAS
A THERE WAS A IDEA THAT WAS
DEAD ON ARRIVAL TO PUT A TEN
CITY AT THE OLD COURTHOUSE
LINDY AND LOGAN AND A GAL AND
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM
WITH THAT BUT THAT'S THE ONLY
IDEA THAT I'VE SEEN COME OUT
FOR SOUTH COUNTY ONE FROM THE
COUNTY'S PERSPECTIVE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CITIES
ARE ON BOARD -- WITH WHAT IT
IS THAT WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS
AN IN NORTH I MEAN IT'S BEEN
A COLLABORATION FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING -- IN CENTRAL
WE'VE HAD LOTS OF INDIVIDUAL
DIALOGUES AND IT'S NICE TO GET
THE CITIES TO WORK TOGETHER
BECAUSE AGAIN AS I SAID IF ONCE
OPENING A SHELTER SOMEBODY ELSE
IS GOING TO BE WORKING ON THE
HOUSING PIECE AND WE NEED THE
CRISIS STABILIZATION UNIT IN
THE RECOVERY PROGRAM A WHERE'S
THE EMPLOYMENT PIECE WE'VE GOT
TO BE WORKING ON ALL OF THOSE
COMPONENTS AND YOU KNOW YOU
LOOK AT THE APPETITE OF CITY
COUNCILS IN NINE DIFFERENT
CITIES -- YOU KNOW THEY ALL
HAVE THE THE GOVERNMENT'S
AUTHORITY FOR THEIR CITY WHAT
DO THEY HAVE THE APPETITE TO
CONTRIBUTE INTO THAT SYSTEM
-- PERSPECTIVE AND YOU KNOW
FROM THE COUNTY WE TALKED TO
THE CITY'S A LOT ABOUT WHAT
DO YOU HAVE AVAILABLE WHAT DO
YOU THINK IT'S FEASIBLE WHAT
IS YOUR COUNSEL ON YOU KNOW
WILLING TO DO AND SO YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S A MUTUAL DIALOGUE
AS I SAID IT'S A FIVE PLANES
FLYING WE NEED ALL FIVE IT'S
NOT EVEN JUST THE COUNTY OR THE
CITIES IT'S THE CONSTITUENCIES
AS WELL AND SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND COMMUNITY EDUCATION
TO GET PEOPLE UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT IS BETTER TO RESPOND
PROACTIVELY THAN RE ACTIVELY
THANKS VERY MUCH YEAH CAN HELP
AT ALL PLEASE THANK YOU SIR
YOU ARE AT THE RIGHT PLACE
TO HELP YOU COULD LEADS THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ART BUT IF THERE
IS A COUNTY SAYING LET'S PUT
AMOUNT LOS PINOS THAT'S NOT
A SOLUTION BECAUSE MATTER OF
FACT I THINK THAT ALICE FOR
SURPLUS LAND WE ACTUALLY MOVE
FORWARD ON THE COUNTY MEDIA
BILLET COMMITTEE A FEW YEARS
BACK LIKE FOR FIVE YEARS TO
ACTUALLY MOVE FORWARD WITH
SELLING THAT PROPERTY BUT
THOSE TYPE OF SCENARIOS WHERE
PEOPLE SAY LET'S JUST GO AHEAD
AND MOVE THEM SOMEWHERE ELSE
THE TRUTH IS WE CAN'T SOLVE
ORANGE COUNTY'S HOMELESSNESS
ISSUE AND ONCE EVERY SINGLE
CITY TAKES RESPONSIBILITY AND
I SEE WE HAVE CYPRESS HERE
JOHN PETE WE HAVE WHERE'S THE
DISSIDENT -- CITIES WHO WILL
HAVE A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE
LIKE LOW COMMA ONE OF OUR
SMALLER CITIES AND THEY'RE
HERE THE ENTIRE TIME SO AND I'M
NOT I DON'T KNOW ALL YOUR TREE
AND HE'S WILLING TO HELP BUT
LIKE I SAID BUT THEY WILLING
THEY HAVE TO HELP ANY CAN'T BE
WITH IT WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
LIKE TO LIKE THE FORMER SOUTH
COUNTY GPA AND FIND STILL TO
TAKE IN IN SOUTH COUNTY THE
DAY FOCUSED ON WORKING WITH IN
THE SITUATION THAT THEY HAVE
VERSUS LET'S SEND IT SOMEWHERE
ELSE OKAY JUST BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY LIKE ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT TOUCH TONE
FOR ME WHERE I CAN BE REALLY
VERY CONGENIAL BUT DON'T PUT
ONE ISSUE YOU HAVE IN ONE PART
OF THE COUNTY ON TO ANOTHER
BECAUSE THAT'S WHY FULLER TIM
WE DRIVE DOWN LIMÓN STREET
AND THERE'S TWENTY DIFFERENT
HOMELESS ON EVERY STREET CORNER
I'M NOT SAYING YOU ARE IT
WAS IN MY POINT MY MIND SOUTH
COUNTY WANT TO SOLVE AS FOR
REGIONAL SO DATA POINTS AND
LONG WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A REGIONAL ACTION LIKE
THEY'RE DOING UP HERE YEAH I
HAVE A CLEANING AND PICKING
UP ON ON THIS I THINK TENSION
BETWEEN CITY RESPONSIBILITY IN
COUNTY RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE
I DO FEEL LIKE THERE ARE SOME
CITIES THAT ARE REALLY GETTING
CAUGHT IN THIS CATCH TWENTY TWO
BECAUSE FOR FOR SOMETHING TO
HAPPEN I THINK THERE'S GONNA
THREE LEGS OF THE STOOL IN
THE FIRST IS POLITICAL WILL
AND LEADERSHIP THE SECOND IS
AN ACTUAL PLAN THEN THE THIRD
IS RESOURCES AND FUNDING AND
I DO THINK THERE ARE EXAMPLES
IN THE COUNTY WHERE THERE ARE
CITIES WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
POLITICAL WELL AND LEADERSHIP
WHERE THEY DO HAVE A PLAN THAT
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
GET ANY RESOURCES ARE FUNDING
AND THEY'RE FINDING THEMSELVES
NOW CAUGHT HOLDING THE BAG FOR
YOU BECAUSE MAYES EVER EXAMPLE
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS GOING
TO THEIR GENERAL FUND AND
THEN ONE OTHER CITY SEE THAT
THAT MAKES CITIES LIKE NEWPORT
BEACH HUNTINGTON BEACH MISSION
VIEJO DANA POINT SAN CLEMENTE
THEY'RE EVEN LESS LIKELY TO
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH A
SOLUTION WHEN THEY GO OH MY
GOD I'M GONNA I'M GONNA PUT MY
NECK ON THE LINE FROM MY FROM
MY CONSTITUENTS I'M GONNA MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS PLAN AND THEN
I'M GONNA HAVE A GIANT HOLE IN
MY GENERAL FUND THAT NO ONE'S
FELLING SO HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
FIGURE OUT THAT RATE FORMULA
AND MAKE SURE THAT CITIES BACK
TO THE CITY MANAGER'S POINT
THAT CITIES THAT ARE DOING
THE RIGHT THING ARE GETTING
REWARDED ONE ABSOLUTELY I WOULD
-- I WOULD ALIGN WITH THAT
SENTIMENT AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT COSTA MESA -- YOU
KNOW THERE INITIATIVE WAS ON
THE HEELS AND TO THE TAIL END
OF WHEN THE FIRST ROUND OF HE
CAME AND THEY MISSED THAT THEY
JUST MISSED THAT COMPLETELY AND
YOU KNOW THAT OPPORTUNITY THE
WAY THAT THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
BOARD WAS ALLOCATING THAT MONEY
WAS REALLY NOT ALLOCATING IT
BUT PARKING IT IN NORTH PARKING
IN CENTRAL PARKING IN SOUTH
AND SAYING EVERYONE HAS ACCESS
EVERYONE SHOULD APPLY -- AND I
THINK IN THE FIRST WHEN YOU HAD
TO CALL THE SHELTER CRISIS AND
THAT THERE WERE ONLY SIX THEY
DID AND IT WAS THE SIX THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING SHELTERS ARE
WE'RE GETTING DIRECT FUNDING
YELL SANTA ANA ANAHEIM AND
CENTURY IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THE THE ALLERGEN ALSO HAD TO
DO THAT AND THAT IS NOT AN
EASY AS AN ELECTED LEADER OF
A LOCAL BODY TO SAY WE HAVE A
SHELTERS CRISIS AND THERE WERE
SOME CITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY
THAT DELIBERATELY CHOSE NOT TO
DO THAT FOR WHATEVER THE REASON
SO NOW TO THEN COME BACK AND
SAY WELL SEE WE DON'T GET THAT
THEY'RE THERE IT'S IT'S IT'S
YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE HAVE LET
IT AND SOME PEOPLE ARE THERE
IN THE MIDDLE AND SOME PEOPLE
ARE KIND OF COMING INTO THE
GAME WE WANT EVERYBODY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL I DO BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO SEE PEOPLE DUMPING
AND I'VE SEEN THAT TOO MUCH
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO OUR LAST PANELS
AND THEN OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS BUT TOBY HAS BEEN --
YOU LEAN VERY PATIENT AND AND
HERE HE IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AND HE ACTUALLY DID
COME INTO A NOR SPOT A WHILE
BACK AND SPEAK TO ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE WE HAD THERE
AND WE APPRECIATED THAT SO
THANK YOU AND WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE AS YOU MENTIONED I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE COMMISSION
VERY BRIEFLY WERE AND A STATE
AGENCY ONE OVERSIGHT BODY ON
MENTAL HEALTH I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED BEFORE
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IF EVER YOU COMMITTEE YOU
FOR THAT I I THINK THE THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD TODAY
REALLY TOUCHES ON MANY OF THESE
KEY POINTS I LOVE THE COMMENT
ABOUT LEADERSHIP A PLAN IN
THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT WHAT
WE FIND WORK LOOKING AROUND
THE STATE IS THAT THERE ARE
STRATEGIES AROUND CALIFORNIA ON
THAT TOUCH UPON IS THE ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
AROUND HOUSING AND HOUSING
STOCK AROUND THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AROUND
MAXIMIZING ACCESS TO BENEFITS
THAT ARE ALREADY AVAILABLE
BE THAT A STATE OR FEDERAL
BENEFITS IN TERMS OF THE ARRAY
OF SERVICES THAT ARE NECESSARY
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE EITHER HOMELESS AT RISK
OF HOMELESS OR ON THAT WHAT
WE MIGHT CALL ON THE PRECIPICE
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN COMING
OUT OF THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
OR FOLKS WHO WE KNOW WHO ARE
DISCHARGING FROM OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM I THINK IT FROM
THE COMMISSION'S PERSPECTIVE
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE CANNOT
FIND OUR WAY OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM TO A HOMELESS RESPONSE
STRATEGY WE HAVE TO LOOK
UPSTREAM WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE CORD DRIVER SOME OF
WHICH YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
BUT I I I DO THINK THAT WHILE
WE SEE EXAMPLES ACROSS THE
STATE OF EFFORTS TO MAKE ALL
OF THESE PIECES FIT TOGETHER AT
THE BLUE ANGELS MODEL WE DON'T
SEE THIS AT A AT A SYSTEM LEVEL
IN ANY PARTICULAR LOCATION IN
CALIFORNIA OTHER WORDS THERE'S
NOBODY IS DOING ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN AND
I WILL AND I WOULD I WOULD ADD
TO YOUR LIST BECAUSE I THINK
YOU HAVE A PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE
LIST AT THE MOMENT AND AND AND
INTEREST OF TIME RATHER THAN
REITERATING ALL OF THOSE THINGS
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU THE
ONE THING I HAVEN'T HEARD YOU
TALK ABOUT TODAY AMONG THE
PANELISTS IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE
NOT LEVERAGING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AS EXTENSIVELY AS
WE COULD THE TICKET EARLY
FEDERAL ENTITLEMENTS WE HAVE
TO DO A BETTER JOB MAKING IT
EASIER FOR THE SYSTEM WE HAVE
TO WORK IN OTHER WORDS THE
BLUE ANGELS NEED TO BE ABLE
TO FLY IN UNISON I'LL BORROW
THE THE EXAMPLE UNFORTUNATELY
THE PLANES ARE ALL DIFFERENT
SIZES DIFFERENT AGES THEY
FLY DIFFERENT SPEEDS THEY YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE ALL THESE SORT
OF CHALLENGES THAT REALLY
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO LINE UP WITH EACH OTHER
THAT HAS TO DO WITH ALL OF
THE ASPECTS THAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT LAND USE PLANNING IT HAS
TO DO WITH BUILDING AND CITING
IT HAS TO DO WITH EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT EVEN SUPPORTING
PEOPLE TO GET ENROLLED IN
MEDICAID MEDICARE HOW PROGRAMS
AND ENSURING THAT THE DOLLARS
ARE AVAILABLE WE SEE DRAMATIC
DISPARITIES IN THE ABILITY
OF PUBLIC AGENCIES TO DRIVE
DOWN FEDERAL DOLLARS AND THOSE
DISPARITIES CAN'T BE EXPLAINED
AWAY BY PREFERENCES IN TERMS
OF THINGS LIKE HOW MANY DOLLARS
LOCAL DOLLARS COUNTIES PUT
INTO NON REIMBURSABLE PROGRAMS
LIKE PREVENTION PROGRAMS VERSUS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE REIMBURSABLE
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TODAY
FOR THE SYSTEM TO WORK AS YOU
WANT IT TO WORK AND ONE OF THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
TO ADDRESS RELATIVE TO THAT
IS WE HAVE TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
BE SUCCESSFUL VERY DIFFICULT
TO FOR A COUNTY TO KNOW WHERE
TO TURN THE COMMENT WAS MADE
EARLIER ABOUT LOOKING AT
PHOENIX OR LOOKING AT A PEOPLE
OFTEN MENTION HAVEN FOR HOPE
IN SAN ANTONIO THE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES IN
OUR OWN BACKYARD ORANGE COUNTY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ARE EACH USING AND IT
TO SAY DOLLARS IN THE CASE OF
ORANGE COUNTY IT'S BE WELL TO
TRY VERY CREATIVE APPROACHES
OF END OF IT INTEGRATED CARE
THAT REDUCE THE LAW THAT LEVEL
OF BARRIERS THAT PEOPLE FACE
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO ACCESS
SERVICES IS A VERY INTERESTING
COMPONENT TO THAT ON FOR
FOLKS WHO HAVE BENEFITS ON THE
COMMERCIAL PAYER SIDE NOW WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WHO ARE
CAMPING ON YOUR STREETS TODAY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WHO
ARE AT RISK OF EARLY PSYCHOSIS
FOR EXAMPLE CURRENTLY WE HAVE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE OTHER SIDE
BECAUSE THIS PROGRAMS ARE IN
ORANGE COUNTY WE COULD FIGURE
THAT OUT BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE STATEWIDE TODAY
TO SUPPORT THE ABILITY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BUILD OUT THOSE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS AND FOR THE
FOLKS WHO ARE ON YOUR STREETS
WHO ARE REALLY STRUGGLING WITH
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF MENTAL
HEALTH NEED THOSE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT CAN BE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WE STARTED SIX MONTHS
AGO TO BUILD OUT HEALTHCARE
LEARNING COLLABORATIVE
HONORABLY PSYCHOSIS WE'RE
TRYING TO TAKE IT TO SCALE THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT THE
GOVERNOR AGREED -- WERE REALLY
WORKING TO PULL THOSE COUNTIES
TOGETHER THAT'S ONE PIECE AS
A SLIVER OF THE CHALLENGE THAT
YOU HAVE IN IN YOUR COMMUNITIES
RELATED TO THE DIFFICULT TO
SERVE HOMELESS POPULATION IN
IN IN THIS COMMUNITY AND IT'S
TRUE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SIMILARLY ON THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DIVERSION OPPORTUNITY
I AM I AM STRUCK BY THE
COMMENTS AROUND FOLKS WHO
ARE RESISTANT TO SERVICES WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
RESISTANCE IS THERE SOMETIMES
IT'S BECAUSE THE LEVEL OF
PSYCHOSIS THAT SOMEONE HAS IS
THERE REALLY NOT ENGAGING BUT
THEY MAY NOT BE AT THAT POINT
WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
MOVE FORWARD AND INVOLUNTARILY
COMMIT SOMEONE WE ALSO NEED
TO UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE ARE
HEAVILY RESISTANT TO ACCESSING
SERVICES THERE WAS A RECENT
CONVERSATION IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY ABOUT IT A TEMPORARY
SHELTER PROGRAM AND THERE WAS
A FUNDAMENTAL MISMATCH BETWEEN
WHAT PEOPLE NEEDED IN ORDER
TO STAY IN THAT SHELTON WHAT
THE SHELTER OFFERED SO PEOPLE
FELT LIKE THEY WERE BETTER
OFF CAMPING IN THE WOODS WE
REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW CAN WE DESIGN OUR SYSTEMS
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO WEAR
LR THE TICKET EARLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF
ENTERING INTO THE POPULATION
THAT YOU'RE MOSTLY TRYING TO
ADDRESS INCLUDING THOSE FOLKS
WHO ARE COMING OUT OF YOUR
JAILS YOU HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE THERE
IN YOUR CARE THAT A CHIEF OF
POLICE AND OTHERS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE BELIEVE IT WAS ACTUALLY
RICHARD SANCHEZ TALKED ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES OF USING I MEANT
TO SAY FUNDS IN YOUR JAIL FOR
THE RIGHT KINDS OF SERVICES
PLAY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN A
PRE ADJUDICATION STATUS RIGHT
WE WE HAVE LOST THE ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE SOME OF THE RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS THOSE FOLKS AND
WE KNOW THAT THOSE PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY IF THEY WERE
HOMELESS BEFORE THEY ENTERED
YOUR JAIL AT A VERY HIGH
RISK OF COMING OUT -- CHILD
WELFARE FAMILIES INVOLVED THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AS WELL
IT IN IN NEW YORK THERE WAS A
AN EXAMPLE OF A PROGRAM THAT
WAS REFERRED TO AS A HOMELESS
PREDICTOR SYSTEM ALMOST AS
PREDICTORS SYSTEM AND IT WAS
VERY ACTUALLY VERY SIMPLE THEY
SIMPLY REQUIRED LANDLORDS TO
NOTIFY THE CITY OF INNOVATION
BEFORE IT HAPPENED AND THE
IDEA WAS TO HELP THAT FAMILY
WITH THAT DEPOSIT WITH THAT
TRANSITION BEFORE THEY WERE
EVICTED IT'S MUCH CHEAPER TO
KEEP A FAMILY INTACT TRANSITION
THEM INTO AN ALTERNATE HOUSING
PROGRAM THAN TO HAVE THAT
FAMILY GET DISBURSED BECAUSE
SHELTER DOESN'T ALLOW MOM AND
DAD AND CHILDREN OR THE PATS
OR IN PARTICULAR THE CASE A
MULTI GENERATIONAL FAMILY SO I
BOTTOM LINE I WOULD SAY THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE SYSTEM WE'VE DESIGNED IS
VERY DISTRIBUTED CITIES HAVE A
ROLE COUNTIES HAVE A ROLE YOUR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HAVE A ROLE
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A
ROLE PARTICULARLY FOR CHILDREN
WHO ARE AT HIGH RISK IN THE
STATE AND THE FEDS ARE ALSO
HAVE A ROLE BUT WHAT WE WHAT
WE'VE DONE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE STATE IS ENCOURAGE THOSE
INDIVIDUAL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO FIGURE THIS OUT ON THEIR
OWN WITH A MISHMASH OF LONG
TERM FUNDS ONE TIME DOLLARS
GRAND DOLLARS -- AND WE'VE
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THEM FOR FOR YOU OFFER LOCAL
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY THAT
THE KEY INVESTMENT THE KEY
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THE
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS ON THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT THAT CAN
BE AVAILABLE TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN MOVE DOLLARS FROM
REACTIVE HI COSTS LOW VALUE
TO PREVENTATIVE LOW COST
HIGH VALUE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS UNLIKELY TO HAPPEN
ACROSS FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
THOUSANDS OF CITIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS WE DO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF OUR LOCAL AGENCIES
TO RETAIN THEIR NEED TO TAILOR
THEIR STRATEGY TO THEIR UNIQUE
SITUATIONS WHETHER IT'S YOUR
RESOURCES YOUR GEOGRAPHY
YOUR DEMOGRAPHICS SO YOUR
SERVICE MAX WELL ALSO CARVING
THE PATH FORWARD IN TERMS OF
AGAIN LEADERSHIP THE PLAN IN
THE RESOURCE BASE WE WE HAVE
WE'VE BEGUN TO DO THIS AGAIN
I USED EARLY PSYCHOSIS EXAMPLE
THE COMMISSION IS SUPPORTING
COUNTIES IN THINKING IT REALLY
UNDERSTANDING CRIMINAL JUSTICE
DIVERSION HOW DO WE MOVE FOLKS
UPSTREAM RESEARCH FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
HAS FOUND THAT FORTY SIX
PERCENT OF PEOPLE COMING INTO
THEIR STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM
WITH A FELONY CHARGE AND VERY
SERIOUSLY ILL BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN DEEMED COMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL FORTY SIX PERCENT HAD
NO COMMUNITY SERVICES SIX
MONTHS PRIOR TO THE FELONY
ARREST THEY'RE FALLING THROUGH
THE CRACKS WERE WORKING TO
SUPPORT COUNTIES TO DO THE
DATA ANALYTICS THAT THEY NEED
TO DO TO UNDERSTAND WHY THOSE
CRACKS ARE THERE AND HOW THEY
CAN STOP THOSE PEOPLE FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS SIMILARLY
WERE USING IMAGES A INNOVATION
FUNDS TO SUPPORT STRATEGIES
LIKE USING PSYCHIATRIC ADVANCE
DIRECTIVES TO PREVENT THE NEED
TO CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE FIRST PLACE TO SLOW DOWN
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE SERVICE DELIVERY STRATEGY
THAT COUNTY HAS IN PLACE FALLS
APART WHEN SOMEONE IS STRESSED
HOW CAN WE AGAIN LOOK AROUND
THE CORNER AND ANTICIPATE WHO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE AND PUT
A PLAN IN PLACE MUCH LIKE WE
DO WITH OLDER FOLKS WHO ARE
MOVING OUT OF THEIR HOMES INTO
SOME SORT OF AN ASSISTED LIVING
KIND OF PLAN IS THAT WE TALK
WITH OUR OLDER RESIDENTS ABOUT
WHAT COMES NEXT WE OFTEN DON'T
TALK WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN OUR SYSTEM TODAY AGAIN TELL
WELL FAIR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STATE HOSPITAL OTHER KINDS OF
PROGRAMS ABOUT LOOKING AROUND
THE CORNER WHAT WE DO IS WE
RELEASE WE MOVE THEM FROM ONE
PROGRAM TO THE NEXT AND WHEN
AND WHEN THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
MAKE THAT TRANSITION AND THE
SYSTEM FAILS YOU END UP IN
HAVING THESE VERY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HIGH COST
IMPACT VERY REACTIVE CARE AND
SO I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THAT
SELECT COMMITTEE TO THINK ABOUT
HOW CAN THE STATE HOW CAN OUR
PARTNERS IN ACADEMIA ON THE
RESEARCH SIDE HOW CAN WE BEGIN
TO BRING TOGETHER THE EXPERTISE
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING EXPERTISE THAT YOU
HAVE HERE IN YOUR COMMUNITIES
TO TALK ABOUT STRATEGIES TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR YOU TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND HARDER FOR YOU
TO FAIL BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
VERY EASY TO FAIL AS YOU KNOW
AND SUCCESS AS THE FOLKS TO MY
LEFT NOW IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO BE
HERE THE COMMISSION OF A LOVE
TO HELP YOU WITH THAT -- WE'VE
SEEN SOME SUCCESS IN BRING
FOLKS TOGETHER IN THIS WAY AND
AND I THINK THIS EVERYTHING
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY IS THIS
IS WHAT IS NEEDED IN TERMS
OF ALL OF THESE COMPLICATED
PIECES THAT COME TOGETHER
TO RESULT IN THE CHALLENGER
TRYING TO ADDRESS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK
THAT YOUR COMMENTS CAME
EXACTLY AT THE RIGHT TIME OF
THE HEARING WHICH IS THAT --
WE ALL HAVE EXPERIENCES WITH
SUCCESS AND FAILURE WITHIN
THE SYSTEM OF HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND IT CAN GET
VERY QUICKLY A MOTIONAL SO
I APOLOGIZE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BILL GROWING KNOW THAT YOU'RE
WORKING HARD IN YOUR AREA --
BUT I I THINK THAT IS FOR ME
PERSONALLY WHERE I GET REALLY
-- CAN MOVE FROM MORNING TO
DO THE BEST THAT I KNOW ON A
VERY UNEMOTIONAL WAY WHICH IS
WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITIES TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE EMOTIONAL PART
AND YOU SEE HOW MANY FAILURES
THERE ARE OUT THERE AND THEN
YOU ATTACH IT TO PEOPLE YOU
EVEN KNOW IS THEN BECOMES AN
URGENT KIND OF CRY THAT HOW
MANY PEOPLE DO WE HAVE TO LOSE
-- AN ORANGE COUNTY OVER FOUR
HUNDRED PEOPLE LAST YEAR DIED
NOW ON THE STREETS OF ORANGE
COUNTY WE DON'T KNOW THAT THOSE
WERE ALL BECAUSE OF I'M NOT
GETTING ATTENTION MAYBE AS WAS
SAID THEY DECLINED IT BUT FOR
WHATEVER REASON THOSE NUMBERS
ARE UP ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I DO FEEL IT'S A
MORAL IMPERATIVE THAT NOT ONLY
DO WE RESPOND BUT I THINK WHAT
YEAR YOUR LAST REMARK SPENT
IS LET'S RESPOND EFFECTIVELY
IN THAT SOMETHING WE CAN ALL
ANYTHING GAIN FROM THIS SO
WITH THAT I THINK IF YOU HAVE
ANY CLOSING REMARKS THAT WAY
-- WILL BRING PEOPLE UP THAT
THEY HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THEN WHAT WE DO IS COULD
PROBABLY KEEP THOSE COMMENTS TO
ABOUT ONE MINUTE IF YOU -- BUT
MEMBERS ANY FINAL COMMENTS JUST
VERY BRIEFLY BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT WE'RE RUNNING TRÊN TIME
BUT THERE IS A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT YOU SAID THAT THAT REALLY
STRUCK ME I THINK YOU'RE A THAT
WE WITH THE STATE YOU ARE MOST
IMPORTANT ROLE HERE IS TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR OUR PARTNERS IN
THE COUNTY AND THE IN STATE
GOVERNMENT TO BE SUCCESSFUL SO
I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK
FOR US TO DO ON THAT FRONT AND
I CAN YOU ALSO MENTIONED THAT
WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
LEVERAGING FEDERAL ENTITLEMENT
SO THERE'S ARE BOTH THINGS THAT
I WOULD LOVE US TO BE ABLE TO
FOLLOW UP ON OUR COMMUNITY AND
AND WE ARE DEFINITELY MISSING
THAT REPRESENTATION HERE SO
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL WORK TO ENGAGE OUR
REPRESENTATIVES AS WELL ON AT
THE FEDERAL YES I'M A NUMBER
THANKS AGAIN I'M CHAIR FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING SO I
COME AT THIS YOU KNOW I'M OF
THAT -- AND PRESIDENT BUSH
APPOINTED ME TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS ONE THE
FIRST THING I DID IS I WENT OUT
WITH A HOMELESS ADVOCATE TO GO
TO SOUP KITCHENS AND SHELTERS
TRYING TO FIND VETERANS AND
SPEND A DAY DOING THAT WITH
WITH THE GENTLEMAN AND IT GOES
BACK TO THE SERVICES THE VA'S
GOT EVERY SERVICE AVAILABLE
DRUG AND ALCOHOL COUNSELING
HOUSING JOB TRAINING BUT YOU
CAN'T MAKE THE PEOPLE TAKE
IT NOW WAS TO TAKE AWAY FROM
THAT TO YOU WE MAINLY ONE OUT
AND WE HANDED OUT ARMY SURPLUS
SLEEPING BAGS AND BOOT SO
PEOPLE BECOME TO WE DID TAKE
ONE GENTLEMAN IN FOR HEALTH
CARE BUT IT'S IT'S FINDING A
WAY TO MAKE THE FOLKS TAKE TO
SERVICES AND SO YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN ADDED SINCE THEN TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF HOMES WERE
VETERANS AT THE TIME MY LAST
YEAR ON DANA POINT CITY COUNCIL
YOU KNOW WE KNEW THE THIRTY
PEOPLE IN DANA POINT THAT WERE
HOMELESS -- THE DEPUTIES KNOWN
WE KNEW HOW TO MANAGE -- BUT
MY LAST YEAR SOME CHANGE WHERE
PEOPLE WERE STANDING ON THE
STREET CORNER WERE SIGNS DAY
GETTING IN AN CONGREGATING
AND SO I ASKED FOR HOMELESS
TASK FORCE AND WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS BUT IT'S LIKE
A LOT OF COMMUNITIES DID YOU
KNOW WE PUT THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
ON THEIR FAMILY ASSISTANCE
MINISTRIES THE VFW YOU KNOW
SO THE DEPUTY WOULD ENCOUNTER
SOMEBODY YOU KNOW WE CAN AT
LEAST BE THE MIDDLE MAN TO TRY
TO GET HIM SERVICES THEY NEED
BUT EVEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN IT'S EXPLODED WAY
BEYOND THAT AND -- SO I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
IT IS A HUGE ISSUE WE'RE ALL
WORKING ON IT AND -- WE GOT
TO COME UP WITH SOME SOLUTIONS
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF OUR OUR
CITIZENS BUT ALSO THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HOMELESS AND WE GET
ON THE CARE THAT THEY NEED SO
THANKS AGAIN FOR FOR PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING AN IT JUST ONE VERY
QUICK RESPONSE TO THAT IN A
FORMER POSITION I LIST ADDRESS
THE STATE'S RESEARCH BUREAU WE
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA'S DRAWDOWN
OF FEDERAL VA BENEFITS PENSIONS
RETIREMENTS AND CASH PAYMENTS
RELATIVE TO OTHER STATES AT
THE TIME WE WERE IN THE FORTIES
FOR FRANK FORTIETH IN THE BACK
OF THE ENVELOPE CALCULATION
OF CALIFORNIA WERE TO MOVE
COMPARABLE TO FLORIDA AND
TEXAS AND DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENTS FOR FOR BATS WOULD
HAVE BROUGHT ADDITIONAL BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY NOT MONEY THAT GOES
INTO STATE COFFERS ARE COUNTY
COFFERS IT'S MONEY THAT GOES TO
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED TO
PAY RANT BY WASHERS AND DRYERS
PURCHASE A CAR SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT BECAUSE THE VA'S MANDATED
BASED OFF THE POPULATION
WHOSE AND ROLLED TO BUILD MORE
CLINICS AND HOSPITALS AND WE'LL
GET THOSE RESOURCES IN HERE
SO EVEN IF A NUMBER WAS NINE
PERCENT I BELIEVE YOU SAID
WAS MINUTES NINE PERCENT WE
TAKE OFF THE TABLE THAT THE
VA COULD HANDLE AND THEN WE
CAN FOCUS ON THE OTHER EIGHTY
ONE BUT THAT'S THAT'S A GREAT
POINT AND THAT'S PROBABLY THE
BIG REVEAL NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF
JUST COMING FROM LOCAL TO STATE
BUT I THINK FOR MANY OF US IS
UNDERSTANDING THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND HOW
DO WE ATTAIN THEM AND I THINK
IT'S AN EDUCATION THAT IS STILL
A WORK IN PROGRESS I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO BE BETTER AT IT
ORANGE COUNTY AS A WHOLE BUT
ALL TOO OFTEN I WOULD HEAR WILL
ORANGE COUNTY IS NOT GETTING
THEIR FAIR SHARE WHICH WAS
JUST KIND OF A CONSTANT AND
WE IN FACT LOOKED AND DID SOME
RESEARCH ON WE CAN'T GET OUR
FAIR SHARE IF WE DON'T APPLY
FOR THE FUNDING OR FOR NOT IN
THE GAME AND SO SOME OF OUR
RESEARCH SHOWED THAT IN FACT
WE HAVEN'T BEEN AS AGGRESSIVE
AS WE COULD BE OR SHOULD BE ON
MULTIPLE FRONTS OF FUNDING AND
SO AS THIS LAST YEAR OR SO HAS
MOVE FORWARD I THINK WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE GO AFTER THE
MONEY OUT WE MAY NOT ALWAYS
WIN BUT WE CAN'T COMPLAIN IF
WE DIDN'T EVEN APPLY IN THEN
WE CAN WORK ON THE APPLICATION
PROCESS AND MAKING IT A LITTLE
BIT MORE CENTRALIZED AND SO
FORTH ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO
HAS ATTENDED A PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR INFORMATION IF YOU'D LIKE
TO BE ALERTED TO OTHER TYPE
OF EVENTS WERE HAVING AND --
WE WILL CLOSE THE PANELISTS
PART AND LET PEOPLE LEAVE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO AND THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS US I
WILL BE HERE AND WE WILL BE
ON PUBLIC -- RECORDED A YOU
MAY JUST LINE UP AT THE MIKE
YEAH
THANK YOU MY ASSEMBLYMAN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN SHARON QUIRK
SILVA -- MY NAME IS MARGARET
TO GANG IS BORN IN ANAHEIM IS
NOT MY KHN YES YES OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU MAYOR -- I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT LAST WEEK CITY
COUNCIL MEETING IN THE CITY
OF ANAHEIM WHICH WAS FORMALLY
KNOWN AS THE CITY OF KINDNESS
-- THEY TABLES FOR ITEMS
THAT POTENTIALLY WOULD HELP
-- RENTERS AT THAT RENTAL A
PAUSE ON ALL ON COMMUNITY AND
RUNNERS IN APARTMENT BUILDINGS
AND WHATNOT ACROSS THE CITY
AND THEY OPPOSED -- THIS THESE
MEASURES AND TABLE DOWN WHICH
MEANS WE'LL NEVER HEAR FROM
AGAIN AND POTENTIALLY PUTTING
PEOPLE OUT IN THE STREET AND
POSSIBLY -- EVEN DEATH BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN THEIR EIGHTIES ON FIXED
INCOMES THAT ARE ON MEDICATIONS
OF VARIOUS TYPES AND -- IT'S
COMING DOWN TO THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE BASICALLY PUTTING THEM
ON AND ON AND -- ICEBERG AND
PUTTING THEM OUT TO SEE WHAT
THEY OLD ESKIMO -- TRADITION
WAS BACK IN YEARS PAST THAT --
YOUR SENTENCING THESE PEOPLE
TO TO ANSWER CERTAIN FUTURE
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS ADDRESS
THIS -- SITUATION BECAUSE
AS WERE WERE STRIVING TO END
HOMELESSNESS OUR GOVERNMENT
ITSELF IS CREATING MORE
HOMELESSNESS SO PLEASE -- HELP
US WITH THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND WHAT PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE WON'T BE ENGAGED IN WILL
JUST ACKNOWLEDGES MY NAME IS
LOOKING REPAIRS STARTED RANCHO
SENIOR ACTION COMMITTEE AND
RENTAL A PAUSE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE SAME THING MOST OF
THE SENIOR CITIZENS ON THE
PART THAT I LIVE IN WILL BE
HOMELESS WITHIN THREE YEARS
BECAUSE THE INCREASE IN ARRESTS
IS GOING TO BE APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH AND
SOCIAL SECURITY IS NOT GOING
TO TAKE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
OWN THEIR HOMES AND RENT A DIRT
WE'RE NOT ASKING YOU TO BUILD
MORE HOMES WE'RE NOT ASKING YOU
TO BUILD STRUCTURES ARE CONDOS
OR WHATEVER WE'RE ASKING YOU
TO PROTECT THE HOUSES THAT LOW
INCOME PEOPLE ALREADY LIVE IN
DO SOMETHING FROM THE STATE
TO PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE NOW
YOU THINK IT'S EXPENSIVE TO
HAVE PEOPLE WITH DRUG PROBLEMS
ON THE STREET IMAGINE NINETY
AND A HUNDRED YEAR OLD PEOPLE
I MEAN WE'VE GOT PEOPLE LIKE
THAT THAT WILL BE ALMOST IN
THREE YEARS GOT TO STOP THE
PREDATORY BUYERS FROM PUTTING
THE SENIORS OUT OF THEIR HOMES
MARKET RATE WILL NOT CORRECT
THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
HI JOANNA SELENA AND THE
PRESIDENT CYPRESS COLLEGE THANK
YOU SHERRIN FOR PUTTING THIS
ON AND THINK YOU ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WHO ATTENDED TODAY
-- SO ONE THING I DIDN'T HEAR
TODAY I DID HEAR FROM MISTER
EWING ABOUT THAT ACADEMIA NEEDS
TO BE PART OF THIS AND I REALLY
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE ARE VERY VERY EAGER TO
PARTNER WITH OUR CITIES AND OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO HELP TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
I A FEW PEOPLE TALK TODAY
ABOUT THE PREVENTATIVE HEART
OF HOMELESSNESS AND I BELIEVE
THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
PREVENTATIVE PIECE OF THAT
YOU KNOW OUR STUDENTS ARE POR
THE NOT ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
STUDENT COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
POOR BUT MANY OF THEM ARE AND
WE ARE EDUCATING THE FUTURE AND
THEY LITERALLY CANNOT AFFORD
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND TO LIVE
IN ORANGE COUNTY ANYMORE AND
SO WE ARE DESPERATELY TRYING
TO FIND WAYS TO HOUSE THEM OUR
STUDENTS A RECENT SURVEY FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
SURVEYED SAID THAT THEY HAD
EXPERIENCE HOUSING AND SECURITY
IN THE LAST YEAR THAT MEANS
THEY DIDN'T HAVE STABLE HOUSING
OR IS STAYING WITH FRIENDS
FAMILIES COUCH SURFING SOME IN
CARS THIRTEEN PERCENT SAID THEY
WERE HOMELESS -- WE HAD ANOTHER
RECENT SURVEY ON OUR FACILITIES
-- PLAN AND THE NUMBER ONE
THING THAT PEOPLE ASK FOR
IS STUDENT HOUSING WE DO NOT
HAVE THE DEEP POCKETS EITHER
TO BUILD AND TO BUY IN THE IN
THE CYPRESS AREA SPECIFICALLY
BUT WE DO FEEL THAT WE CAN
SOLVE THIS WITH PARTNERING
WITH OUR CITIES I WANT TO
COMMEND THE CITY OF WHEN A
PARK WE ARE ACTIVELY DISCUSSING
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THEM MAYOR
BROWN HAS BEEN FABULOUS THANK
YOU MAYOR BROWN JIM VANDERPOOL
RUBEN LOPEZ AND COUNCILMAN
TROUT SPECIFICALLY AND WE ARE
VERY VERY EAGER TO PARTNER
AND TO FIND SOLUTIONS WITH
OUR -- WITH HER POLITICIANS
AND OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO THANK YOU FOR
ACT FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
ON THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HARRY
LINEBACKER I LIVE IN FULLERTON
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
RECUPERATIVE CARE EARLIER THIS
YEAR I WAS SIGNING PEOPLE AND
AT THE FULLERTON ARMORY AND
A GUY CAME IN AND -- STARTED
COMPLAINING THAT HE'S JUST BEEN
DISCHARGED FROM THE HOSPITAL
AFTER AFTER ONE DAY THERE ARE
LESS AND -- HE WASN'T WELL AND
WHILE HE WAS IN THERE THEY ARE
THROWN AWAY ALL OF HIS WORLDLY
BELONGINGS AS HE PUT IT SO
VERY WAS OUR WITH CLOTHES ON
HIS BACK IN A NUMBER ALLEN HE
SPENT A FEW HOURS LYING ON THE
CONCRETE FLOOR IN THE ARMORY
AND WAS PUT BACK ON THE STREET
BEFORE DAWN THE NEXT MORNING
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF -- ONE OF
THE TEN PERCENT OF CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT CAN END UP
COSTING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR -- IN BECAUSE
HE IS HEALTH WERE DETERIORATE
AND HE'LL BE BACK AGAIN SO
I I WANT TO MENTION THAT THE
CITY OF FULLERTON TONIGHT WILL
BE VOTING ON A PARTNERSHIP
WITH ILLUMINATION FOUNDATION
-- TO DEVELOP A SHELTER AND
THE FIRST PHASE WILL INCLUDE
SIXTY BEDS OF RECUPERATIVE
CARE -- THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT COULD END UP PAYING FOR
ITSELF WHITE QUICKLY -- IT'S
FUNDED BY OF FULLER TENS
-- FUNDS THAT COME FROM THE
STATE AND OF FROM ELIMINATION
FOUNDATIONS ON FUNDS ARE SO
I HOPE SAID ARE THE STATE CAN
ARE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
AND I HOPE OUR PEOPLE CAN
COME TO FOURTEEN CITY COUNCIL
TONIGHT AND SUPPORT THIS OUR
HUMANITARIAN AND COST EFFECTIVE
MEASURES THANK YOU THANK YOU
DAVE DURAN WITH HOUSING
IS A HUMAN RIGHT ORANGE
COUNTY AND IT'S BEEN A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
LISTEN TO EVERYONE TODAY
MOVING FORWARD ON THE PREMISE
THAT WHAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
IN THE SYSTEM THAT IS ARGUABLY
BROKEN AND ALREADY ESTABLISHED
ONE OF THE ISSUES IN ADDRESSING
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE
-- RESISTANT TO CARE -- AS
WAS BROUGHT UP HAS TO DO A LOT
WITH WHAT IS ALREADY IN PLACE
FOR EXAMPLE SHELTERS WILL JUST
USE THAT AS AN EXAMPLE THERE
REALLY IS NO OVERSIGHT CHAU
POTENTIALLY LICENSING SHELTERS
TO BE THE SHELTER THAT THEY'RE
DESIGNED TO BE WELL ALONG WITH
THE SERVICES ALONG WITH THE
PROPER CARE ALONG WITH GOOD
FOOD ALONG WITH IT YOU KNOW AND
CENTER AT CETERA ETCETERA SO --
POSSIBLY SOMETHING OF THAT SORT
TO BRING UP THE LEVEL OF CARE
IN THOSE SHELTERS -- THEN I
THINK WE COULD FIND THAT PEOPLE
ARE NOT SHELTER RESISTANT IF
YOU WILL BECAUSE THERE THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO
SOME PLACE FOR HELP MUCH LIKE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ILL PHYSICALLY
THAT THEY WANT TO GO TO A
HOSPITAL BECAUSE THERE'S GOING
TO GET SOME HELP THERE -- SO
OBVIOUSLY OVERLY COMPLICATED
BUT -- HOPE LOOK MAYBE TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DAISY CHÁVEZ -- I AM A RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF ANAHEIM I'M
ALSO A POLICY FELLOW WITHIN
ARGUES AN AGING AIRPORT IS
ORGANIZATION BASED OUT OF LA
CALLED INITIATE JUSTICE THAT
SEEKS TO AND MASS INCARCERATION
-- BY ACTIVATING THE POWER
PEOPLE WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY IT -- I JUST WANT
TO QUICKLY SHARE THAT -- AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD SEVERAL A
LOVED ONES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY INCARCERATION AND -- JUST
SEEING HOW -- THE RE ENTRY
PROCESS HAS BEEN DIFFICULT
FOR THEM -- I DO THINK THAT
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR --
THE COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THE
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT COME
INTO PLAY WHEN IT COMES TO --
WHAT CAUSES -- HOMELESSNESS AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE OF THE A
-- PEOPLE TESTIFIED TODAY WHO
BROUGHT TO THAT TO LIGHT --
I HAVE A PARTNER WHO HAD BEEN
INCARCERATED FOR SIX YEARS --
CAME HOME TWO YEARS AGO FOUND
A JOB AND I WAS THE ONLY PERSON
WHO WAS ABLE TO SUPPORT HIM
AND IN WATCHING HOW -- WHEN HE
LOST HIS JOB THE -- THE KIND
OF THE DOWN FALL THAT HE HAD
-- JUST REALLY BROUGHT TO LIGHT
HOW AT MEMBERS OF HIS FAMILY
HIMSELF ZERO ARE IMPACTED BY
THIS SO I REALLY WOULD LIKE
-- FOR YA THE MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE -- TO
CONSIDER -- HOW WE CAN HELP
FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE RE ENTRY
PROCESS -- BECAUSE I THINK --
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT REALLY
IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO HELP THEM REENTER SOCIETY
AND NOT FALL INTO -- THE YOU
KNOW THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU
HELLO MADAM CHAIR THINK YOU ARE
MANY MISS MINOR WORK FOR ALL
CORD A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
IN ORANGE COUNTY -- I AM A
MILLENNIAL TO OUR HOUSE GRAY
HAIR BY THE SORT OF STORY --
I'M HERE TO SAY TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR PUTTING A FACE
TO THIS THIS ISSUE THE HOMELESS
ISSUE GRAY ASKS YOU HAD SAID
HOMELESS IS A SYMPTOM -- AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS HOMELESS AT
SIXTEEN EXITING FROM A MENTAL
HEALTH INSTITUTE AFTER MY FIRST
ATTEMPT I REALIZED THERE IS
AN ISSUE THE ISSUE IS -- THERE
THERE'S A NEED TO SHIFT FROM
OUT REACHING TO ENGAGING YOU
KNOW -- OUR SYSTEM HOW IT FELT
TO ASK -- FOLKS WHO REFUSED
CARE OWN NO WHO CHOOSE TO
SLEEP IN PARK BENCH OR OTHERS
TO SEE ASK THEM WHAT THEY NEED
AND SERVE SAYING HERE LET ME
HELP YOU ON THE OTHER ISSUE AS
WELL AS THIS REALLY NAMING THE
ROOT CAUSE AS WE SAID EARLIER
HOMELESSNESS IS A SYMPTOM NOT
ROUTE BECAUSE THE ROOT CAUSES
THE COST OF LIVING -- AS THE
AS THE USE MY DREAM OF BUYING
A HOUSE IS NO LONGER THERE I
CAN I CAN NEVER HOPE TO REALLY
HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE ON MY
OWN AND SO I NEEDED FURTHER
PROTECTION THOUGH YOU YOU HAVE
NOT ASKED WHY NEED OR THAT
THIS COUNCIL I'M NOT ASK FOR
WHAT I NEED -- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THERE NEED TO BE A MORE LOCKER
IS PLANNED YOU KNOW I WANT TO
UPLIFT THE STORIES OF FOLKS
TO WORK FIFTY SIXTY HOURS TO
JOBS AND STILL YET STRUGGLES
TO SERVE LIVED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I WANNA UP LIFT
THE FOLKS WHO CANNOT GET BACK
TO SCORE IS REALLY TRYING
TO REALLY HARD TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AND INCREASED THEIR
THEIR JOBS OR BE ABLE TO A
BETTER LIVING AND I ALSO WANTED
TO PUSH FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
EASE OUR LOCAL LEADERS AND
US WALLACE YOU ALL TO HAVE
OUR LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE TO
DEVELOPING -- ALL OF OUR NEEDS
WITHIN THE HOUSING AS WELL AS
PROTECTING OUR SENIORS SAVOR
SENIORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
HEY SAMANTHA MEMBERS YES I
JUMP THE CITY OF CYPRESS AS
WELL THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS TODAY AND AT PRESENT THE
CITY'S PERSPECTIVE AS YOU HEARD
THAT -- CONSISTENT FUNDING IS
WHAT IS WILL REALLY HELP US WE
HAVE SOME VERY GREAT SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY PUBLIC SAFETY TASK FORCE
HAS BEEN A WONDERFUL SUCCESS
A GREAT PARTNERSHIP AND THEY
WERE IN THE THIRD YEAR OF THAT
AND I BELIEVE IT RIGHT NOW
SAID TO TERMINATE NEXT YEAR
AND SO HAVING ASSURANCE THAT
FUNDING STREAMS LIKE THAT ARE
GOING FORWARD WILL ALLOW US TO
DO THE STAFFING AND AND ALLOW
FOR THE PUBLIC ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
SOMETHING TO PLAN FOR THEIR
FUTURE AND THE AND THEN SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE THE CITY WERE
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING WE'VE
ENTERED INTO THE AGREEMENT
WITH THE NORTH SPA AND WE HAVE
A LONG TERM AGREEMENT TO TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
WINTER PARKA PLACENTIA FACILITY
SO WE'RE WE'RE COMMITTED TO
HELPING YOU KNOW YOUR SHARE
-- BUT I JUST WANT TO RE
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
STABLE FUNDING STREAMS AND
AND CLEAR DELINEATION BETWEEN
ROLES RESPONSIBILITIES OR
REALLY ALLOW US TO BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU THANK YOU
HELLO ASSEMBLY WILL MENTION
COOKS UP A MY NAME IS LAUREN
AMERICA'S AND I'M A STUDENT
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON I'M
STANDING POLITICAL SCIENCE
AND I VERY QUICKLY WANTED TO
ADDRESS -- TWO THINGS THAT
IN MY OPINION WE'RE KIND
OF BY PASS I'M TODAY AT THE
FIRST BEING WE REALLY FOCUSED
-- ON THEIR RE ENTRY AT THE
CRIMINALIZATION AND ALSO MENTAL
HEALTH WE FORGOT TO FOCUS
ON A LOT OF JUST ORDINARY
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE HERE
TODAY WE LIVE OFF OF FIXED
INCOME AND CALIFORNIA UNLIKE
ANY OTHER STATE BESIDES FLORIDA
AND NEW YORK ARE MEDIAN INCOME
AS MENTIONED VERY BRIEFLY IS
THIRTY FIFTY PERCENT OF WHAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE MAKING AND
STATISTICALLY ONE SAYS MEDIAN
INCOME SURPASSES THIRTY PERCENT
WE SEE A SIPS OF BRENDA'S HER
A RISE IN HOMELESSNESS AND
I THINK WE CAN IT GREATLY --
ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE BY PASSING
THE LEGISLATION REGARDING
MEDIAN INCOME AND THAT IS
GOING TO REALLY HELP PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS FROM THE SIDE OF
ORDINARY CONSTITUENTS -- WHO
ARE ON FIXED INCOME SECONDLY
THING I WANTED TO ADDRESS --
IS THIS WE STILL HAVE THIS
NEGATIVE CONNOTATION AYE AYE
AND I KIND OF EVEN SEE IT FROM
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE BEING
ASKED -- HOW DO WE FORCE THESE
HOMELESS PEOPLE TO GET HELP AND
WE WE CAN'T FORCE THESE PEOPLE
TO GET HELP WE HAVE TO THINK
OF THESE THEY ARE PEOPLE AND
WE CAN WE CAN WE TREAT THEM
LIKE SECOND CLASS CITIZENS IT
WOULD CRIMINALIZE THE HOMELESS
AND WE NEED TO REALLY FOCUS
ON THE CONSTITUENTS SITE
AND A LEGISLATIVE SIDE -- WE
CAN'T FORCE THESE PEOPLE WE
NEED TO BE MORE SYMPATHETIC
AN ASTRAL A WHAT DO THEY NEED
WATER WHAT ARE THESE WHAT
ARE THEY SUFFERING AND WE
JUST AS THIS IS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND THAT THANK YOU
HELLO I'M PAT DAVIS I LIVE
IN ANAHEIM ALSO A PART OF
HOUSING IS HUMAN RIGHT ORANGE
COUNTY I'VE BEEN AN ADVOCATE
FOR ALMOST THREE YEARS SPENT
MY WORKING CAREER AND HIGHER
ED AND I SEE WHERE THESE TWO
ISSUES TO COME TOGETHER I
WANTED TO DRAW TO THE ISSUES
THAT MICHELLE BROUGHT UP IN
OTHERS THAT ZONING ISSUES
AND LAND USE I THINK ARE THE
PRIMARY WAYS IN WHICH THE STATE
CAN HOLD CITIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR NOT TAKING SERIOUSLY THE
ARENA NUMBERS THE BUILDING
THAT GOES ON IS OFTEN MODERATE
UPPER INCOME LOW IN VERY
LOW ISN'T EVEN ON THE RADAR
AND THEY BRAG ABOUT IT I'VE
HEARD OUR OWN CITY PLANNER
DEPARTMENT HEAD SPEAK TO WE
DON'T TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY
THAT WAS MOST TROUBLESOME NOR
WOULD HE TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
PART OF THE ISSUE WITH THE
DIALOGUE -- IN ADDITION THERE
WAS A LOT OF DEPTH AND WHAT
WE HEARD TODAY THERE WAS ALSO
SOME VERY OVER SIMPLISTIC
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS BOTH
BY THOSE INFORMED AND OTHERS
I THINK THE NOTION THAT A
ONE DAY RELATIONSHIP CHANGES
ANYTHING YOU SPOKE TO THAT
QUITE WELL AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND ALSO THE NOTION THAT
FORTY PERCENT THAT FRIGHTENS
ME AS ADVOCATES YOU GIVE US
THOSE MOTEL VOUCHERS AND WE'LL
GET FOLKS AND MOTELS THANK YOU
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
MELISSA CHINCHILLA AND I'M
HERE WITH ULTIMATE HEALTH
SERVICES -- I'M A RESEARCHER
WITH ULTIMATE HEALTH SERVICES
FOCUSED ON HOMELESSNESS AND THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
A WITH A SPECIFIC FOCUS LOOKING
OUT LATINO HOMELESSNESS --
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONVENIENCE
TODAY'S MEETING TO BRING UP
SOME IMPORTANT ISSUES HERE
THROUGHOUT ORANGE COUNTY
-- I ALSO WANTED TO MAKE A
POINT REGARDING SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE EARLIER
REGARDING SERVICE CONNECTION
SO WE KNOW THAT A LACK OF
SERVICE CONNECTION OFTEN POINTS
OF BROKEN SOCIAL SYSTEM SO
I WANT TO REALLY EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF TAKING A
DEEPER LOOK AT WHY INDIVIDUALS
MAY NOT BE CONNECTING TO
SERVICES FOR INSTANCE WE KNOW
THAT ALSO MADE A LOT OF THE
PATIENTS THAT WERE SEEN THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED AS HOMELESS BE
BROUGHT UP CONCERNS REGARDING
PUBLIC CHARGE -- I'M SURE YOU
AS WELL AS OTHERS ARE AWARE OF
THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO PUBLIC
CHARGE AND THIS HAS LED TO
A LOT OF SERVICES ENGAGEMENT
AMONG NON CITIZENS AND MAKE
STATUS HOUSEHOLDS ARE WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
STIGMA SOMETIMES REGARDING THE
RECEIPT OF HOMELESS SERVICES
SO THAT'S ALSO SOMETHING ALSO
CONSIDER HARLEY SERVICES BEING
FRAME POWER INDIVIDUALS BEING
OUT EACH TO -- IS THE OUR
REACH CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
AN AYE LASTLY I JUST WANT TO
BRING ATTENTION TO THE NEED TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW SERVICES
ARE CURRENTLY BEING PROVIDED
WE KNOW THERE ARE CHALLENGES
TO ENTRY INTO SHELTERS FOR
INSTANCE -- THE ISSUE WAS
BROUGHT UP EARLIER WITH REGARDS
TO FAMILY SEPARATION -- A
LOT OF FEAR WITH REGARD TO
ENTERING SHELTER SYSTEMS THE
SHELTER AS BEING AN UNSAFE
SPACE FOR SOME INDIVIDUALS
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR SILVA
AND -- THANK YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING THE
SUPPORT DISCUSSION HERE TO
ORANGE COUNTY JUST QUICKLY
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
THINGS YOU MENTION WHAT CAN
WE DO IN SACRAMENTO -- WE
TALKED ABOUT THE ALIGNMENT
OF PROGRAMS ELEVEN THE
FUNDING IS CRUCIAL EIGHT CD
AND TELEVISION HAVE PROBABLY
OVERS ON NOVEMBER TWENTY A
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE TO APPLY SEPARATELY SO
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS I THINK
IS CRUCIAL ALSO HAVING THE
STATE HAVE A CONCRETE PLAN WE
HEAR THE GOVERNOR SAYING THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION HOMES BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HOW MANY
OF THOSE HOMES ARE GOING TO
BE AFFORDABLE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION I WOULD SAY TWO MILLION
WE HEAR FROM OUR COMMUNITY THAT
HOUSING IS BEING BUILT BUT IT'S
NOT HOUSING THAT PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD WE NEED TARGETED HOUSING
THAT IS GOING TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITIES HEARING
AND ORANGE COUNTY AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL ALSO THE ISSUE OF
FOR A LOCAL FUNDING SOURCES
COME OUT TO HELP LOCAL CITIES
AND I WOULD JUST SAY ALSO I
WOULD INVITE YOU AND OTHER
FOLKS IN SACRAMENTO LOOK AT
ORANGE COUNTY AND ASK US WHAT
WE CAN DO BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
ASKING THE STATE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT WE DON'T
HAVE A LOCAL FUNDING SOURCE
HERE AS IS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
PRESENTATION BY MISS ANGLE
THERE ARE MANY COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE PUT HOUSING BONDS ON THE
BALLOT TO BE ABLE TO APPROVE
HOUSING IN AND TO FIND HOUSING
LOCALLY -- THERE'S ALSO LOCAL
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS THAT GO ON
THAT AS WE HAVE A NOW ANALYZE
A LAST PROGRESS REPORT FROM
ALL THE CITIES THAT WENT UP TO
EIGHT CITY IN APRIL -- UNDER
HEALTHY ELEMENTS THERE'S OVER
PRODUCTION ON MODERATE ABOUT
MODERATE BUT THE LONG VERY
LOW IS NOT BEING MET NOT EVEN
A FRACTION OF IT SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND -- FOR ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES HERE YOU SO MUCH
-- WITHOUT OUR FINAL SPEAKER
I'LL JUST CLOSE MY WITH A VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS IN THE SENSE
THAT OF WHAT I'VE WILL TAKE
AWAY FROM THIS BECAUSE AS SOME
OF YOU MAY KNOW WATCHING THE
LEGISLATURE MANY TIMES THINGS
ARE BROUGHT TO US AND THEN WE
VOTE ON THEM AND SAME THING
WITH COUNCIL WE DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE THE CAPACITY WITHIN OUR
SCHEDULES TO BECOME COMPLETELY
ENGAGE AN ISSUE WHERE WE'RE
LEARNING EVERY DAY AND TO BE
HONEST THE MORE WE LEARN THE
BETTER WE ARE AT OUR JOBS SO I
TAKE THIS ISSUE VERY SERIOUSLY
AND ONE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO HAVE TO
BE TALKING ABOUT HOW HOUSING
WE CANNOT TO AS WAS NOTED
SHELTERS ARE A PART OF THE THE
TEMPORARY SOLUTION BUT ANALYSTS
WE BUILD HOUSING AND WE BUILD
THE RIGHT TYPE OF HOUSING
THAT -- IS NOT ONLY GOING TO
COMPLEMENT THE CITY -- THAT
IS HOSTING THE HOUSING BUT
-- THAT THE CONSTITUENTS CAN
AFFORD WE WILL FIND OURSELVES
HAVING THE SAME CONVERSATION
IN TEN YEARS AS I WAS ON A
SKAGGS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
I WAS IN DEEPLY INVESTED IN
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION WE
HAD THIS CONVERSATION AND --
AND SOMEBODY WHO SERVED FAR
LONGER THAN I AM THE MAYOR HERE
ARE BROWN WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT RAIN AND NUMBERS AND HOW
DO WE NOT ONLY BUILD THAT BUILD
SO THAT FAMILIES CAN AFFORD AND
WHERE I CAN GET VERY TESTY IS
WHEN WE HAVE -- SOME ELECTED
BODIES THAT WILL LOOK AT EVERY
WAY NOT TO DO WHAT IS PRESENTED
TO THEM WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
LITIGATION WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
IT'S NOT OUR PROBLEM SOMEBODY
ELSE'S AND THAT BECOMES AN
ISSUE THAT WE ALL DEAL WITH
SO -- I'D LIKE TO END ON A
POSITIVE NOTE I DO SEE OPTIMISM
OUT THERE ARE SO AND -- YOU SAW
SEVERAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WERE PUT FORWARD --
SOME OF THOSE HAVE NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED YET AS JANUARY ONE
WILL BE THE DATE SOME OF THIS
WILL BEGAN A ONE THING THAT WE
DID NOT TALK ABOUT AT ALL THAT
I FELT WAS A BRIGHT SPOT IN THE
STATE WAS AD USE OR ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS AND THAT TO IS
USING EXISTING LAND RESIDENTIAL
HOMES WITHIN A CERTAIN CRITERIA
THAT THEY MEET TO HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY ON BUILDING NOW
AS WE SAID EARLIER BECAUSE I'M
SEEING THE ANAHEIM MAYOR HERE
IS SOMETIMES ONE THING LEADS TO
UNDERTAKEN IN CONSEQUENCE WHICH
COULD BE PARKING ISSUES AND SO
FORTH BUT IF WE CAN USE -- LAND
BUT TO NOW HOW IS OTHER PEOPLE
THAT IS THE CHOICE THERE IS
MORE FLEXIBILITY NOW WITH THOSE
BILLS SO IF YOU'RE REALLY INTO
THAT KIND OF DEVELOPMENT LOOK
THOSE UP -- SECONDLY IS SURPLUS
LAND THE STATE HAS SURPLUS LAND
WE HAVE MANY ACRES OF SURPLUS
LAND AND MATTER OF FACT WE'RE
IN THE BUSINESS UP AND TELL
A GOOD HANDFUL OF YEARS AGO
OF OF NOT GIVING IT AWAY BUT
TAKING THE RESPONSIBILITY FROM
THE STATE AND MOVING IT TO
ANOTHER ENTITY WHETHER IT BE A
COLLEGE OR A COUNTY NOW ALL OF
A SUDDEN WE REALIZE WELL THIS
IS VERY VALUABLE SO WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN ACRES OF
COUNTY LAND WHICH IS KNOWN AS
THE FAIRVIEW LAND IN WE ARE
GOING TO LOOK FORWARD AND I'M
GOING TO BE RELENTLESS ABOUT
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
AND WE CANNOT WALK AWAY SO
MENTAL HEALTH IS ONE TYPE OF
HOUSING THERE'S ALSO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE THERE'S DISABLED
HEALTH AND WITH A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN ACRES THERE'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF POSSIBILITIES BUT
IT TAKES THE WILL IT TAKES
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT ONLY LEADING BUT THAT ARE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO STOP
FIGHTING US AT EVERY STEP SO
WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE THIS
HEARING AND ALWAYS HOPE YOU
STAY ENGAGED IN THIS AND WE
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR TIME
THREE HOURS THANK YOU SO MUCH